Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du hast das Buch gelesen. Bist du in einer Aufbruchstimmung?
Überhaupt nicht.
Warum nicht? Nein, wir fangen natürlich vorne an. Also es ist ein junger Politikwissenschaftler unseren Alters ungefähr, glaube ich.
Kann sein, steht keine Zahl da, aber er ist jung, für sein Fach ist er bestimmt ganz jung.
Auf dem Sprung ins Professorenamt. Ja. Und er hat ein Buch über die Demokratiedämmerung geschrieben.
Bei Suhrkamp erschienen, Suhrkamp Wissenschaft, diese honorige Reihe. Und sehr viel, was hier zitiert wird, ist auch schon in dieser Reihe erschienen. Aber er, Veith Selk, stellt sich quer zu dem, was dort vor allem publiziert wurde. Da fallen große Namen runter wie Chantal Muff, Jürgen Habermas. Manches wird aber auch zustimmen, zitiert zum Beispiel Niklas Luhmann hin und wieder. Aber es ist kein soziologisches.
Zwei Erwähnungen.
Wir sagen hier ganz deutlich, das muss man vielleicht dem Soziologen Stefan Schulz auch kurz mitteilen. Es ist ja das Buch eines Politikwissenschafts, nicht das Buch eines Soziologen. Jetzt sagt nicht gleich, und das ist das Problem.
Das ist das Problem.
Naja, also wir müssen ja gucken. Jede Fakultät macht ja das, was sie kann. Ja, also ich kann ja jetzt auch nicht mich in die deutsche Bahn setzen und sagen, ich wäre gern mitgeflogen.
Ja, aber irgendwann kann man aus der Kutsche aussteigen und ins Auto ein.
Okay, also wir fangen mal so an. Der Titel ist provokant und zugleich würden wir sagen, ja, wir haben es auch so ein bisschen im Gefühl. Also irgendwas dämmert da. Die Demokratie ist jedenfalls nicht mehr so selbstverständlich, wie sie vielleicht vor 20 Jahren oder 25 Jahren noch gewesen ist. Woran liegt das, kann man sich fragen. Und welche Rolle spielt dabei die Demokratie-Theorie? Das heißt also, welche Rolle spielt die akademische Diskussion über die Demokratie? Und Veith Selk diagnostiziert jetzt sowohl der Demokratie-Eindämmerung, wie auch der Demokratie-Theorie eine Dämmerung bzw. ein Defizit. Oder, um es in seinen Worten zu sagen, die Demokratie-Theorien werden unplausibel. Deshalb, weil die Demokratie unglaublich viele Schwächen hat, viele Dilemata hat entstehen lassen in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten. Und eigentlich wissen die Demokratie-Theoretiker darauf keine Antwort. Und das zeigt er ihnen jetzt, dass sie eigentlich ziemlich nackt dastehen.
Ja, in dem Falle ist es so, ich habe mir in diesem Buch, sonst mache ich mir viele Notizen im Sinne von inspirative Gedanken, diesmal habe ich mir recht viel wortwörtlich rausgeholt, um das einfach hier, damit wir auch wissen, wie darüber gesprochen wird. Denn du hast jetzt schon zwei Sachen genannt, die natürlich ganz augenscheinlich sind, also die Demokratie und ihre wissenschaftliche Reflektion, also die Demokratie-Theorie. Er schreibt ja gleich zu Beginn, in der politikwissenschaftlichen und demokratie-theoretischen Literatur finden sich zunehmend Beiträge, die eine Verschlechterung der Rahmenbedingungen für demokratische Politik sowie eine krisenhafte Transformation liberal-demokratischer Regime diagnostizieren. Sie artikulieren Zweifel an der Stabilität und Legitimität. Und ich finde, hier braucht man noch eine dritte Dimension zwischen der gelebten Demokratie und ihrer Reflexion. Im akademischen Zirkel gibt es dazwischen noch, deswegen auch dieser interessante Begriff, diese Literatur. Denn die Demokratie-Theorie oder die Demokratie-Wissenschaft, was auch immer das ist, dient ja nicht immer nur, um wissenschaftliche Anschlüsse zu provozieren, um da irgendeinen Wissen weiterzubringen, sondern sie war auch entscheidend für den Ausbildungsbetrieb der Leistungsrollen. Also relativ viele Politikwissenschaftler werden dann tatsächlich Politiker oder Parteifunktionäre oder in irgendwelchen Mittelbauten, irgendwelche Stiftungen und so weiter. Plus nicht nur hat die Leistungsrolle davon profitiert, dass es so eine Reflektion gab und die man anschließen konnte, sondern auch das Publikum. Ja, also auch das Publikum bekommt immer wieder, wir sagen dann dispektierlich, Sonntagsreden, in denen nochmal idealtypisch dargestellt wird, was schön wäre und was aktuell das Problem ist und so weiter und so fort. Und nur, wenn man das mit in den Blick holt, finde ich, wäre überhaupt gerechtfertigt, von so etwas wie einer Demokratie-Theorie zu sprechen, denn ich würde es ansonsten immer soziologisch fragen, würden wir nicht einfach mal von einer politischen Theorie, von einer Politikwissenschaft, von Politiktheorien reden, statt immer gleich Demokratie.
Lass uns mal diese Differenz ganz kurz weiterverfolgen. Also eine Theorie des Politischen ist ja zum Beispiel das, was Karl Schmitt und auch die vielen, die ihm dann gefolgt sind, anbietet. Er stellt sich ja erst mal nicht die Frage, ist das demokratisch verfasst oder sonst was, sondern er fragt sich grundsätzlich, was ist das Politische? Und das ist die Unterscheidung zwischen Freund und Feind. Und das meine ich jetzt bei Karl Schmitt. Man hat eine homogene Gemeinschaft, zum Beispiel die deutsche Nation, und dann hat man draußen den Freund oder den Feind. Ja, das kann dann auch wechseln. Und das ist eine Theorie, die man aber auch aufs Inland übertragen kann. Also man kann, das ist ja eine Idee von Chantal Mouffe, die hier auch kurz rezipiert wird, auch diesen Freund-und-Feind-Konflikt in den Parlamentarismus übertragen. Karl Schmitt wäre nicht dafür, aber man kann das machen. Man sieht das am deutlichsten vielleicht, aber in den USA zwischen Demokraten und Republikanern, die stehen sich als Freund und Feind gegenüber, müssen aber aufgrund parlamentarischer Situationen und so immer wieder auch Kompromisse schließen. Und dann gibt es auch mit Parteien, innerhalb der Parteien verschiedene Differenzierungen. Aber diese politische Theorie an sich kann ja losgelöst von der Demokratie stattfinden, sondern dann geht es ja mehr um grundsätzliche Fragen der Macht und der politischen Organisation von Macht. Und eine dieser politischen Organisationen von Macht ist die demokratische Organisation. Und hier sagt jetzt Veith Selk, das will ich mir mal genauer anschauen, denn irgendwas liegt ja wohl im Argen. Also wenn selbst auch die Demokratie-Theoretiker selbst schon darüber befinden, dass etwas nicht so präsent ist. Er sagt, zum einen sind die demokratischen Regime einen Prozess unterworfen, den ich als Devolution bezeichne. Er zersetzt die Grundlagen demokratischer Politik und Legitimation. Zum anderen wird die Demokratie-Theorie als die zentrale theoretische Reflexionsinstanz der Demokratie infolge der Devolution unplausibel. Sie scheitert dabei, unsere politischen Regime, die wir aus normativen Gründen und Gewohnheitsmäßig als Demokratien bezeichnen, in wissenschaftlich valider Weise als Demokratien zu beschreiben. Die Demokratie-Theorie gerät dadurch in eine Paradigmakrise. Dazu kommt er dann immer wieder zurück, dass so eine Paradigmakrise da ist. Er bezieht sich auf den Wissenschaftshistoriker, Theoretiker Thomas S. Kuhn, der sagt, wenn so eine Paradigmakrise zu beobachten ist, dann könnte daraus auch ein Paradigmenwechsel folgen, eine wissenschaftliche Revolution. Aber dazu kommen wir später. Was wir, glaube ich, hier deutlich machen müssen fürs Publikum, wir haben es hier zwar mit einer akademischen Schrift zu tun, aber wir haben es hier, und das macht das Buch, finde ich, so genial, mit einem Buch zu tun, das für alle, auch die nie Politikwissenschaften studiert haben oder studieren wollten, interessant ist. Nämlich, ich glaube, dass hier so gut, wie ich es noch nie gelesen habe, wirklich die Demokratie mit ihren Schwächen aufgezeigt analysiert wird, hier eine große Dekonstruktionsleistung stattfindet.
Also, das ist genau der Punkt, an dem ich zum, also ja, zustimme, aber dann auch sage, die Schlüsse daraus müssten genau andersrum sein. Mag vielleicht noch überraschend klingen, ich werde es natürlich nachher ausführlich begründen, aber wenn man das, also man kann es, glaube ich, auch am Text herleiten. Wir können uns ja diese Zeit nehmen, diese Kapitel mal einzeln. Also, bevor es überhaupt erst um Phänomene des Niedergangs und dann seine Begriffsfindung, also der gegenteiligen Evolution, der Devolution geht, macht er ja oben ganz deutlich, wie der Zusammenhang ist zwischen Demokratie, in der wir leben und Demokratie, über die wir sprechen. Gibt es also Differenzen. Bislang war es so, wir hatten eine große Zukunftszauglichkeit. Demokratie, optimistische Progressionsthese nennt er das. Es war eigentlich die Demokratie eingebaut, dass wir damit gleichzeitig so eine Entwicklungsgeschichte, also eine Sonntagsrede beginnt üblicherweise mit den Gründungsvätern und so weiter. Und dann hat man einfach gesagt, alles geht in die richtige Richtung. Er kommt dann hier mit so Begriffen wie normativer Sperrklinkeneffekt. Also wenn erstmal das Bildungssystem richtig funktioniert und die Einkommen da sind, dann wird auch die Bewusstseinswertung, also alles stabilisiert sich so gegenseitig. Wir haben Selbstverbesserungen, Selbststabilisierungen, schreibt er in diesem ganzen Geflecht drin, dass heute, das hört man dann aus dem Text schon raus, so nicht mehr funktioniert. Also eine Annahme einer progressiven Bürgerkompetenz. Da mangelt es zum Beispiel, die haben wir heute schon nicht mehr. Also die Leute sind nicht per se überzeugte Demokraten und sagen dann, ja, da müsste man mit ihnen eine Stellschraube nochmal oder so. Das war mal zu der Zeit, als es hieß, naja, haben wir jetzt das Briefpapier auch für die privaten Unternehmungen oder ob man die Bereicherung über Flugmeilen, die man gesammelt hat, auch für den Urlaub nutzen darf. Da würde man sagen, ja, genau, das sind so diese kleinen, eigentlich ist alles stabil, es hält sich in der Waage. Und diese kleinen Sachen müssen wir noch ausmerzen und dann sind wir im, und so. Und heute haben wir ja solche Diskussionen nicht mehr. Also niemand tritt mal wegen irgendwas zurück, keiner übernimmt mehr Verantwortung. Es gibt Bereicherung überall. Kanzler, die eigentlich gar keine Kanzler mehr sind, machen plötzlich Außenpolitik im Kriegsfalle. Joachim Gauck, der gar kein Bundespräsident ist, hält trotzdem weiter Reden. Also lauter diese Entfranzungen einfach überall. Also ein Gefüge gerät hier auseinander. Er spricht so von kultureller Dynamik, ökonomischer Flexibilität, politischer Übersichtlichkeit, wurde propagiert in den Demokratie-Theorien und die Demokratie hält heute nicht mehr Schritt. Weshalb die, Zitat, Hintergrundannahme, dass es irgendwie schon gut wird, nicht mehr plausibel ist. Wir statten sie heute mit Skepsis aus. Wir sind in einem Strudel politischer Konflikte. Wir sind in Deutungs-Kontroversen. Alles, was Tinder fragt. Niemand glaubt mehr irgendetwas. Wir können uns nicht mal darauf einigen, in welchen Medien wir uns jetzt darüber informieren, was passiert, geschweige denn darüber, dass wir uns darauf verständigen. Das war einfach an. Nee, also davon ausgehen, alle akzeptieren erst mal das, was passiert, sondern plötzlich werden so Obskoritäts. Ich habe aber beim Telegram-Chat gelesen und so weiter. Warum macht ihr jetzt die Tagesschau nicht? Solche Sachen. Früher hat man gesagt, die Tagesschau hat nicht gebracht. Dann ist es Nonsens. Also Ciao und so. All diese Sachen funktionieren heute nicht mehr. Und das finde ich auch. Er macht es super plausibel. Ich hätte es mir noch ein bisschen empirischer gewünscht. Also er bleibt hier so sehr auf seinem Sohrkamp-Level. Irgendwie würde ich es mal so klassifizieren. Das hätte man ruhig noch so ein bisschen in den Alltag, in die Empirie runterbrechen können. Aber wir haben heute, und er schreibt dann, daraus ergibt sich insgesamt eine Demokratieskepsis. Und dann, ich werde im Folgenden argumentieren, dass die Skepsis begründet ist. Er möchte im Grunde einen Zeitgeist einfangen.
Ja.
Zum einen sind die demokratischen Regime einem Prozess unterworfen, den ich als Devolution bezeichne. Die Demokratie-Theorie, die zentralen theoretischen Reflexionsinstanzen der Demokratie. All das ist unplausibel. Und dann die von dir angesprochene Paradigmen-Krise, auf die das zuläuft. Und dann beginnt dieses Kapitel Phänomene des Untergangs. Auch hier, ich hätte mir mehr Empirie gewünscht, aber er nennt sie ja pflichtbewusst, also die EU allen voran. Ja, der Markt hat die Politik überwölbt.
Lass uns noch eine Sache vorher klären, indem wir sagen, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Fortschritt und Demokratie. Denn das ist ja etwas, was auch häufig zusammengedacht wird. Erinnert euch mal an all die Silicon Valley-Reden, wenn irgendetwas Neues vorgestellt wird. Dann heißt es nicht einfach nur, wir haben hier neues Produkt, das ist ganz modern, sondern damit demokratisieren wir auch den Büchermarkt, den was weiß ich. Man hat immer dieses Argument, es gibt etwas Neues, und das ist zugleich auch demokratieaffin oder demokratisierend. Und er sagt auch mit Verweis aus Samuel Huntington, nein, Modernisierung und Demokratisierung, die muss man analytisch auseinanderhalten, sonst kommt man nicht weiter. Denn enorme Fortschritte erleben wir und wir erleben auch gesellschaftliche Ausdifferenzierungen und gerade was Lebensziele anbelangt, hat ungeheure Fortschritte von der Ehe für alle, wie jetzt auch mit dem Selbstbestimmungsgesetz. Kann man ja nicht sagen, dass das alles regressiv ist. Ganz im Gegenteil, das ist fortschrittlich. Aber die Demokratie, die scheint sich in einer regressiven Phase zu befinden. Und dann zeigt er, wie ich finde, sehr schön auf, was dann eigentlich die Punkte sind. Und vielleicht sollen wir die mal durchgehen.
Lass mich eins noch sagen. Also bevor wir die Punkte durchgehen. Das, was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, das halte ich auch, man könnte heute nochmal, sollte vielleicht sogar ein eigenes Buch darüber schreiben. Der technologische Fortschritt wird nicht nur davon bedroht. Oder sagen wir mal, dieses Gefüge aus der technologischen Fortschritt führt gleichzeitig zu einer Mehrdemokratie, zu einer Demokratisierung. Das wird zum einen bedroht, weil in China, wir einfach sehen, das ist dort kein demokratisches Gefüge, sondern da wird einfach autoritär von oben bestimmt was Sache ist. Und dann wird einfach ausgerufen, 25 Schlüsseltechnologien usw. usf. Aber auch in der westlichen Welt. Wir haben gerade Angst davor, dass die nächsten großen künstlichen Intelligenzmodelle nicht so gut mehr funktionieren wie die alten, weil irgendwelche Leute irgendwelche demokratischen Ansprüche haben an Wissensbestände, die da nicht benutzt werden dürfen. Urheberrecht, an Personal, also ist doch meine Person, wieso kann das da einfach und so. Das sind ja alles ganz konkrete, echte Gerichtsprozesse, die jetzt gerade laufen. Und wir haben aus dieser Erfahrung mit Apple zum Beispiel, bei Apple wusste nicht mal der Kollege, mit dem man täglich essen war, woran man selber arbeitet, weil einfach im Arbeitsvertrag drin stand, du arbeitest hier am Apple-Car, du arbeitest an der Apple-Vision-Brot, du darfst niemandem davon berichten. Nicht mal deinen Mitarbeitern. Also Obskurität, etwas im juristischen Abseits zu entwickeln, sind Erfolgsmodelle, auch innerhalb von Demokratien. Also dass da immer automatisch so, ja, das ist alles demokratisch und so. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Die Demokratie ist ein Verzögerer, eine Bremse. Das macht alles länger weg. Wir wären mit dem wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt beim Thema Genforschung und so weiter viel schneller, wenn wir auf relativ viele demokratische Errungenschaften einfach mal verzichten würden. Und die Geschichte des Silicon Valley ist ja auch, dass man selbst beim Vertrieb, also nicht nur bei der Entwicklung, sondern man hat dann eine Uber-App, man hat dann eine Buchlese-App, man verkauft dir den Leuten und preist dort, baut quasi diese Demokratie-Rückschritte ein. Hier gehört das Buch nicht mehr, du kaufst nur noch eine Lizenz. Dein Fahrer, ja, keine Ahnung wer das ist, der ist bei uns nicht angestellt, wir vermitteln hier nur Fahrten und so. Also diese Rückschrittlichkeit über technischen Fortschritt sollte man sowieso mal als eigene Kulturgeschichte fassen. Er hat es hier so ein bisschen angedeutet, wir können es inspirativ herauslesen, aber ist glaube ich auch ein sehr großes Thema. Plus, das ist jetzt sozusagen die Drucksituation, die sowieso schon da ist in diesem Gefüge, macht er jetzt seine Liste. Er beginnt bei der EU, also Phänomene des Niedergangs. Die EU hat einfach den Markt gewähren lassen. Wir wissen aus vielen plausiblen Beschreibungen, dass es nicht einfach in den EU-Verträgen so drin steht, dass es ein neoliberales Projekt ist, sondern das ist einfach so passiert. Also da wurde einfach dem Druck nicht standgehalten. Das Regieren selbst, wir haben es zunehmend mit Informalisierung zu tun. Irgendwelche Netzwerke bauen, irgendwelche Governance-Strukturen. Und am Ende ist das Beraterbudget im Innenministerium größer als die Personalkosten, weil irgendwelche Gesetze in irgendwelchen Allianz- privaten Organisationen geschrieben werden, statt einfach in-house und so. Also wir haben da dieses Blurring of Lines, wie er es nennt. Prozesse entfernen sich von dem, wie man darüber redet, dass im Bundestag in der Aussprache alles schon geregelt ist und da nur noch sozusagen Signalworte hin und her geworfen werden. Verstehen wir eigentlich mittlerweile alle, aber das ist so beispielhaft, was er hier meint. Wir haben es auch bei der Publikumsansprache mit immer mehr informellen Meinungsbeeinflussungen zu tun. Es gibt gar nicht mehr die Große, der Kanzler hat gesagt, sondern der Kanzler hat gesagt, aber viel wichtiger ist, was sagt denn jetzt Julian Reichelt dazu? Und lauter solche Sachen. Also von überall kommt es in Bedrängnis. Wir haben es zunehmend mit misstrauischer, zivilgesellschaftlicher Gegenpolitik zu tun. Also gegen Institutionalisierung, antipolitische Opposition. Früher war die APO, die Außerparlamentarische, noch was Besonderes, heute ist es total normal. Sowohl im politischen als auch im medialen Prozess.
Versuchen wir das nochmal ein bisschen an den einzelnen Punkten festzumachen. Also ein Punkt ist Legitimationsprobleme durch Politisierung. Da denkt man doch erst mal, es ist doch gut, wenn die Gesellschaft politisiert ist. Und an sich war das ja auch mal ein emanzipatorisches Versprechen. Also wir kennen den Spruch, das Private ist politisch. Das war ein feministischer Slogan, der meinte zum Beispiel. Und deshalb, weil das Private politisch ist, brauchen wir dringend ein Gesetz, das Vergewaltigung in der Ehe verbietet. Das ist der emanzipatorische Impetus. Wenn aber alles politisch wird, alles private im Sinne von, du bist da ein Schnitzel, bist du etwa AfD-Wähler, dann bedeutet das natürlich etwas fundamental anderes.
Wenn du heute eine rote Kappe aufgehabt hättest, die Leute wären ausgerastet. Das wäre sofort eine politische Botschaft gewesen.
Ja, ich werde mir mal eine beschaffen. Er schreibt, Politisierung ergibt sich vielmehr emergent aus dem naturwüchsigen Zusammenspiel heterogener politischer Kräfte. Sie folgt keinem übergreifenden Plan oder einer zentralen Koordination, sondern ist das Resultat eines unkoordinierten Zusammenwirkens. Das ist also ganz wichtig. Diese Politisierung hat nicht irgendjemand losgetreten oder steuert sie, sondern die ist durch verschiedene technische Möglichkeiten, durch eine Ausdifferenzierung der Gesellschaft entstanden. Er sagt, mehrdimensionale Probleme sind Probleme, die nicht nur unterschiedliche Lösungsmöglichkeiten zulassen, sondern auch aus anderer Perspektive betrachtet, selbst als Lösung beschrieben werden. Das klingt jetzt sehr abstrakt, können wir aber ganz deutlich machen. Wir reden darüber, wie kann man es schaffen, dass die deutsche Migrationspolitik nicht migrationsfeindlich wird, während jetzt ein AfD-Wähler sagt, ja, euer Problem ist meine Lösung, die deutsche Politik muss migrationsfeindlich sein. Und das kann man jetzt auf ganz viele Punkte natürlich herunterbrechen. Und das bedeutet, dass man verschiedene Revolten laufend in der Demokratie hat, zum Beispiel die rechtspopulistische Revolte. Und damit wird also auch plötzlich etwas geschaffen, was vorher nicht da war, nämlich ein politisiertes Institutionengerüst. Die Institutionen haben wir als neutral erlebt oder ja leidlich neutral. Es gab natürlich auch immer Kritik an Einflussnahmen oder so etwas. Aber wenn man plötzlich sagt, das öffentlich-rechtliche ist links-grün versifft, dann hat man eine Hyper-Politisierung vorgenommen dieser Institution. Hat eine Politisierung dieser Institution vorgenommen. Und das kann dann für Gerichte genauso gelten. Denken wir daran, was Trump gemacht hat mit den Gerichten in den USA. Was da auch noch folgen wird, wenn er wieder Präsident wird. Das heißt, auch diese ganzen demokratischen Institutionen werden extrem politisch aufgeladen. Und das sorgt also dafür, dass gewisse Prozesse demokratisch nicht mehr ablaufen können.
Dazu möchte ich schon mal anmerken, worauf meine Argumentation nachher auch hinausläuft. Diese Verwunderung darüber kann überhaupt nur möglich sein, wenn man vorher mit verherrlichenden Theorien und Vorstellungen herangegangen ist. Also eine Institution ist per Definition einfach eine Ansammlung von Erwartungen, die man so hat. Sie steht also niemals neutral im Raum. Und selbst wenn man die Idee hat, es ist eine Institution, also erwarte ich Neutralität, ja, das ist eben eine Erwartung, die man so hat und die konnte auch plausibilisiert werden. Nur es soll doch niemand behaupten, dass dieses Phänomen, Christian Drosten ruft das erste Mal in seinem Leben eine Polizei, weil er beleidigt wird, geht dann vor Gericht und stellt dort fest, ach, der Richter ist auch der Meinung, dass man hier mal noch eine innerliche Aufklärung. Ich hab gedacht, ich bin hier von einer neutralen Instanz. Diese Erfahrung hat man, egal welche Sonntagsredenverherrlichung stattfand, schon immer so gemacht. Jeder, der vor Gericht plötzlich mal tatsächlich ist, ist ernüchtert und er überrascht, dass er nicht im Fernsehen vor so einer... Also Krankenhäuser, die Institutionen, die wir so kennen, das Krankenhaus, das Gericht, das Parlament, wurde bislang immer verherrlicht. Vielleicht ist das ja ein Problem. Und nicht so sehr, dass heute die Verherrlichung offensichtlich nicht mehr passt. Vielleicht hat sie nie gepasst.
Ich würde sagen, Veith Selk ist nicht derjenige, der verherrlicht, sondern eher die Leute, die er da kritisiert dann.
Das stimmt.
Die haben es verherrlicht. Dann als nächstes Differenzierung und Komplexität. Differenzierung meint, dass wir immer mehr Akteure haben, die in dem politischen, demokratischen Prozess eine Rolle spielen. Wir haben also politische Akteure in Form von Politikern. Wir haben Institutionen. Wir haben diverse Organisationen bis hin zu NGOs. Wir haben Netzwerke. Und diese sind natürlich auch deshalb entstanden, weil es eine Ausdifferenzierung in der Gesellschaft gibt, weil man nicht sagt, wir machen jetzt ein Gesetz für alle, sondern wir versuchen auch particulare Interessen, Interessen von Minderheiten zum Beispiel, zu berücksichtigen. Also brauchen die auch wieder entsprechende Verbände, brauchen auch dort wieder politische Akteure. Das führt dann zu einer Komplexitätssteigerung. Und da kommt dann für Veith Selk der Schluss. Der Bürgerschaft erscheint die Politik pointiert formuliert, entweder als ein undurchsichtiges und unfaires Machtspiel von Insidern oder als die Folge eines incrementalistischen Krisenmanagements, aber nicht als die planvolle und zweckrationale Verwirklichung demokratisch entschiedener Ziele. Hier kann man auch wieder sagen, ja, dann haben die Leute was anderes erwartet. Aber ich würde hier auch hinzufügen, diese Unübersichtlichkeit durch Differenzierung und Komplexität ist etwas, was wir ja auch laufend erleben. Und wir stehen da im Prinzip wie in einem Kafka-Roman davor und können kaum durchschauen und können es auch sehr schwer verstehen. Deswegen sind ja beispielsweise dann Verschwörungstheorien so beliebt, weil sie uns wiederum einfache Antworten geben. Aber was daraus ja folgt, ist, dass wir nicht mehr eine Machtzentrale in irgendeiner Weise vorfinden, bei der wir sagen können, wenn wir dort einen Austausch vornehmen, dann verändert sich fundamental etwas. Und das ist eine frustrierende Erfahrung.
Weshalb ich ja nachher dafür werbe, gar nicht erst mit Theorien anzufangen, die irgendwo ein Machtzentrum sieht, sondern es vielleicht wirklich grundsätzlich anders zu denken. Das, was du jetzt genannt hast, ist eine Entgrenzung. Wir haben eine Differenzierung. Viel mehr Menschen nehmen heute und auch nicht nur am Wahltag an der Demokratie teil. Da würde ich ja sagen, die Demokratie hat in ihrer Definition schon immer, dass sie für alle regelt und dass alle an ihr teilnehmen. Und vielleicht ist das Besondere heute, dass das das erste Mal verwirklicht wird. Nicht nur am Wahltag und nicht nur diejenigen, die denken, ich habe die Zeitung gelesen, ich habe es verstanden, sondern jetzt gehen auch diejenigen, die eine Telegram-Gruppe gelesen haben, nicht nur am Wahltag, sondern auch schon zu Wahlkampfzeiten oder nach einer Wahl, einfach hin und sagen, ich akzeptiere das aber gar nicht, ich stürme jetzt das Parlament. Oder Agnes Strack-Zimmermann kommt da, ich gehe mal hin und beleidige sie, auch wenn ich an diesem Tag keine Stimme abgeben kann, die irgendeine Folge hat. Also man könnte hier auch schon mal anmerken, ja, die Demokratie-Theorie, die immer behauptete, für alle von allen Demokratie zu ermöglichen, wird halt jetzt auf die Probe gestellt. Was ist denn, wenn alle und immer teilnehmen am Prozess?
Und da denke ich aber, würde Veith Selk dir absolut zustimmen in dieser Diagnose.
Ja, damit bin ich nicht so sicher, weil er ja doch schon eine relativ lange Liste hat. Also wenn relativ viele teilnehmen, dann haben wir es mit Informalisierung, mit Netzwerken, irgendwelchen Governance-Strukturen und so weiter. Wir haben es mit Blurring the Lines, wir haben jetzt zivilgesellschaftliche Gegenpolitik, die Misstrauisch ist, läuft bei ihm unter Niedergang der Demokratie. Ich werde nachher dafür argumentieren, dass man das auch sehr auf der Positivseite für die Demokratie verbuchen kann, denn Misstrauisch und zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement, jetzt können wir uns hier überlegen. Die Chinesen werden es auch demnächst haben. Welches System wird denn besser damit umgehen können? Unseres oder das Chinesische? Da würde ich sagen, gibt es ein paar Argumente, bei denen man einfach sagen kann, mal nicht den Tag vor dem Abend loben. Das Chinesische Modell sieht zwar jetzt gerade sehr erfolgreich aus, aber sehr leistungsfähig und belastbar ist es nicht. Unseres dagegen schon. Also es sind am 6. Januar vor vier Jahren Menschen mit Waffen ins amerikanische Parlament gestürmt, haben dort Politiker bedroht und danach wurden einfach Verfahren, die die alle ins Gefängnis bringen und wir haben eine ganz normale demokratische Wahl. Also es findet gerade einen Wahlkampf statt. Jetzt haben wir natürlich Angst, was passiert denn dann, wenn Trump gewählt wird und so weiter. Aber da kann man ja erstmal abwarten, was passiert. Also wir hatten bisher diese Art von institutionellen Untergängen, wie er sie ja hier dämmern sieht, tatsächlich noch nicht zu verbuchen, erst recht nicht im Vergleich zu anderen Politikmodellen, die sich Nicht-Demokratien nennen, die unter dem gleichen Druck stehen.
Ja, wie weit der Untergang schon fortgeschritten ist, oder ob er schon eingesetzt hat, oder ob es nur dämmert, das ist ja noch eine Frage, die zu stellen ist. Ich würde aber schon hier deutlich machen, dass es ja, glaube ich, nicht darum geht, er präsentiert uns ja nicht ein Ideal von Demokratie, wo er sagt, und das gibt es leider nicht mehr, sondern er zeigt in der Demokratietheorie viele Ideale auf und sagt dann ja, aber die treffen ja nicht mit dem zusammen, was in der Wirklichkeit vorherrscht. Und er spricht dann zum Beispiel über die Kognitions-Asymmetrie und sagt, wir können also in einer Gesellschaft, die sich so sehr ausdifferenziert hat, die solche Komplexitätssteigerungen erlebt hat, nicht mehr klar orientieren. Und das ist ja das, was wir jetzt in der regulären Folge hatten. Wir sehen Talkshows, die haben nichts mit der politischen Wirklichkeit zu tun. Da geht es nur noch mal darum, abzufragen, welche Musik Lars Kling bei hört und ob er schon Mütze nicht auf die Mütze gegeben hat.
Und die war es auf der Jagd.
Mehr ist da eigentlich nicht mehr zu leisten. Und hier sagt er ja, es reicht, wenn die Bürger wissen, was für sie selbst gut ist und wie sie das, was für sie gut ist, politisch realisieren können. Das ist eine reduktionistische Sichtweise, die aber ganz viele hatten zum Beispiel auch jemand wie Schumpeter in so einer liberalen Demokratie-Auffassung. Er sagt jetzt, das Problem dieser reduktionistischen Sichtweise auf Bürgerwissen ist, dass infolge der Zunahme politischer Differenzierung und der resultierenden Komplexität von Politik auf Seiten der Bürger sowohl theoretisches, das heißt allgemeines politisches Wissen als auch politikfeldspezifisches Wissen essentiell geworden sind. Interessenlagen und deren politische Implikationen, die Differenz zwischen privaten Anliegen und öffentlichen Angelegenheiten, die Auswirkungen politischer Entscheidungen auf das Gemeinwohl wie auf das Partikularwohl von Gruppen, sowie die möglichen politischen Entscheidungsalternativen. All das lässt sich nicht aus einer lebensweltlichen Anschauung privater Lebenszusammenhänge und vor dem Hintergrund je eigener praktischer Erfahrung verstehen und beurteilen. Und ich will diese Abstraktion auch jetzt an was konkretes direkt koppeln. Du hast uns hier vorgestellt, was mit diesem Batteriewerk los ist. Das wird jetzt im Norden gebaut. Und dann erklärst du uns den Zusammenhang, warum das dort gebaut wird, wo es doch eigentlich in das Batterie- Bundesland Bayern müsste.
Also da, wo man die Batterien braucht, in Bayern.
Und du zeigst uns dann den Zusammenhang auf, warum das jetzt nicht in Bayern entstanden ist. Da sage ich, das machst, das kannst du machen, weil du dich damit auseinandergesetzt hast und diese Zusammenhänge verstehst. Du spielst uns dann aber einen Bauern vor, der sagt, naja, ob so eine Firma, die es erst seit ein paar Jahren gibt, wirklich hier Erfolge haben wird, da bin ich skeptisch. Was dieser Bauer da sagt, ist natürlich das, was jeder sagen würde, könnte. Man könnte auch einfach sagen, keine Ahnung. Denn man hat gar keine Ahnung davon. Und ich hätte zu diesem Batteriewerk auch nichts sagen können, wenn du es mir nicht erklärt hättest. Das bedeutet aber, dass es so voraussetzungsreich überhaupt einen politischen Prozess zu beurteilen, dass eigentlich nur noch die Profis, also nur noch die, die sehr viel Zeit darauf verwenden, das durchschauen können. Ich kann nur sagen, ja, wahrscheinlich hat Stefan recht. Ich habe jetzt nicht nochmal, ja ich hätte die Möglichkeit, aber ich habe jetzt nicht die Lust, auch nochmal fünf Stunden was dazu zu lesen, um am Ende zu sagen, na ja, aber das hätte auch in Baden-Württemberg entstehen können.
Also darin liegt ja dieses Missverständnis, dass der Inhalt, und damit meine ich jetzt alle inhaltlichen Fragen, die man so haben kann, zum Thema, mein Traktor, die Batteriefabrik, ist nicht eine alte Entscheidung der Politik, viel besser als eine neue, ein abgehangener Fisch und so, ist doch viel besser, als wenn ich jetzt gar nicht weiß, was habe ich da gerade geangelt. Diese Idee von die Inhalte des Bewusstseins sind für den politischen, konkreten Prozess so wahnsinnig bedeutsam, ist einfach wirklich ein Missverständnis.
Aber ich muss doch entscheiden können, wer macht jetzt gerade für mich die bessere Politik? Ist das Söder oder ist das nicht? Das kann ich dann nur entscheiden, wenn ich weiß, ach, der Söder, der verhindert nicht nur, dass ich ein Windrad im Garten habe, sondern der verhindert damit zugleich auch, dass die bayerische Industrie vorankommt. Diesen Zusammenhang, den muss ich ja erst mal herstellen können.
Ja, und deswegen gibt es ja hier, und ich will es jetzt ganz deutlich sagen, Soziologie, die eben ganz fein differenziert zwischen du musst überzeugt sein, du musst etwas wissen, du musst mit Ahnung in die Wahlstube gehen und sagen, das ist mein Mann, der entschrifft für mich Entscheidung. Oder du vertraust. Und die Quellen für Vertrauen müssen nicht zwingend konkretes Wissen über politische Probleme sein. Sondern diese Art von Repräsentation funktioniert auch anders. Und ich will nur die Buchtitel nennen, die er ja auch nennt, Legitimation durch Verfahren oder Vertrauen als eigenständigen Grundbegriff eben darüber nachdenken.
Ist ja eine ganz frühe Schrift von Luhmann.
Fehlt aber in dieser Demokratie-Theorie. Denn hier, und ich will mal einen Satz, von dem ich sage, hier ist nicht nur, also er hat Recht mit der Kritik, die er macht. Aber auch, wie er sie macht, würde ich sagen, steht er ja auf der Seite, die er kritisiert. Er schreibt zum Beispiel, nachdem er so die Digitalisierung, die Fragmentierung der Öffentlichkeit, also mal mitten in den Satz reingesprungen, die kohärente Konstruktion eines Volkswillens und einer öffentlichen Meinung ist nicht mehr möglich. Das ist ja seine Kritik. Die war nie nötig, muss man ganz deutlich sagen. Vor 50, 60 Jahren, wenn man so ein Buch jetzt liest, denkt man ja, ja, vor 50, 60 Jahren hat es also mal funktioniert und jetzt nicht mehr. Also er macht ja eine Entwicklungsgeschichte, Devolution als Gegenteil von Evolution. Wir hatten keinen Zustand, in den irgendwann die Leute mehr aufgeklärt darüber waren, was Bundestagsausschüsse entscheiden, wie Geldströme funktionieren, wie Rekrutierung im politischen Verwaltungsapparat klappt, und so weiter. Diese Aufklärung gab es nie. Und sie war auch nie nötig. Nur, sie steht heute unter anderem Druck.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, das stimmt, dass nie das so ganz transparent war. Das war nie ganz klar. Und das waren nur wenige Eingeweihte, die es durchschaut haben. Und schon damals spielten ja Journalisten eine wichtige Rolle, um aufzuklären, was will die CSU da eigentlich? Franz Josef Strauß oder so etwas. Aber durch diese Differenzierung, durch die Komplexität, die hinzugekommen ist, wird das alles noch undurchsichtiger. Dass ja sogar ich, wo ich sage, ich beschäftige mich schon relativ professionell mit dem, was politisch passiert, dir hier gegenüber sitzt und sage, keine Ahnung, was die Söder-Politik für Auswirkungen darauf hat, du erklärst es mir. Dann habe ich das Vertrauen, dass das richtig ist. Es ist auch plausibel argumentiert. Ich kann dann auch Dinge, die ich weiß, damit verknüpfen, aber mehr ist nicht. Wenn ich aber hier lese, dass man Studien gemacht hat und man sagen kann, dass 50 Prozent der Wähler mit den sozialpolitischen Ausrichtungen der einzelnen Parteien nicht vertraut sind, dann bedeutet das, dass alle im Nebel herumstochern. Und jetzt kommt eine andere Zahl. Lass uns wirklich mal über diese reden. Der funktionale Analphabetismus. Das war mir nicht so bewusst. Ich weiß, dass es Analphabeten in Deutschland gibt. Es gibt auch mal wieder Werbung, die dazu auffordert, dass man doch Hilfe in Anspruch nimmt. Aber hier geht es um die Leo-Studien. Diese Studien sprechen von funktionalen Analphabeten. Wir machen das mal in Detail. Es gibt mehrere Level. Es gibt das Alpha-Level 1, das wird erreicht, wer einzelne Buchstaben lesen und schreiben kann. Das Level 2 wird erreicht, wenn einzelne Wörter gelesen und geschrieben werden können. Dann gibt es noch das Alpha-Level 3, das bedeutet, man kann einzelne Sätze lesen und schreiben. Diese Leute scheitern jedoch bereits an zusammenhängenden Sätzen. Eben deine These, kein 17-Jähriger kann heute einen Roman schreiben. Die jüngste Leo-Studie bemisst den Anteil der deutschsprachigen Erwachsenen zwischen 18 und 64 Jahren in Deutschland, die sich auf diesen drei Stufen befinden, auf 6, 2 Millionen Menschen. Das heißt, 6, 2 Millionen Menschen können nicht Sätze lesen und sie in einen Zusammenhang bringen. Und wir sprechen hier also von 50 Millionen Erwachsenen, 51, 5 Millionen deutschsprachigen Erwachsenen im Alter von 18 bis 64 Jahren, davon 6, 2 Millionen Menschen. Und dann gibt es aber noch Alpha-Level 4, immer noch funktionaler Analphabetismus. Das ist die Ebene des Schriftdeutsch in leichter Sprache. Laut, also da sprechen wir, hier wird das zitiert, die Rechtschreibung, wie sie bis zum Ende der Grundschule unterrichtet werden sollte, wird nicht hinreichend beherrscht. Also das heißt, die sind unter dem Niveau eines Grundschülers, der fertig ist mit der Grundschule. Und hier heißt es, 10, 6 Millionen Menschen sind auf diesem Level 4 der 18- bis 64-Jährigen. Das heißt, von 51, 5 Millionen 18- bis 64-Jährigen sind 16, 8 Millionen Menschen nicht auf dem Grundschulniveau des Schriftdeutschs. Das ist ein ungeheures politisches Versagen. Man weiß gar nicht, wie das sein kann, wo ja alle schulpflichtig sind und auch an Schulen waren, dass das passieren kann. Das ist so erschreckend. Und das bedeutet aber nicht, dass diese Leute gar nicht am politischen Prozess teilnehmen, sondern sie nehmen teil in irgendeiner Weise. Gucken sich vielleicht TikTok-Videos an, bewerten Kandidaten nach Aussehen, Performance, was auch immer, nach irgendeinem Spruch, den sie gehört haben, den sie verstehen. Und da sind wir jetzt mal gerade hier bei diesem Level 4. Man kann sich ja vorstellen, wie viele Level darüber kommen müssen, bis wir bei dem Level sind, dass jemand einen FAZ-Artikel lesen kann, in dem aufgedröselt ist, warum der bayerische Ministerpräsident eine falsche Industriepolitik macht. Und das ist ja hier von Selks wirklich wunderbar deutlich gemacht, zu zeigen, jam, wir können über die Wissensgesellschaften und all das reden, aber de facto ist das Wissen bei sehr großen Teilen der Bevölkerung überhaupt nicht vorhanden, nicht mal rudimentär.
Und jetzt möchte ich ihn mit seinen eigenen Mitteln hier etwas entgegenhalten. Angenommen, wir hätten es jetzt mal mit, also in dieser Problemlage, vollständig aufgeklärten Menschen zu tun. Wie in der Ökonomie, so neoklassisch ist, alle wissen über den Markt Bescheid. Und dann wird einfach ein Preis gebildet. Das heißt ja, jeder kennt seine Bedürfnisse und weiß, wie er sie politisch entweder selbst umsetzen oder repräsentativ durch Vertretung delegieren kann. Also jeder würde dann sozusagen perfekt vertreten. Man kommt trotzdem nicht aus der Losung raus, dass hier jeder ein particulares Interesse mitbringt. Wir können natürlich hoffen, dass dann über diese Aufklärung noch mal ein universalistisches Argument oder wie auch immer, dass jemand selbst zurücksteckt oder was auch immer. Aber unsere große Klage ist ja eigentlich, wir haben es in Deutschland und in den westlichen Ländern mit so großen Armutsproblemen zu tun, weil diejenigen, die arm sind, unter diesem Analphabetismus, wie du ihn genannt hast, leiden und sich deswegen nicht politisch verwirklichen können. So, was bedeutet? Der Idealzustand, der auch in dieser Idee drinsteckt, ist, jeder bringt sein particulares Interesse ein. Wenn jeder an sich selbst denkt, ist an alle gedacht, diese Idee. Von der ich auch sage, sie klingt zwar als Sprache ein bisschen blöd, aber sie ist nicht ganz falsch. Sie wird nur torpediert von diesen Analphabetsraten, die sich ja auch politisch niederschlagen mit, naja, der Bürgermeister hat eben nur Termine mit denjenigen, die in der Lage sind, einen Termin beim Bürgermeister zu bekommen. Das bedeutet, in einer Stadt wie Frankfurt mit 700.000 Einwohnern, der Bürgermeister hat immer wieder mit denselben 3000 Leuten Termine. Und die anderen 700.000 sind außen vor, weil die nicht in der Lage sind zu verstehen und es ihnen auch bewusst schwer gemacht wird, von denen, die es wissen, wie man jetzt einen Termin beim Bürgermeister bekommt. Und dass der Bürgermeister selber mal zu der Bürgermeister spricht und aufbricht und dann irgendwie durch die halbe Stadt fährt und zu sagen, hier bin ich, trag mir Ideen vor, da weiß er auch fünf solche Termine und danach, da kommt nichts bei rum. Also wir hängen in so einer Partikulationsfalle irgendwie drin und wollen das lösen über, na dann lass mal wenigstens oder gönnen wir jedem Einzigen, der mit particularem Interesse kommt, größtmögliche Aufklärung, sodass er sein berechtigtes, aber particulares Interesse durchsetzen kann. Und jetzt schreibt ja Veith selbst, dass Karl Mannheim schon für die Weimarer Demokratie diesen Kontext der Politisierung, nämlich, ja, man kommt ja gar nicht weiter, man hat die particularen Interessen und so, und am Ende summiert sich es in ideologischen Kämpfen aus. So und wenn man das liest, denkt man sich so, ah das ist ja interessant. Also deswegen auch Die Neuen Zwanziger, in dem Fall besonders interessant, weil wir offenbar jetzt dieselben Probleme haben, wie vor 100 Jahren, ohne sehr viele dieser Punkte, die Veith als, und das macht es heute problematisch, haben. Also wir haben keine Digitalisierung, wir haben keine Globalisierung, wir haben den ganzen Kram einfach nicht. Und trotzdem gilt damals dieselbe Diagnose wie heute, das particulare Interesse des Einzelnen, also das kann man irgendwie aufsummieren oder was auch immer, aber am Ende führt eine Repräsentation, eine Delegierung, eine Delegierung, führt immer zu Ideologisierung. Also diesen Brückenschlag von mein einzelnes Interesse, nee, es muss einmal gesammelt werden. Wir haben Parteien, wir haben Lager, wir haben Vereine, die das machen. Wir haben immer particulare Interessen, die sich allenfalls noch ideologisch zuspitzen lassen, aber nicht eins zu eins umsetzen. So, und wenn man für die Weimarer Demokratie dieselbe Diagnose wie für heute macht, aber plötzlich einen Problemkatalog aufzieht, der damals nicht galt, dann hat man es mit ganz großen Inkonsistenzen in den Prinzipien des eigenen Denkens zu tun. Also dann stößt man einfach an echte Grenzen.
Wir müssen den Unterschied machen, dass man heute ganz andere Heereziele mit der Demokratie verbindet, bzw. dass die Geschichte der Bundesrepublik eine ist, die eine Demokratie für alle mehr Demokratie wagen, wie immer man es ausdrücken möchte. Dass das eine Geschichte ist, die darauf abzielte, einen mündigen Bürger zu haben. Und Veith Selk sagt, ich kann den mündigen Bürger nicht finden. Wenn das in den Zwanzigerjahren auch schon so war, dann kann man da eher noch vielleicht den Schluss auch daraus ziehen, dass die Demokratie als solches ein Konstrukt ist, das auf sehr wackeligen Füßen steht. Aber als Anspruch, den man mal hatte, oder den man auch immer noch formuliert in Sonntagsreden an die Demokratie, zeigt sich ja hier in einem Maße, dass man auch sich wundert, dass das, also ich meine, diese Studie ist ja öffentlich und so was. Und ich habe auch schon mal in Ansätzen davon gehört, dass es ein großes Problem mit funktionalem Anapherbetismus gibt. Aber im Prinzip ist das ja so, dass man sagen müsste, das ist das große Thema. Wir hatten jetzt diese Diskussion, ja die Schüler können nicht mehr richtig Rechtschreibung, wenn sie die 10. Klasse verlassen. Und dann schreibt noch mal irgendjemand einen Leitartikel, das liegt bestimmt an der Autokorrektur beim Smartphone. Aber wie groß die Probleme sind, wird ja überhaupt nicht thematisiert. Und jetzt hat der Selk das hier uns aufgeschrieben. Und verbindet das ja auch gleich auch mit etwas Ökonomischem. Denn auch das sollten wir hier nochmal ganz deutlich machen, das ist natürlich nicht eine Frage von kognitiver Leistung an sich, sondern es ist eine Frage von sozialem, ökonomischem. Also wer bekommt welche Schulbildung, wer wird wie gefördert. Und dann geht es ja darum, dass der demokratische Kapitalismus an ein Ende gerät. Er sagt ja hier auch, naja, so demokratisch war der Kapitalismus nie gewesen. Das ist ja so eine Erzählung, die gerne gemacht wird, bis hin auch zu Wagenknecht, wo es dann heißt, ja und der demokratische Kapitalismus, früher ging das noch Hand in Hand, da war sozialer Frieden und so was, 70er Jahre. Er zitiert hier Charles E. Lindblom, das fand ich sehr interessant. Lindblom argumentierte, dass in kapitalistischen Demokratien das Marktsystem einen Damm gegen ökologische und soziale Politiken errichtet, die gegen die Profitlogik des Kapitalismus verstoßen würden. Seine bis heute überzeugende Erklärung für diese These lautet, dass im demokratischen Kapitalismus die gesellschaftlich folgenreichsten Organisations- und Koordinationsfunktionen nicht alleine von der politischen Klasse ausgeübt werden, die für ihre Entscheidungen öffentliche Verantwortung trägt und mittels demokratischer Beteiligungsverfahren beeinflusst und zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden kann. Nahezu ebenso wichtig wie die politische Klasse ist derjenige Teil der Elite, den er als Geschäftsklasse bezeichnet, als Eigentümer und Lenker der privaten Wirtschaftsbetriebe. Und die verfügen dann darüber, gibt es Arbeitslosigkeit, also Wachstum und Beschäftigung, das ist das, was die steuern. Und da sehen wir also einen immensen Demokratiemangel, der immer schon diagnostiziert wurde oder lange schon. Immer schon ist so eine Formulierung, die ja immer spitzzünglich aufgreift. Deswegen sage ich also die schon früher oft diagnostiziert wurde. Aber was wir heute vorfinden, ist, dass sich das noch weiter auseinander bewegt hat. Dass die Ungleichheit sehr viel größer geworden ist. Das heißt also, dass der von Lindblom beschriebene Effekt heute sehr viel stärker ist. Und das wirkt dann auch so, dass der kapitalistische Markt so einen, wie es hier heißt, automatischen Bestrafungsmechanismus hat, so nennt das Lindblom. Und auch da ist also die Demokratie sehr eingeschränkt. Und nur eigentlich für die zu verbinden mit dem Kapitalismus, also Demokratie und Kapitalismus, die zu den oberen zehn Prozent der Verdienenden gehören, diese PMC-Leute.
Diese Verknüpfung aus Kapitalismus und Demokratie finde ich auch inspirativ super interessant, denn wir haben es ja beim Kapitalismus nun mit einem Profitinteresse zu tun, bei dem wir sagen können, ja, das kann man einfach lernen, was profitabel ist. Da braucht man keine Ahnung für oder wie auch immer. Man hat irgendwie so einen Teil in Error und irgendwann hat man so ein Modell und dann verdient man Geld. Und dieses Prinzip sickert ja jetzt in die Politik ein. Der Profit ist dann Wählerunterstützung. Und man sagt, na ja, es muss einfach auf das Konto eingezahlt werden. Also wir haben ja, wie jetzt klügere Politiker beobachten, immer wieder sagen, wir haben es bei der AfD mit so einer Protestunternehmerin zu tun. Die will ein Cash-In. Unterm Strich, am Ende des Tages, will man da Zustimmung verbucht haben. Und da will ich noch mal kurz auf diesen, denn das wird dann auch im Sinne dieser Zeitidee, die wir ja jetzt immer seit Haglund mitlaufen lassen, interessant, was die Herausforderungen angeht. Also in dieser Weimarer Demokratie hatten wir particuläre Interessen, die sich in, wie er schreibt, kohärenten Ideologien repräsentierten. Wir würden heute sagen, Parteien. Man wusste einfach, diese CDU klärt schon mal ein Kleinbürgertum. Und wenn man irgendwie so eine kleine Zecke ist, dann muss man halt die Linken wählen. So, ne? Also man hat so einen Auffangbecken. Und jetzt sagt er, für heute dieser Kampf dieser Kohärenten Ideologien zerfällt in, Zitat, unübersichtlichen Kampf um Deutungsmacht. Also dieses Tagesaktuelle, alle sind nur noch politische Day-Trader und am Ende des Tages wird einfach so ein kleiner Profit verbucht. Wir haben es also mit episodischen und heterogenen Wissen innerhalb der Bürgerschaft zu tun, das selektiv berücksichtigt wird. Also nicht nur versucht, die AfD ein Thema zu spielen, sondern auch andere Themen gezielt auszublenden. Es gibt nicht mehr so das Allgemeine, sondern nur noch das, was profitabel ist, wird irgendwie herangeführt. Jetzt würde ich sagen, naja, man könnte es dabei belassen, zu sagen, ja, es gibt immer mal dieses kleine Aufstören des ideologischen Tagesgeschäfts, dann kommt plötzlich so die Grünen und dann sind die aber auch eine richtige Partei. Also sie etablieren sich auf Dauer, dann kommt so eine Wende und dann gibt's plötzlich eine Linke und jetzt gibt's halt eine AfD. Die ist zwar nochmal mehr Sammelbecken als vorher, also die ist sozusagen, aber im Grunde vielleicht ändert sich gar nicht so viel, sodass man sagen kann, okay, in der Weimarer Demokratie gab's gefestigte Parteien und man wusste, man schließt sich einer an oder man ist halt außen vor. Heute kann man das ganze Thema unter Druck setzen, es gibt mehr Parteien, aber der große Unterschied ist gar nicht auf sachlicher und sozialer, sondern auf dieser zeitlichen.
In der Weimarer Republik gab's ja noch viel mehr Parteien.
Ja, aber man hat sozusagen das Zentrum, da weiß man schon mal, größte Sammelbecken.
Ab wo man ideologisch stand, war klarer.
Genau, also man konnte sich da klar verorten, heute geht's ein bisschen drunter und drüber. Aber ich würde sagen, viel wichtiger ist noch, und das fehlt dann als Ausarbeitung, aber das fände ich dann interessant, wenn man die ökonomische Logik, dass man ganz schnell lernen kann und dann sein Verhalten ändert. Dass diese Beschleunigung auch in der Politik berücksichtigt wird. Der große Bogenschlag wäre dann nicht, heute ist alles so durcheinander und dann kommt die AfD als Sammelbecken oder soll ich doch lieber sagen, weil Sarah Wank nicht wählt oder wie auch immer, sondern dass man diese Beschleunigung versucht zu institutionalisieren. So wie die EU, das ist ja auch super interessant, wird leider ganz wenig nur beobachtet, aber die EU hat ja auch ein großes Lobbyproblem. Nur Lobbyismus funktioniert ja da nicht mehr, indem eine Interessensorganisation kommt und sagt, wir haben hier Ansprüche, wir schreiben uns mal ins Lobbyregister und wir sind jetzt der Bauernverband. Sondern in der EU hat es sich jetzt so zweistufig ergeben, dass einige Lobbyorganisationen wissen, wie der Hase läuft. Das sind dann ehemalige Parlamentarier oder im NATO-Umfeld da, die Sarasmussen. Man weiß einfach, das sind Leute, die haben Adressbücher. Scheuer hat jetzt zwei Firmen gegründet, die auch Lobbyismus machen wollen. So, da weiß man einfach, wenn ich was will, ist das mein Mann. Man beschleunigt, indem man sein Anliegen nicht mehr selber organisiert, sondern man bucht Lobbyismus für eine gewisse Zeit, die man das braucht, als Service und zahlt dann einfach. Zeit ist Geld. So, und da liegt dann eine gewisse Beschleunigung drin. Also irgendein Thema kommt auf und man weiß, ich könnte jetzt drei Jahre lang eine Lobby-Organisation gründen und so wie die jungen Leute heute bei Land sitzen und sagen, ich geh doch nicht in eine Partei, fünf Jahre Rotsverband, seid ihr bescheuert, ich will, dass jetzt was geändert wird, das sagen sich die Lobby-Organisationen auch. Also da sind schon Beschleunigungs-Sachen drin, die sozusagen keine Rücksicht mehr nehmen auf organisierte Institutionalität, Vereine, Verbände, Parteien.
Ist aber nicht sehr demokratisch.
Es ist nicht sehr demokratisch, aber es ist Realität und allein dadurch, dass es so unbeobachtet ist, relativ akzeptiert. Es bekommt ja gar keiner mit. Ich sehe jedenfalls keinen AfDler, der sich darüber aufregt, dass da so Lobby-Assist-Service-Organisationen irgendwie rumrennen, sondern man ist immer noch in diesen alten Ideologie-Kämpfen, wie vor 100 Jahren. Nur heute sind es eben keine kohärenten Ideologie-Kämpfe mehr, sondern sie sind beschleunigt. Dazu würde ich mir auch wieder ein ganzes Buch wünschen.
Unbedingt. Wir sollten nochmal hier deutlich machen, es ist nicht so ein Buch, das sagt, oh, das ist aber schade, dass es mit der Demokratie bergab geht, denn da sind ja diese Feinde von außen gekommen. Es ist also nicht wie in einem Marvel-Film, wo eigentlich eine friedliche Ordnung ist und die wird dann gestört durch einen Bösewicht, zum Beispiel die AfD oder andere Rechtspopulisten. Was hier Selk uns zeigt, ist, dass solche Rechtspopulisten entstehen, dass die Leute sagen, ich fühle mich gar nicht mehr repräsentiert. Das liegt auch in der Demokratie selbst begründet. Also, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass wir Ausdifferenzierung schätzen, dass wir Komplexität eigentlich wollen, führt das notwendigerweise auch dazu, dass es ein bisschen unverständlich wird oder sogar sehr unverständlich. Und so führt er ja dann in einer Tabelle das nochmal zusammen. Also, diese Devolutionsdimension, wie er es nennt. Es gibt die erwähnte Politisierung. Die bedeutet, dass also die Demokratie umstritten wird. Also auch die Demokratie als solches waren das wirklich faire Wahlen. Hat Trump nicht am Ende doch gewonnen? Also diese Debatten. Dann diese Differenzierung und Komplexität sorgt dafür, dass wir es immer mehr mit einer Unsteuerbarkeit der Demokratie zu tun haben. Das merkt man auch, wenn Politiker gefragt werden, warum ändern sie denn daran nichts? Und sie manchmal dann eingestehen, dass sie nicht dafür zuständig sind und dass sie noch nicht mal wissen, wie genau der Zuständigkeitsbereich aussieht. Also das ist ein großes Problem der Demokratie. Dann gibt es diese Kognitionsasymmetrie. Das heißt, die Demokratie wird uns unverständlich. Jetzt weißt du darauf hin, das war vielleicht früher nicht besser. Ich würde sagen, es hat aber schon zugenommen durch die Komplexitätserhöhung. So dass auch, ich sagen würde, wir, die das relativ professionell betrachten, an unsere Grenzen gelangen. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich dich jetzt frage, Ursula von der Leyen hat gesagt, wir brauchen dringend eine Kapitalmarktunion. Da sind wir immer noch in den Kinderschuhen. Kannst du mir darauf eine vernünftige Antwort geben? Ich habe mich kürzlich damit ein bisschen beschäftigt. Ich habe danach ein paar Stunden gesagt, ach so interessant ist es doch nicht. Ich verstehe es nur halb. Ich weiß grob damit, was gemeint ist. Aber ob das sinnvoll ist, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Bankenunion, Kapitalmarktunion, Union heißt immer nicht mehr national, sondern allgemeingültig für Europa.
Das verstehe ich. Aber inwieweit das wirklich sinnvoll ist und die deutsche Wirtschaft davon profitieren könnte oder die europäische Wirtschaft.
Die interessante Frage ist ja, wenn man noch keine Kapitalmarktunion hat, sondern nur ein deutsches Regelwerk, kennt man das denn? Das ist ja wieder der Bauer, der dann sagt, ne, das ist aber deine neue Regelung, da komme ich mit mehr Skepsis als der Alten. Und dann fragt man sich, aber die alte Regelung findest du jetzt gut?
Die kennt man auch nicht.
Auch wieder die Zeit, die so ausschlaggebend ist.
Und viertens noch, das Ende des demokratischen Kapitalismus, also dass die Ungerechtigkeit als so groß empfunden wird und sie es auch tatsächlich ist, dass auch damit das demokratische Versprechen dass ja eines der Gleichheit ist, damit untergraben wird.
Da muss man übrigens sagen, bei diesem Punkt, wenn er das empirisch gemacht hätte, mit die Ungleichheit hat sich im Zeitverlauf wirklich dramatisch verschärft. Also nicht die Ungleichheit an sich, sondern diese Verschärfung der Ungleichheit. Die ist das Problem. Aber dann müsste man aus dem, also dann muss man sich nicht so an den Theorien oder so was, sondern...
Ja, aber dann würde ich sagen, indem er das erwähnt und ein paar Namen nennt, ich glaube, Branko Milanovic wird ja hier auch zitiert, glaube ich, ist das doch hinreichend, um zu sagen, wer das jetzt wissen will, wie sich das verschlechtert hat oder ob es sich verschlechtert hat, dann kann man das doch nachlesen.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem immer wieder, Steffen Mauer hat ja besonders Wert drauf gelegt, bei seiner Publikation zuletzt, dass Ungleichheit vorhanden ist, heißt noch nicht automatisch, dass sie breit kritisiert wird. Bei dem meritokratischen Buch, das wir gelesen haben, hier angefangen bei Sendel und dann auch andere, die Leute akzeptieren ihre Ungleichheit. Also man kann nicht einfach immer per se so, ja, das erklärt sich ja von alleine, nein, die Leute bewundern Reiche. Und bei der Frage, ja, aber warum sind sie denn dann so anfällig bei Fremdenfeindlichkeit? Warum werden ökonomische Fragen immer umgelenkt auf, nee, es ist nicht der Milliardär, der dir das Geld wegnimmt, sondern der Flüchtling, der das nach Hause bucht. Ja, man identifiziert sich mit seinem Reichen. Man will auch mal ein Reicher sein. Man will aber nie ein Fremdling sein, nie ein Flüchtling. So, ja, da muss man, finde ich auch, da lohnt es sich dann einfach empirisch, mal reinzugehen. So wie Steffen Maudern auch, die Leute einfach mal fragen und die sagen dann, nee, ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool, wenn es Reiche gibt, ich will ja auch mal ein Reicher sein, aber du bist ja gar kein Reicher. Ja, stimmt irgendwie. Ja, also wenn da solche Probleme mit reinkommen.
Dann spricht er ja in seinem Kapitel zur Dämmerung, darüber, dass sich jetzt einige auf den Weg machen, die Licht versprechen in dieser Dämmerung. Und das sind, uns wäre es auch eingefallen, die Populisten, die sagen, es könnte eigentlich so einfach sein, hört mal zu, wir machen das folgendermaßen. Und der geht hier auf dieses Satori-Kriterium ein, also dass man, also die Voraussetzung für Demokratie ist, dass der Bürger einen Überblick über das hat, was geschieht. Jetzt sagst du, aber das hat er generell nicht. Aber punktuell brauche er es ja schon, bzw. er braucht es ja so. Also das ist der, ich verstehe deinen, wenn du dir jetzt sagst, das ist mit der Kapitalmarktunion, aber du weißt ja auch nicht, wie der nationale Kapitalmarkt genau organisiert ist, dann würde ich sagen, gut, man kommt auch mit beidem gut zurecht. Und man kann vielleicht eine Wahlentscheidung treffen, ohne zu wissen, ob Kapitalmarktunion kommen sollte oder nicht. Aber bei anderen Punkten, zum Beispiel Mindestlohn, Arbeitslosenversicherung, Bauen und Wohnen, muss ich ja etwas schon über die Parteien wissen. Also ich kann natürlich auch einfach jemanden wählen nach Sackofarbe oder Frisur. Und das findet ja statt. Das ist ja etwas, was bemängelt wird. Aber ich brauche ja ein Wissen. Weil wir machen ja diesen Podcast, um aufzuklären. Wir sagen ja nicht am Ende. Und dann sucht ihr euch einfach jemanden aus, bei dem euch die Frisur am besten gefällt. Das würden wir nicht sagen, sondern du gibst ja sogar noch mit nach Hause und jetzt zählt mal noch auf der Familienfeier dies und das. Also klärt auf. Und damit setzt du ja auch voraus, dass man etwas wissen muss über den politischen Prozess.
Ja.
Und über die Entscheidungen und über die Politik, die angeboten werden.
Also ich weiß, dass das Argument so ganz komisch ist. Und ich musste auch lange, aber wenn man es, und ich sage es einfach mal aus prinzipiellen Gründen, ganz ernst nimmt, dass die Semantik, wie man über etwas redet und die Struktur, um was geht es eigentlich? Wenn man das wirklich hart unterscheidet, und zwar jenseits des Menschenverstandes, einfach mal ernst nimmt, Semantik und Struktur, dann muss man sagen, wir brauchen Aufklärung. Ja, aber warum? Nicht, damit wir verstehen, wie etwas funktioniert. Beispielsweise, ah, dann kann ich es ja besser machen. Jetzt, wo ich aufgeklärt bin, wie der Motor funktioniert, kann ich vielleicht selber reagieren oder so.
Nein, aber ich muss ja verstehen können, wer es besser macht. Also wenn ich jetzt, zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt...
Ja, warte, da fehlt noch ein Grundbegriff, der aber ganz wichtig ist. Wir möchten Aufklärung, weil wir sie als Vehikel brauchen, zu vertrauen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also da würde ich jetzt widersprechen. Ich finde diesen Vertrauenstext von Nicholas Dumann wirklich sehr gut. Und ich weiß auch, dass grundlegend, brauchen wir Vertrauen. Ich habe das auch immer deutlich gemacht in Bezug auf die Impfung. Du hast dir ja immer viel Mühe gegeben, hier zu erklären, wie das mit den Spike-Proteinen ist. Ich habe dann gesagt, ich habe es nicht verstanden, aber ich vertraue dir.
Genau, das ist das Prinzip.
Das gilt da und wird wahrscheinlich auch bei der Kapitalmarktunion gelten. Nur muss ich wissen, wohin ich überhaupt gehen kann. Also wenn ich eine Haartransplantation mache, dann habe ich ein Problem, wenn ich mich auf einen Zahnarztstuhl setze und sage, machen Sie das mal.
Warum vertraust du ihm nicht? Da gibt es ja Gründe für.
Ich weiß aber, dass wenn ich eine Haartransplantation will, ich zu einem anderen Doktor muss, als wenn ich jetzt ein Bein gebrochen habe. Aber wenn ich jetzt sage, ich hätte gerne, dass die Mieten nicht weiter steigen, zu wem gehe ich denn dann? Gehe ich dann zur CDU, weil die sagen, Wohnen muss bezahlbar bleiben? Oder gehe ich zu Linken, die sagen, Wohnen muss bezahlbar bleiben?
Also und jetzt kommt ein Gegenargument, bei dem ich auch von den Hörern gerne wissen möchte, ob das verfängt, weil ich finde, da steckt, ich verspreche jetzt einen großen RH-Effekt. Wenn Aufklärung die Lösung wäre für bessere Demokratie und bessere Demokratie-Theorie, also Reflektion von Demokratie, dann würde man ja sagen, okay, dann klären wir die AfD-Wähler einfach mal auf. Und zwar zum Beispiel zum Thema, was bedeutet Zuwanderung für Deutschland ökonomisch? Weil ihr wollt doch auch, dass es euren Kindern besser geht. Ihr wollt, dass euer Haufen Hof geschützt ist. Ihr wollt doch ein stabiles Leben und so weiter Zukunft. So, wenn man dann anfängt, aufklärerisch, also mit mehr Information, also man denkt, ich sag ihnen jetzt was und dann wissen sie mehr. Diese Leute reagieren mit Gegenaufklärung. Die wissen viel mehr über ökonomische Zusammenhänge, über irgendwas, ob das dann am Ende alles stimmt und so. Das ist eine andere Frage. Aber bei der Frage Wissen, wie viel Wissen und wie viel Aufklärung? Die Erfahrung ist, wenn man mit Leuten diskutiert, die irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien anhängen, dann hat man selber vielleicht gerade mitbekommen, dass es diese Verschwörungstheorie gibt. Dann diskutiert man plötzlich mit Leuten, die seit Jahren mehrere Stunden am Tag sich mit Inhalten befassen. Da kannst du mit Aufklärung, mehr Wissen und so weiter nicht weiterkommen.
Das ist wie mit so evangelikalen Sekten. Die haben die Bibel auswendig gelernt.
Jetzt schwenkt die aufklärerische Diskussion um. Was braucht es, um das Vertrauen wieder zurückzuholen? Plötzlich diskutieren wir gar nicht mehr über noch mehr Aufklärung und noch eine Mighty-Sendung. Plötzlich lesen wir bei Pierre Lamberti und Katascha im Buch, dass es die soziale Beziehung ist, die sich aufgehebensfühlt. Und dann stellen wir fest, wie die große Aufklärung, die die Unternehmer jetzt gerade machen, die Arbeit vor dem Computer war gar nicht das Entscheidende, sondern die Produktivität entsteht beim Gespräch spontan in der Küche. Deswegen will ich die Leute aus dem Homeoffice zurückhaben. Das sind wirklich sehr große Erweckungsmomente, die man plötzlich hat. Deswegen meine strenge Unterscheidung zwischen inhaltlicher Aufklärung und Vertrauensbildung. Das sind augenscheinlich zusammenhängende Sachen, die hängen auch sehr viel zusammen. Aber das Ziel ist Vertrauensbildung in der Demokratie. Und die ist etwas weitreichender als einfach nur Aufklärung.
Das mag sein, dass sie weitreichender ist. Ich glaube auch, dass man ein gewisses Grundvertrauen braucht. Sonst kann es ja gar nicht funktionieren. Sonst hilft einem auch das Wissen nicht. Und wenn Leute sagen, Deutschland ist eine GmbH, das ist gar kein souveräner Staat, dann kann ich nicht sagen, ich habe hier mal Wissen mitgebracht. Sondern dann ist das eine Vertrauensfrage. Dem stimme ich zu. Aber wir reden mal nicht über die Verschwörungstheoretiker. Also ich will ein Telefonat wiedergeben. Mein Onkel hat den Salon, glaube ich, nicht abonniert. Ich habe mit ihm telefoniert. Ich sagte, irgendwann brauche ich auch mal ein neues Auto. Und sagte, ja, und, Verbrenner oder eben? Wollte natürlich direkt wissen. So, mein Onkel, würde ich sagen, ist CDU-Wähler seit klein auf und wird es auch bleiben. Und sagte dann zu mir, wenn jetzt der Regierungswechsel dann 2025, 26 kommt, dann ist das mit den E-Autos auch zu Ende. So, und das ist ja, und dann habe ich ihm darauf hingewiesen, dass es ja nicht in Deutschland alleine entschieden wird, wie sich die E-Mobilität global entwickelt. Dann habe ich dann so ein paar Sachen aus China erzählt und wie das so in anderen Ländern ist, Indien, so. Und daraufhin habe ich natürlich mit Aufklärung plötzlich ihm etwas deutlich gemacht. Ob er jetzt aufhört, die CDU zu wählen, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber es ist durch Aufklärung etwas entstanden, was er vorher nicht wusste oder was ihm vorher nicht klar war. Und genauso kann ja auch ich mich darüber jetzt aufklären, wenn ich des Lesens mächtig bin und auch die Muße und Zeit habe, darüber, wer jetzt zum Beispiel in Frankfurt die beste Wohnungspolitik machen würde, und dann wähle ich die. Also diese Voraus, das hat ja nichts mit Vertrauen zu tun, sondern das muss ja ein bisschen sein. Nein, aber dann kann ich doch einfach sagen, also der Vogt war doch so nett in der Talkrunde, den er präsentiert hat, dass den CDU-Ministerpräsidenten… Warum sollte ich denn jetzt, wenn ich Thüringer wäre, die Grünen wählen?
Nein, das ist ja nicht… Also ich finde, wir müssen…
Also lass uns doch mal das so machen. Wir haben irgendwie… Man braucht so ein institutionelles, demokratisches Grundvertrauen. Ja, aber es gibt ein enormes Wissensdefizit bei den Leuten, die dieses Grundvertrauen an sich haben. Also mein Onkel sagt nicht, mit der Demokratie ist ja bald zu Ende oder Hilfe, wir werden überfremdet, sondern der sagt nur, für die deutsche Wirtschaft wäre gut, wenn die CDU wieder regiert und wenn der Verbrenner für immer bleiben wird und die E-Mobilität gestoppt wird. Das ist irgendwie seine Haltung dazu. Und da würde ich sagen, der braucht nicht Grundvertrauen, sondern was der braucht, ist Aufklärung. Und die kann ich ihm dann in einem Telefonat vermitteln. Da kann man immer noch gucken, ob alle Argumente ausgereicht haben. Und genauso brauche ich Aufklärung darüber. Wenn ich jetzt in Rheinland-Pfalz wählen würde und sagen würde, für mich wäre es schon wichtig, wenn Wohnen bezahlbar bleibt, wen wähle ich dann da am sinnvollsten? Dann muss ich wissen, will die SPD jetzt noch Sozialwohnungen bauen oder verscherbelt die alles an die Investoren?
Wir sind doch immer wieder über Sachen gestolpert, die wir erstaunlich finden. Wie zum Beispiel ein Chinese, der sehr genau weiß, dass er in einem autokratischen System lebt, das niemandem irgendetwas extra gönnt, über du bist ein fleißiger Typ usw. Wäre nicht bereit, auf seine Wohlstandsgewinne der letzten zwei Jahre zu verzichten, um 100 Millionen weitere Chinesen ein leichteres Leben zu ermöglichen. Wir haben große Belegschaften in Deutschland, die sagen, lieber soll die Hälfte der Belegschaft gehen, hauptsächlich bald meinen Dienstwagen. Also wo dieser Egoismus einfach durchkommt. Obwohl man es in dem Falle nach allen Sonntagsreden und Logiken weiß, das ist kein richtiges Verhalten. Wir haben diese Aufklärung zuletzt von Brechmann bekommen. Während eines Krieges fühlten sich die Menschen plötzlich richtig zu Hause. Aufgehoben, sie haben sich besser einander verstanden. Die Solidarität kam zurück. Man dachte, das ist verloren. Politiker kamen mit der Idee von, wir brauchen jetzt mal eine Aufklärung zum Thema Zusammenhalt. Dann halten auch alle zusammen. Wir stellen fest, in den Friedenszeiten hält niemand zusammen. Man braucht einen Krieg, um mehr Zusammenhalt zu stiften. So, das würde niemand in der Sonntagsrede fordern. Aber der empirische Zusammenhang ist, wie er ist. Und ich will nochmal dafür werben, bei diesen harten Themen, wie wir sie haben, die Demokratie ist in Gefahr, kommt es sehr darauf an, auf den Gemütszustand des Einzelnen zu achten. Und eben nicht auf die knallhart abrechenbaren, wie viel Einkommen, wie viel Freizeit und so weiter und so fort. Sondern am Ende ist es der Gemütszustand und das Einkommen und die Arbeitszeit können aber wirklich nur auf sekundärer Weise zu dieser Zustimmung, und ich sage es jetzt absichtlich ein bisschen esoterisch, zu dieser Zustimmung zum Leben und so weiter, zum Licht, zur Sonne, ja das, was demokratief fördernd sein, aber sekundär.
Nur Selk würde ja sagen, die Leute könnten ja, bei deinem Beispiel bleiben wir mal gerade, die Leute können ja nicht mal egoistisch entscheiden. Also bei der, wenn der Arbeiter sagen, ne, ich will das Dienstwagenprivileg, ist mir scheißegal, was mit den anderen, die nicht im Tarif sind oder so beschäftigt sind, passiert. Das ist ja, die wissen, die wissen ja genau, was los ist und die treffen dann eine egoistische Entscheidung. Das kann man blöd finden, aber die wissen ja genau, was sie tun. Aber Leute, also wir haben zum Teil gehabt, dass die FDP 10, 12 Prozent hat. Da müssen ja einige Leute dezidiert gegen ihr Interesse gewählt haben. Wenn die CDU auf 50 Prozent irgendwo kommt, dann müssen da sehr, sehr viele Leute gegen ihr egoistisches Interesse gewählt haben, weil sie nicht wissen, dass die CDU gar nichts für sie als Erzieher, Krankenschwester, was weiß ich, tut. Das heißt, da braucht man ja das Wissen. Und das Angebot, um weiter vorzuschreiben, wo wir dann herkommen, ist das, was die Populisten machen, die sagen, es ist ganz einfach. Er zitiert dann eine sehr schöne Formulierung von Karen Priester, die nennt diese Neigung zum Populismus detektivischen Materialismus. Also man will jetzt mal wissen, wer ist denn da genau dahinter? Finde ich da jemanden? Kann ich da mal auf Spurensuche gehen? Und jetzt sagt er aber zugleich, und das macht dieses Buch auch so clever, dass er jetzt nicht sagt, und jetzt schreibe ich euch nochmal 100 Seiten auf, wie man gegen Populismus vorgeht, sondern er beschäftigt sich dann auch mit denen, die sich kritisch mit dem Populismus auseinandersetzen. Er sagt, dieser Populismus sei ein reaktiv protestförmiges Phänomen. Dieser reaktive Zug des Populismus wird in der Literatur immer wieder verkannt. Mehr noch in der Einleitung der Angriffsthese zugeordneten Literatur zum Demokratiewandel herrscht die Tendenz vor, gegenwärtige Demokratieprobleme einseitig als vor allem durch den Populismus verursacht darzustellen. Beispielhaft sei hier Diamonds monokausales Erklärungsmuster zu dem von ihm ausgemachten weltweiten Rückzug demokratischer Regime. Daimond zufolge ist ein Großteil dieser negativen Dynamik von einer Kraft hervorgerufen dem Populismus. Meine Erklärung des Populismus spricht hingegen dafür, dass sich unter der Oberfläche des in der Öffentlichkeit ausgetragenen Streits zwischen guten Demokraten und schlechten Populisten tiefer liegende Problemstellungen für demokratische Regime verbergen, die auch für die Teile der Populismusforschung charakteristische, verkürzte Dichotomie zwischen illiberalen Populismus und liberaler Demokratie verschleiert die devolutionäre Transformation demokratischer Regime. Sie gleicht sich dem detektivischen Materialismus an, wenn sie nach den Schuldigen für einen unerwünschten politischen Strukturwandel sucht. Nämlich die Populisten sagen, die liberalen Eliten sind es die 5 Grünen im Amt, oder was weiß ich, und die Populismus-Kritiker sagen, es sind die Populisten. Die Demokratie wäre das Schönste der Welt, wenn nur die bösen Populisten nicht wären. Und das so aufzuschlüssen, finde ich sehr, sehr sinnvoll.
Es ist sehr instruktiv, weil man dann so eine gewisse Handlungsleitung hat. Vor allem in welche Richtung man jetzt nicht mehr weitergeht.
Genauso auch das andere Angebot, das ja gemacht wird. Wenn das alles mit dem Wissen so schwierig ist, dann brauchen wir eine Expertokratie. Und er zeigt dann auch, wo da die großen Probleme sind. Also erstmal nennt er eine Expertokratie eine dünne Ideologie. Denn zunächst ist ja noch nicht klar, für was eigentlich diese Expertokratie dann ist. Also welchen Standpunkt sie übernimmt. Sie ist also programmatisch flexibel. Und sie wird dann erst in Verbindung mit einer dicken Ideologie wirkmächtig, wie zum Beispiel Wolfgang Schäuble. Der bezog sich in seiner Ausführung für eine stärkere Austeritätspolitik auf ein Paper von dem Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Rogoff und sagte, da seht ihr es wissenschaftlich aufgeschrieben, Austeritätspolitik ist gut und richtig und wir müssen sie durchziehen. Und das ist etwas, wo dann die dicke Ideologie mit der dünnen Ideologie verbunden wird. Und was ich auch hier an diesem Kapitel gut finde zur Expertokratie ist, dass bei diesen Expertokraten, und ich glaube, das finden wir mitunter auch wieder, was wir so kritisiert haben, wenn wir uns mit dem von uns so heiß geliebten Ethikrat beschäftigten, dass bei der Expertokratie es oft so ist, dass man die Demokratie nur noch so als notwendiges Übel ansieht. Dass man sagt, ja, das ist jetzt alles richtig, wir müssen jetzt nur noch sehen, wie kriegen wir das so demokratisch verklickert. Und das führt ja dann…
Ja, das ist übrigens ein ganz enormes Missverständnis. Ich war ja bei so einer Veranstaltung über Wissenschaftskommunikation, wo ich auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen habe, dass durchaus Sozialwissenschaftler vor Ort waren, aber eben für diese Therapie treu. Weil die Wissenschaftler so, ne, da waren ja nur Virologen. Ich so, ne, da waren noch Psychologen. Und die haben sich im Sinne des Ethikrats, wie kriegen wir das jetzt jetzt durchgesetzt? Also haben sozusagen Beschleunigungsfantasien der Politik, wir können nicht erst ein Gesetz machen, das muss ab morgen gelten und so. Und dann hat man sich da die Expertise geholt. Und da fragt man sich ja, wieso hat sie sich für den Rest nicht auch mal eine sozialwissenschaftliche Expertise? Es muss ja nicht immer die Therapietreue für, wie wir heute sagen, wenn auch inhaltlich gerechtfertigt, relativ autokratische politische Entscheidungen. Ja, also da sind so kleine Defizite, da sollte man durchaus mal ein bisschen strenger reingehen. Aber ich finde seine generelle Abklärung der Expertokratie natürlich gut, wie auch den Rechtspopulismus, wo er noch mal beschreibt, es gibt Populismus, der die Demokratie nicht gleich abschaffen will, was mich ja noch mal bestärkt in meiner Bewerbung, um grüner Populismus-Beauftragter zu werden. Das geht also konform mit der Lobhudelei der Demokratie.
Ja, bald nicht mehr, wenn wir noch weiter im Buch fortschreiten. Ich habe auch selten so eine gute Kritik an Muff und Co. Er geht dann noch auf die Governance ein, also dass man sagt, man braucht viel mehr Partizipation. Das ist ja auch so ein Angebot, Bürgerrat, etc. Das bringt aber dann wieder ganz eigene Probleme mit sich. Und zwar wird da oft verschleiert, dass es eine Interessendurchsetzung gibt. Man spricht dann am liebsten nur noch von Koordination und Management. Dabei geht es natürlich um Interessendurchsetzung. Und was auch dann der Punkt ist, dass man eigentlich bei so einem Partizipationstheater ankommt. Er sagt, de facto gibt es wahnsinnig viele partizipative Möglichkeiten inzwischen. Aber es ist auch so, dass sich eigentlich so gut wie nichts mehr ändert dadurch. Das heißt, wir haben die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Bürgerräte. Aber sind die wirklich entscheidend für das, was zählt? Nein, sind sie nicht. Und es ist am Ende auch wieder eine Elitenbildung. Also es sind die Besserverdienenden, die sich damit beschäftigen. Er sagt dann hier an einer Stelle, die Hoffnung auf mehr Freiheit, Gleichheit und Solidarität, die früher mit der Partizipatorischen Revolution verbunden wurden und gegenwärtig mit partizipativer Governance verknüpft werden, erfüllen sich nicht mehr. Partizipation führt nicht zu mehr Demokratie, weil sie in hohem Maße sozial selektiv ist. Die Kernbereiche von Herrschaft werden weiterhin von effektiver demokratischer Beteiligung abgeschirmt und die Verteilung von Machtmitteln innerhalb der Bürgerschaften ist ungebrochen asymmetrisch. Aufgrund der Vermehrung der Entscheidungsbeteiligten und der Stakeholder im Kontext partizipativer Governance entstand, wie ausgerechnet der konservative Niklas Luhmann erkannte, eine Intransparenz der Machtverhältnisse mit Begünstigung der Insider, die genau dies durchschauen und in diesem trüben Wasser sehen und schwimmen können. Eigentlich das, was du jetzt eben beschrieben hast. Ja, der Bürgermeister trifft sich da zwar mit irgendwelchen Initiativen und Bürgern, aber nur mit jenen Bürgern, die wissen, wie man überhaupt an einen Termin mit dem Bürgermeister rankommt.
Ja, so muss man es sehen, also bei dem Populismus. Ich habe mir so ein paar Sachen rausgeschrieben. Die retrograde Revolte der Populismus erschreibt, die soziale Homogenität wird auch dadurch vermindert, dass in Folge von anhaltender Zuwanderung und einer vernachlässigten politischen Integration die Gruppe der Zugewanderten und die Gruppe der Bürgerschaftsmitglieder in den Demokratien immer weiter auseinandergehen. Ich finde auch hier wieder, das ist halt historisch plausibel, aber geht da hier nicht auch so eine Idee auf dem Leim im Sinne von ich schreibe ein Buch über Demokratie, also muss ich irgendwo Hashtag, Integration, Gruppe der Zugewanderten weiter auseinander im Verhältnis zur Bürgerschaft? Oder sollte man das nicht irgendwie direkt konstruktiv wenden, dass hier eben Arenenverletzungen stattfinden im Sinne von ja, also wenn die Bürgerschaft es so organisiert und auf welcher Intransparenz und Aufklärungsmangel auch immer so organisiert, dass man auf der einen Seite sagt, uns fehlen Fachleute und dann kommt ein Informatiker, aber der darf nur als Bäcker arbeiten, dann braucht man keine Theoriearbeit dazu oder so, das kann man dann einfach kurz nennen, wie das im Fernsehen so präsentiert wird, und sich dann einfach sagen, ok, das macht wenig Sinn. Dadurch entsteht ein relativ großes Segment an Menschen, die dauerhaft auf einem Staatsgebiet leben, aber dort über nur eingeschränkte Bürgerrechte verfügen. Sie sind Subjekte zweiter Klasse, können als ein vermeintlich fremdes Kollektiv markiert werden und sind damit eine Zielscheibe für rechtspopulistische Agitation. Da würde ich nochmal darauf hinweisen, diese Argumente für Universalismus kommen aus einer gleichen verherrlichenden Richtung wie diese Demokratie-Theorie. Aber sie haben auch einen funktionalen Kern. Hinsichtlich, wenn wir die Beobachtung haben, dass sich Menschen immer weniger aufgehoben fühlen, also sie haben eine Wahlstimme, aber selbst mit der sehen sie, die Bundestagswahl des ersten drei Jahren, ich bin aber jetzt unzufrieden, für mich geht das nicht unter einen Hut. Warum man dann plötzlich sagt, dann sollen andere erst gar nicht wählen, niemals in die Bürgerschaft aufgenommen werden, sondern da könnte man ja auch wieder einfach hinweisen auf so eine Diskussion, die rein logisch doch eigentlich stattfinden möchte, so wie es die sächsische Sozialministerin schrieb in ihrem Buch, integriert doch erstmal uns. Mit diesem allein des Titels. Der Titel gibt es schon her. Wir haben nichts dagegen, dass ihr Ausländer integriert, aber integriert doch erstmal uns. Oder aufgreift dieses, ich fühle mich fremd in meinem Land, ich verstehe es nicht mehr, ich wünsche mir Deutschland, aber normal. So, solche Sachen, die vermisse ich hier irgendwie als Diskussions-, weil ich glaube, da stecken doch diese einzelnen Prinzipien drin, bei denen man dann auch mal kontrafaktisch, so wie beim Thema Aufklärung, dass man nicht einfach sagt, naja, es fehlt Aufklärung. Nee, komm, Autor, stell dich nochmal der Diskussion. Es ist nicht einfach nur so die Aufklärung, es ist nicht einfach nur so die Fremden, sondern es gibt so Gemengelagen.
Ja, ich will dir gar nicht widersprechen, aber ich will eine ketzerische Frage stellen. Jetzt reden wir immer viel über die anderen, also die, die ein bisschen Verschwörungstheoretisch unterwegs sind oder nicht so ganz integriert sind, was auch immer. Reden wir mal über uns. Also wenn wir dieses Buch jetzt mal nur auf uns beziehen, wir lesen das mal ganz identifikatorisch, dann sind ja diese Demokratiedevolutionen, die er hier beschreibt, diese verschiedenen Faktoren, welche, die wir auch in großen Teilen nachvollziehen können, ich würde fast sagen spüren, aber spüren ist das falsche Wort dafür. Also das heißt, dass die EU große Demokratiedefizite hat. Dass wir es mit einer Zunahme von Governanzen zu tun haben, die dafür sorgen, dass man gar nicht mehr so leicht sagen kann, naja, dann enteignen wir mal die Wohnungskonzerne oder so. Also dass wir diese Handlungsspielräume, die sehr beschränkt sind, das alles erleben wir doch auch und darum wissen wir. Jetzt führt uns das wohl auch deshalb, weil wir gut integriert sind, sozial wie ökonomisch, beruflich, Anerkennung etc. nicht dazu, dass wir uns radikalisieren und irgendwo wild auf der Straße rumrennen und sagen, es ist ja alles nur noch Schein oder so. Aber wenn wir uns tief befragen, dann stimmen wir ja diesen Diagnosen über die aktuelle Verfasstheit der Demokratie zu. Und dann bedeutet das doch eigentlich, dass wir dieses Arrangement Demokratie, wie es jetzt gerade ist, in den Defiziten zwar erkennen, aber sagen, wir können einigermaßen uns gut dadurch bewegen. Vielleicht können wir noch auf der lokalen Ebene was auslösen, dass wir hier mal ein Schwimmbad bekommen. Aber es ist ja auch eigentlich eine sehr fast fatalistische Haltung, die wir einnehmen, oder?
Und gegen die will ich ja gleich anargumentieren.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wie. Okay, aber dann lassen wir das mal so in den Raum.
Na, ich will es mal direkt aufgreifen. Also ich lese mal, ich habe ja eben schon zwei Teile vorgelesen, die ich kurz kommentiert habe, die direkt zusammenhängen. Und ich lese jetzt direkt weiter in diesem Text. Also ich mache jetzt keine Sprünge durchs Buch, sondern das dritte, ich schließe das direkt an.
Ich will nur sagen, du sitzt ja nicht hier mit mir zusammen und sagst, Mensch, was freuen wir uns schon auf die Europawahl? Das wird aber bestimmt eine große Veränderung bringen.
Ich sage mal so, die Europawahl, Europa. Ich stelle dich mal in den Raum.
Wenn Hessenwahl ist, sagst du dann, Mensch, das wird wieder ein tolles Fest der Demokratie sein?
Ich nähe mich gleich mal genau dieser Problemlage. Also ich habe eben schon gesagt, er kommt mit, die soziale Hochguminität ist nicht mehr da, es gibt Zuwanderung, die Gruppen entzweien sich. Also er ist eins zu eins mit dem, was man auch heute schon sieht. Relativ große Segmente von Menschen gestehen den Zugewandten die Bürgerrechte nicht mehr zu, obwohl man doch auch hier so ein allgemeines Argument machen müsste, irgendwas mit Universalismus. Dieser Text geht dann weiter. Zudem hat sich in den Demokratien ein Multikulturalismus herausgebildet, also auch hier wieder einfach ein Nachrichtensignal statt einen Grundbegriff aufgegriffen, woraus sich eine verstärkte Differenzerfahrung ergibt. Hinzu kommen die mit dem Niedergang des demokratischen Kapitalismus einhergehende sozioökonomische Ungleichheit, also Armut, und das über sozialselektive Bildungsinstitutionen erzeugte Bildungsgefälle. Also Menschen können sich nicht mehr am eigenen Schopf herausziehen, sondern Herkunft entscheidet. All diese Differenzen und die mit ihnen einhergehenden Konflikte wurden bisher nicht hinreichend repräsentiert und dadurch nicht politisch integriert. Also die Politik ist nicht mehr in der Lage, einen Aufhangbecken für diese Problemlagen zu bilden. Da würde ich jetzt sagen, das ist, also so zu schreiben, ist ein Ergebnis von zu viel Fernsehen gucken vielleicht. Denn im Fernsehen wird auch immer verwechselt, Politik ist gleich Demokratie und Politik ist immer Bundesliga. Was macht eigentlich der Bundeskanzler mit meinem Problem? Und da würde ich sagen, ne, wir haben in Deutschland Gefüge aus Ländern, du hast sie eben auch schon genannt, und die, die Bund, genau, und dann kommen die Städte, die Kommunen, die spielen ja eigentlich nirgendwo eine Rolle. Und wir wissen aber aus diesen Rechnungen, 24 Prozent der Aufgaben, 14 Prozent des Geldes. Angenommen, das wäre umgekehrt. Wir hätten 24 Prozent des Geldes für nur 14 Prozent der Aufgaben. Was zum Beispiel hieße, keine Stadt hätte ein Problem damit zu sagen, ach, wir haben eine Bevölkerungsprognose von so und so viel, ja, dann bauen wir mal den Stadtteil. Öffentliches Geld, es ist einfach da. Und in diesem Stadtteil gibt es dann auch die 15-Minuten-Wege usw. Hierfür mangelt es nicht an Geld. Und meine These ist, wenn wir das einfach nur im Rahmen der Demokratie anders organisieren, hätten wir diese Art von Repräsentanzproblemen nicht. Sie werden uns medial vermittelt. Irgendwelche Leute in Sachsen machen sich Gedanken über die Einwanderung in Baden-Württemberg und haben gehört, dass oben an der Küste, 500 km von ihnen weg, oder vielleicht sogar in England oder wo auch immer, es hat gar nichts mit ihnen zu tun, Ausländerprobleme entsteht. Diese Integration von Themen, dass man sich verstanden fühlt, repräsentiert fühlt, eine Adresse für sein Anliegen hat usw. kann man gar nicht auf der Ebene lösen, auf der wir heute diese Probleme beobachten. Was macht eigentlich der Kanzler? Warum trifft der Finanzminister so komische Entscheidungen? Uns könnte doch scheißegal sein, welche Verteidigungsetats Pistorius von Lindner zugestanden bekommt, solange völlig klar ist, mein Kind ist heute in der Schule, da ist es gut aufgehoben, ich kann meinem Tag nachgehen. Und das ist dann wirklich wie vor 50 Jahren. Man kann einfach darauf vertrauen, dass diese Sachen funktionieren. Stattdessen, das Problem ist ja nicht, dass man sich heute usw. ein Wissensdefizit hat, sondern das Problem ist, wir glauben heute, wenn wir das Wissensproblem nicht lösen, wenn wir uns nicht wie Verschwörungstheoretiker rein nerden, in wie funktioniert der Bundestag usw., dann kommen wir hier nicht mehr zu Potte. Das ist aber eine völlig vielgeleitete Idee. Aufklärung führt hier nicht weiter, sondern einfach das grundlegende Leben wieder organisieren, wie früher, als alle in ihren Dörfern, in ihren kleinen Städten usw. Und dann funktioniert da einfach der Alltag.
Würde Veith Selk sagen, nichts dagegen ist aber nicht. Also er diagnostiziert ja nur, was er ist.
Aber er argumentiert leider auch nicht in diese Richtung.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht das Anliegen. Er hat jetzt hier wirklich kein Buch geschrieben, das in irgendeiner Weise zeigt, wie man die Demokratie retten kann. Also es ist ein Buch, das Dekonstruktion ist.
Das kritisiere ich ja, aber ich würde gerne die Demokratie retten und ich werde es gleich ausführen.
Ich finde das bei einer wissenschaftlichen Arbeit völlig okay, erstmal in der Negation zu verharren.
Aber da muss man unterschreiben, dass der Sequel kommt.
Ne, muss man nicht. Also ich finde, man kann sagen, ich weiß keinen Ausweg. Ich wollte das Bild erst am Ende nehmen, aber was der eigentlich jetzt macht, wir kommen ja jetzt zu den Demokratie-Theoretikern. Wir sind ja jetzt einfach noch bei der Bestandsauffassung, die Demokratie-Theoretiker. Wir müssen uns da vielleicht ein bisschen sputen, aber wir schaffen es. Was macht er mit denen? Der macht mit denen das, was im Comic passiert, mit der Figur, die über den Abgrund hinaus ist. Und die hat er aber noch nicht runtergeguckt. Und der, der Selk nimmt jetzt diese ganzen Leute, Chantal Mouf, Jürgen Hammermas, nimmt die immer mit, sagt, komm mal her, und schiebt die über den Abgrund und sagt am Ende, ich bin mal gespannt, ob die auch runterguckt und dann fällt oder was passiert. Das macht er. Also es ist sehr, sehr böse Art, ich möchte mal was sagen. Und er kommt dann zu diesen Demokratietheorien und sagt, die scheitern alle samt. Er sagt, in diesem Sinne meine ich, dass sowohl die Idee der Demokratie als auch Demokratietheorien zunehmend unplausibel werden. Also diese Versprechen der Demokratie und der Demokratietheorie, die lösen sich ja nicht ein, wie jetzt eben diagnostiziert bei den verschiedenen Modellen. Bei den verschiedenen Problemen, die er aufführt. Jetzt kommt er zu den Demokratiemodellen. Da ist erst das radikaldemokratische Modell. Das sagt, wir brauchen also ein Primat des Politischen. Wir müssen eine Demokratisierung aller Bereiche vornehmen. Wir müssen also jetzt sehen, dass wir tatsächlich zu einer radikalen Demokratie kommen, zu einem Republikanismus. Wie auch immer das dann genau geartet ist. Manche sehen darin auch so etwas wie direkte Demokratie. Auf die Theoretikerin, die er sich bezieht, kann man das nicht Münzen. Das ist Chantal Mouffe, die sagt, wir brauchen ein radikales Demokratieprojekt. Dann skizziert er so ein bisschen, worauf die eigentlich hinaus wollen. Mouffe und Laclo, vor allem, das war ja das philosophisch-politologische Ehepaar, das diese Theorie dann in die Welt hinausgetragen hat. Und bis heute wird sie stark rezipiert. Sie hat ja diese Idee, wir müssen in ein agonales Verhältnis drehen. Wir müssen also den Parlamentarismus nicht als Freund und Feind, aber doch im Sinne einer Gegnerschaft erkennen und brauchen deshalb auch, um zum Beispiel gegen das Informationsdefizit anzukommen, nicht mehr Informationen, sondern mehr Emotionen. Also es darf durchaus Gefühlspolitik gemacht werden. Es darf auch so etwas wie einen linken oder grünen oder sonstigen ökologischen Populismus geben. Und er sagt dazu Folgendes, das zitiere ich noch, dann bist du wieder dran. Das Scheitern radikaler Demokratietheorie lässt sich prägnant anhand von MUFs Modell einer agonalen Demokratie aufzeigen. Denn MUF geht es ja mit ihrer Demokratietheorie nicht nur darum, die Institutionen repräsentativer Demokratie gegenüber der Linken zu rechtfertigen. Ihre Theorie stellt im gleichen Maße eine demokratietheoretische Apologie linker Hegemonie-Politik dar. Das heißt, das Projekt einer sozialistischen Gesellschaftsumgestaltung soll als ein genuin demokratisches Projekt ausgewiesen werden. Jetzt ist es gar nicht so, dass er etwas dagegen hat, sondern er sagt, diese linke Hegemonie, die MUF seit Jahrzehnten einfordert und die viele nach ihr einfordern, die entsteht ja nirgends. Das heißt, dieses Demokratie-Modell wird von der Zeitdiagnose, die Selk macht, widerlegt.
Also ich möchte final zu diesem Buch sagen.
Wir sind doch nicht mal Finale. Das war jetzt Modell 1. Das zweite ist dein Lieblingsmodell. Das deliberative Modell Jürgen Habermas. Jürgen Habermas möchte das aufgeklärte Subjekt haben, das dann im herrschaftsfreien Diskurs diskutiert, was zu tun ist, was zu lassen ist. Aber was Selk hier schreibt, dass diese primäre, diese deliberative Theorie primär auf das Continuum und die Kommunikationsverhältnisse, die sich zwischen den beiden Polen befinden, dem Subjekt auf der einen und dem Kollektiv auf der anderen Seite bezieht. Hauptgegenstand dieser Theorie ist damit der für die Demokratie als relevant erachtete kommunikative Zwischenraum von Individuen, Institutionen und der politischen Gemeinschaft. Um das für die Leute, die da nicht so in Habermas sind, kurz zu machen. Es gibt Politiker und es gibt ganz viel in der Gesellschaft. Intellektuelle wie Habermas selbst, Verbände, Vereine und so weiter. Jetzt gibt es zwischen diesen Interessengruppen und der Politik einen kommunikativen Zwischenraum, in dem entsteht der Wunsch nach günstigerem Wohnraum. Und dann tritt man in einen vernünftigen Diskurs ein, wie ist das sinnvoll zu regeln, wo sind die Mehrheiten, welche Wünsche sind realistisch umsetzbar. Und dann muss die Politik das, was dort entstanden ist, nehmen, in Gesetze gießen und sagen, ab sofort haben wir eine Mietpreisbremse.
Wenn du mich einlättest, Habermas nochmal und so, du hast ja dieses schöne Bild, man steht oben an der Klippe und lässt sie einfach mal springen und gucken, ob sie es überleben. Diese Theorien, die hier genannt werden, allen vor allem Habermas, liegt schon seit Jahrzehnten unten tot, zermatscht, unsichtbar, im Wasser, es ist alles schon weg.
Entschuldigung mal. Bei dir und bei deinen Lumavianern.
Bei mir und bei allen, die vernünftig darüber nachdenken. Ich weiß, das ist ja das große Problem, deswegen ist ja das Buch auch wichtig.
Da ist ja der Wunschvater des Gedankens, das mag ja sein, dass du das längst durchgespielt hast.
Er hat ja die richtigen Zitate hier rausgeholt. Die politische Kommunikationspraxis soll vielmehr auch die und an Original Habermas rationale Lösung pragmatischer, moralischer und ethischer Fragen ermöglichen. Und die Zitat Vermutung der Vernünftigkeit ihrer Ergebnisse und dadurch demokratische Legitimität begründen. Wer heute noch erwartet, dass irgendetwas pragmatisch, moralisch und ethisch rational abläuft.
Und dass auch eine Voraussetzung, die gewählten Repräsentanten es besser wissen als die Bürger.
Ja, der hat die Demokratie nicht verdient und dem wird sie auch zu Recht zerschlagen. Denn mit so einer Kindergartenhaltung darf man einfach nicht mehr rangehen. Dass man dann unzufrieden scheitert und die ganze Welt für blöd hält, verstehe ich. Aber da nützt es nichts weiter zu diskutieren. Man muss davon jetzt Abstand nehmen. Habermas hat sich selber –und er erwähnt ihn auch nochmal –Ja, das ist ja ganz toll, dass er das macht. Du hast in dem Text mitgebracht, wie Habermas über das Social-Media-Zeitalter spricht und feststellt, ich hatte eine Idee von Delibration, viele nehmen teil und dann kommt irgendwann ein vernünftiges Konsens-Argumentationsmuster heraus, alle sind zufrieden. Und Habermas sagt dann selber, ne, die Theorie hält nicht stand, dass am Ende wirklich Leute teilnehmen an diesen Gesprächen.
Und Habermas stimmt ja sogar der Postdemokratie-These von Colin Crouch inzwischen zu.
Also wenn Habermas selber den schärfsten Kritiken heute zustimmt, was seine Theorie angeht, darf man nicht mehr diese Verherrlichung von ach ja, der Habermas und so weiter, nein, aussatieren jetzt, Schluss. Sehr gut, dass der Veit das auch nochmal macht.
Aber Veit macht das wirklich mit allen Waffen, die zur Verfügung stehen und macht das aber so elegant und präzise, dass man fast niederknien möchte. So schön ist das gemacht. Ich will gleich noch auf einen anderen Aspekt einkommen, will nur kurz verdeutlichen. Habermas Demokratie Theorie ist weiterhin sehr einflussreich. Eine bekannte Adeptin ist Carolin Imke, die dafür mit Preisen ausgezeichnet wird.
Die schreibt auch nur Scheiße.
Es gibt ganz viele Interviews bei Tilo, die ich gehört habe, mit Transformationswissenschaftlern, die sich alle auf Habermas beziehen. Und ich höre mir das an und sage, ja, das wäre eine schöne Sache, wenn das so wäre. Ist aber nicht. Wir haben nicht, wie sich Habermas wünscht, eine vitale Bürgergesellschaft. Also das ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Weißt du, warum wir sie nicht haben? Man muss es auch ganz deutlich sagen. Weil die Menschen besseres zu tun haben. Es können nicht alle nur Politik machen. Wir haben eine funktional differenzierte Gesellschaft, in der wir ganz viele Bedürfnisse haben, die gestillt werden müssen. Gute politische Entscheidungen sind nur eins von vielem. Die Leute wollen essen, die Leute wollen wohnen, die wollen die Kinder betreut haben. Einfach jetzt alle in so einen politischen Prozess des Gesprächs hinein zu zwängen, ist wirklich genauso dämlich wie, keine Ahnung, dieses neue Bürgerrat-Ding. Und dann hofft man einfach mal, dass die Leute so Zeit haben dafür und dann da irgendwie hingehen. Und es sie auch noch interessiert. Oder, genauso dumm, eine Werbpflicht. Wir können nicht 700.000 Leute in einem Jahrgang in die Werbpflicht stecken für ein Jahr. Wir brauchen die für was anderes. Und da nützt mir auch das schwedische Modell nicht, nur einen Tag sie zu einem Kreiswehrersatzamt zu schicken, damit sie da mal irgendwas und so. Nein, nicht mal dafür haben wir Zeit. Diese Theorien funktionieren einfach alle nicht.
Dann gibt es das dritte Modell, das liberale Modell, das hat keinen besonders hohen Anspruch. Das legt ja Wert auf das bürgerliche Subjekt, also ist fest mit dem bürgerlichen Recht und der bürgerlichen Gesellschaft zusammen. Da hat man aber auch eine undemokratische Tendenz deshalb, weil man schon da akzeptiert, es gibt eine Elite. Innerhalb dieser Elite gibt es einen Wettbewerb. Und der drückt sich dann zum Beispiel in Wahlen aus. Man kann die einen oder die anderen wählen. Aber man hat eine Elitenherrschaft. Und da ist auch die Frage, wenn alles so sehr ausdifferenziert ist, dann ist also diese Idee vom Wahlvolk, das entscheidet, diese Elite oder jene, nicht mehr so einfach zu treffen. Das heißt also, diese Idee, die es da gibt von einer Spaltung der Spitze, wie das ja dann auch Luhmann beschrieben hat, den er hier zitiert, das ist natürlich da nicht mehr möglich, wo man diese Ausdifferenzierung hat. Also, wen soll ich jetzt wählen? Diese Frage wird schwierig, wenn ich verschiedene Interessen habe, die vertreten werden sollen. Dann ist das nicht mehr alles durch eine Partei abgedeckt und damit wird das ganz kompliziert. Und bedeutet dann also, dass dieses Modell schon aufgrund dieser Komplexität. Nicht funktionsfähig ist, eher diffuse Ängste produziert. Und dann gibt es als viertes Kapitel diese Demokratie-Vergewisserung. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt ganz viele Texte, die erscheinen, die einfach nur noch mal mitteilen, wie toll eigentlich Demokratie ist. Ja, es gibt zwar so ein paar Probleme von Rechten vor allem, aber diese Rechten, die müssen wir mal gucken, was wir damit machen. Aber eigentlich ist die Demokratie toll. Und da gibt es diese Formulierung schon immer. Also da wird dann immer so gemacht, was die Demokratie eigentlich ist. Und hier, das war für mich einfach sehr gut zu lesen. Er beschäftigt sich da mit Isabelle Laurie. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du sie kennst, die Philosophin. Die ja auch einflussreich ist, so in den geisteswissenschaftlichen Gefilden. Also du hast unter Habermas, du hast ja nicht bei ihm studiert oder so, du hast aber unter diesem Denken sehr gelitten, wie du eben gesagt, du hast dem Ausdruck verholfen, dass das etwas ist, was dich immer sehr gequält hat, wenn es um deliberative Demokratie ging.
Also heute, wo wir das in solchen Büchern, und du sagst dann, aber das findet ja ganz viel, und dann hört man hunderte Stunden Jung und Naiv und die ganze Zeit wird es propagiert. Darunter leide ich. Damals im Studium war das natürlich super instruktiv, einfach die ganze gute Theoriearbeit, Systemtheorie, der ganze Kram, ist ja nicht die einzige, die gut ist, abzuarbeiten an diesen Sachen, die einfach wirklich blöd sind. Und das ist dieses, also ich will nicht sagen, dass Habermas blöd ist. Habermas hat auch kluge Sachen geschrieben, und da stecken sehr viele inspirative Gedanken drin. Aber die Theorie, das Gesamtbild, die Paradegmen und was er darauf aufbaut, was dann mündet in diesem Jahr, es reden einfach nur alle miteinander und nehmen sich ganz viel Zeit, und am Ende kommt schon was Vernünftiges darum. Das ist einfach wirklich Quatsch. Und das ist aber so attraktiv für so viele Leute, dass man darunter leiden kann, weil so gehen wir leider den Schritt nicht vorwärts, den ich gleich vorschlage, wie wir gehen müssten.
Wir kennen ja all diese populären Sachbücher, die dann auf 50 Seiten nochmal schreiben, und so stelle ich mir die Zukunft vor. Und dann wird da irgendein Mischmasch, und ich denke, ja, das hat mit der Wirklichkeit aber überhaupt nichts zu tun. Und das ist ja etwas, was Selk immer wieder deutlich macht. Er guckt und sagt, also, kann so ein Projekt der linken Hegemonie von Chantal Mouffe sinnvoll sein? Möglicherweise trifft es mit der Wirklichkeit zusammen, sieht man, nichts dergleichen ist zu beobachten. Also scheint ja irgendwas mit diesem Modell nicht mehr so ganz zu stimmen.
Ich möchte klare Urteile sprechen in diesem Falle. Wir haben diesen Monat dieses Buch Wir von unserem Frank-Walter-Schneinmeier-Bundespräsidenten. Die Rezensionen, die natürlich pflichtbewusst stattfinden, machen sich alle lustig über dieses Buch. Und niemand, der dieses Buch mit, also zu Recht lustig findet, kann ernsthaft ein Carolin Imke Buch lesen. Wir haben es auf ganz vielen Ebenen, dass wir uns hier mal über Sachen lustig machen müssen.
Ja, ich finde auch. Und ich bin ja vielmehr gebeutelt durch die Geisteswissenschaften und durch, ja, da gewisse Strömungen in den Geisteswissenschaften, auch durch vor allem dann moderne Kunst, Performance, Theater und so. Ich will hier nicht alles übereinkommen scheren. Aber ich will sagen, dass dort so eine Art des Sprechens und demokratisch Seins vorherrscht, das mich so sehr abschreckt. Ich bekomme manchmal die Frage, wie kam das eigentlich, dass du so als Linker dich für Ernst Jünger interessiert? Ich glaube, wenn ich ganz tief in mir bohre, dann nur aus einem einzigen Grund, weil ich den anderen Rahmen nicht mehr getragen habe und dachte, toll, bei Ernst Jünger wird wenigstens noch geschossen. Also das war wirklich bei mir diese Idee. Und ich will das als Beispiel hier wirklich nur als Schiff ranführen, was er da über Isabel Lohr gesagt hat, weil das so typisch ist für alles, was ich stark erleiden musste in den Geisteswissenschaften. Also diese Vergewisserungen vermitteln einen Eindruck von Lohr's Deal, der karnevalesken Anrufung von Demokratie, in dem sie eine verrätzelnde Rhetorik und die Technik des automatischen Schreibens mit dem Vokabular des bewegungsförmigen Politikaktivismus zu einem parodistischen Demokratie-Theorie-Happening verbindet. In dieser Theorie-Performance wird Demokratie mit vitalistisch-romantischen Beschwörungsformeln enthistorisiert. Von der Demokratie im Präsens heißt es dort. Und dann zitiert er, und das muss man sich jetzt auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, weil das könnte in jedem zweiten Programmheft in einem Theater stehen. Sie ist ein werden, ein unentweigtes demokratisch werden in der Jetztzeit der konstituierenden Prozesse. Ihre Wiederholung in Zeit und Raum ist transversale Wiederkehr aus den affizierenden Machtbeziehungen heraus. Wiederholen und differenzieren sich Sprünge und Tänze des Widerstands, transversale Konstellationen, Verschuldungen auf Distanz. Und das ist Dokumenta. Das ist Kulturzeit.
Ganz genau. So, die konstruktive Wende.
Also jetzt kommen wir zu deinem Fazit. Also er sagt dann auch mal Paradigmenwechsel, was das bedeutet bei Kuhn. Brauchen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt, wir müssen sagen, es gibt da Denkzwänge.
Du kannst noch so lange reden über das Buch wie der Welt.
Ich will gar nicht beschleunigen. Also was er jetzt beschreibt, ist unter diesen ganzen Demokratie-Theoretikern und Vergewisserern. Gibt es Denkzwänge und eine Denksolidarität. Und die geht über das Kollegiale hinaus auch. Wir müssen auch vor allem, weil wir Demokraten sind, nochmal vergewissern und uns in diesem Zwang befinden. Er sagt aber, dadurch wird nicht mehr betrachtet, dass es diese Devolution der Demokratie gibt. Was daraus folgt, kann er noch nicht sagen. Möglicherweise setzt sich sehr stark eine postkolonialistische Theorie durch, bei der er aber sagt, Vorsicht, die hat ganz stark auch antidemokratische Tendenzen, indem sie sagt, die Demokratie ist eh so ein westliches Konstrukt und das ist kolonialistisch. Also hier sieht man auch nochmal, welche eigentlichen Kämpfe wir gerade führen. Und ich glaube, das zeigt sich auch gerade an den Universitäten, da mit Nahostkonflikt. Es geht nochmal um sehr viel mehr als um das Konkrete, was da in Nahost stattfindet. Also dass es zwar demokratisierende Tendenzen im Kolonialismus gibt, aber auch ganz stark, die dann sagen, wir sehen jetzt den Tribalismus als unser Alternativmodell, was dann ja auch bis dahin zuführt, dass irgendwelche Leute sich mit der Hamas solidarisieren oder so. Darauf geht er jetzt nicht ein, aber das führe ich jetzt mal so weiter. Oder es geht man noch lange Zeit einfach so weiter. Also man steht über den Abgrund, fliegt einfach nicht runter, weil sich jetzt alles in diesen verschiedenen Institutionen so verfestigt hat. Die werden ja jetzt noch 20, 30 Jahre weiter sagen können, dass die Demokratie wunderbar partizipativ ist. Und damit sagt man einfach, gucke ich mal, was dann passiert. Und jetzt möchte ich deine optimistische Wende, deine Vision.
Also zum einen möchte ich noch mal sagen, ich finde den Grundbegriff Devolution sehr gut. Er ist sehr nützlich, den werden wir viel brauchen. Es ist einfach das Gegenteil von Evolution. Und hier beginnt es. Die Evolution, ja, es gibt das als biologischen Grundbegriff. Sachen passieren, Zellen teilen sich. Und dann findet ein Selektionsprozess statt, über den nicht noch mal diskutiert wird, sondern die Natur sortiert einfach aus. Noch mal darüber zu diskutieren, kann man, aber es wird an den natürlichen Sachverhalten nichts ändern. Was aussortiert wird, wird aussortiert. Nun haben wir bei der Demokratie eine Evolution, die wir unterstellen. Also irgendwann begannen sie mal als Idee. Und da sie ja als Idee begannen, kann man ja den Ideenschleier immer mitschleifen und hoffen, dass die Demokratie sie so hinsichtlich der guten Idee mitentwickelt. Nur, die Demokratie entstand nicht aus einer Idee, sondern die Demokratie war eine Antwort fast nach natürlichem Selektionsprozess, sozialem Selektionsprozess, zu Leistungsanforderungen, die gestellt wurden. Also aus Dörfern, wo man sich kennt, zog man in die Stadt und war plötzlich unter Unbekannten. Wie geht denn das? Man muss sich ja koordinieren mit Unbekannten. Man kann ja nicht jedem sagen, ich habe Angst vor dir, ich haue dich mal tot. Nein, das geht natürlich nicht. Also hat man irgendwann versucht, die Sachen zu regeln. Man hat Geld an die Hand bekommen, Urteile, Gesetze, Recht. Irgendwer hat gesagt, wir sollten auch mal darüber reden, was jetzt als Gesetz gilt. Okay, also reden wir mal darüber. Und irgendwann hat man halt gesagt, okay, das ist interessant, wir haben ja so ein Parlament und dann haben wir so verschiedene Regeln. Wir nennen es mal Demokratie. Und schon da, finde ich, kann man jetzt mal einhaken und sagen, nicht nur brauchen wir keine Demokratie-Theorie, die die Sachen, wie sie sind oder sein sollten, verherrlicht wie so ein sozialistisches, historisches Buch, wo einfach die ersten 20 Seiten nochmal reserviert wurden für ein abfeierndes Sozialismus, sondern wir brauchen nicht nur diese Theorie nicht, wir brauchen auch diesen Begriff nicht. Demokratie können wir jetzt aussortieren. Wir können ja einfach so einen Dimensionsstrahl aufmachen, wo wir sagen, wir haben verschiedene empirische Politikmodelle auf der Welt, die rangieren von, ja, irgendwer wird immer noch so reingeboren und dann regiert er halt 50 Jahre, keine Ahnung, es geht alles auf Lebenszeit und der hat auch Hoheit über alles. Und dann haben wir eben, und dann kann man ja die Grundbegriffe durchgehen, wir haben eine Trennung von Regierung und Opposition, wir haben eine von politischen Klärungsprozessen, ausgelagerten Zentralbankprozess, solche Sachen.
Der nicht demokratisch ist.
Der zum Beispiel dann nicht demokratisch ist. Und wir haben uns auch darauf geeinigt, dass es ist, wie es ist. Also wir sind nicht überrascht davon, dass es nicht demokratisch ist.
Haben wir uns darauf geeinigt?
So, das ist jetzt diese große Frage. Muss sich jemand darauf einigen? Das soll ja mit aussortiert werden. Wir haben Regierung und Opposition. Wir haben Wahlen alle vier Jahre. Wir haben Amtszeitbegrenzung. Was wir nicht haben, ist, alle haben sich darauf geeinigt. Bitte nicht mehr irgendwelche Texte schreiben, in denen gefordert wird, dass es einen Gesellschaftsvertrag geben soll oder Neuen oder was auch immer. Wir haben uns alle darauf geeinigt, einfach aussortieren. Das steckt nicht mehr drin. Wir nutzen nicht mehr diesen Demokratiebegriff, in dem so ein Quatsch drin steht, sondern niemand hat sich darauf geeinigt.
Das finde ich sinnvoll.
Wir leben einfach hier, wie es hier ist. Das Klima hat hier entsprechende Zustände. Und der politische Prozess eben auch. Was nicht bedeutet, wir können ihn verändern. Wenn jemand will, dass wir uns alle erst einmal darauf einigen, dann bitte einen großen Prozess anleihen, dass wir uns demokratisch eine Mehrheit finden, darauf einigen, dass alle mit 18 Jahren eine Unterschrift leisten, wo man sich darauf verständigt. Ich finde das gut, wie es hier ist. Ansonsten Alternative, ja, was muss dann im Prozess entschieden werden, wandert aus, was auch immer. Wer solche Quatschideen hat, soll sich bitte im demokratischen Prozess Mehrheiten organisieren. Also wir haben Grundprinzipien. Regierung und Opposition, Verfahren, wissenschaftliche Beiräte müssen finanziert werden, wir haben Amtszeitbegrenzungen, wir haben Zeiten, zwischen denen man irgendwo Chef und irgendwo Regierungschef sein kann. Laute solche Sachen, ne? Und die besprechen wir jetzt einfach ohne den Shortcut Demokratie, bei dem niemand genau weiß, was damit gemeint ist. So, und jetzt kommt meine konstruktive Wende. Die Demokratie, wie ich sie jetzt beschrieben habe, also die Sammlung dieser Grundbegriffe, bei denen wir sagen, die sind eigentlich unhintergehbar, können aber durch eine verfassungsgebende Mehrheit oder was immer noch geändert werden, also Amtszeitbegrenzungen können abgeschafft werden, aber jetzt gerade gelten sie. Wir nehmen den Status quo, wie er ist, und damit meinen wir auch, wie er ist und wie er bedroht ist. Und fragen uns jetzt, ist es nicht eigentlich der große Aufbruch der Demokratie? Zeigt sie nicht genau jetzt gerade, was sie leisten kann? Sie ist in Amerika bedroht durch Donald Trump, der irgendwie seine Leute selber anstiftet, einen Sturm aufs Parlament zu machen. Und vier Jahre später gibt es trotzdem noch mal eine demokratische Wahl. Und wir sagen, erstaunlich resilient. Wir können es ja auch mal abfeiern. Also nicht eine Sonntagsrede, wie sollte es die nächsten 30 Jahre sein? Wer sind wir? Und so weiter. Sondern, das haben wir überstanden. Wie haben wir das denn überstanden? Na ja, durch die und die Prinzipien, die wir also erhalten müssen. Wir haben in Deutschland eine Diskussion zum Thema, wie sollten Verfassungsrichter bestellt werden? Vor allem, in welchem Gesetz sollte das denn stehen? Und mit welchen Mehrheiten sind diese Gesetze zu ändern? Und dann gab es ja jetzt die große Resilienzoffensive, bei der dann Friedrich Merz nicht mitmachen wollte, weil er im kleinen, kleines Tagesgeschäft der Ampel keine Zugeständnisse machen wollte, im Sinne von, ja, ich stimme mal mit euch. Ja, das kann man ja dann einfach mal... Also da findet man Themen, die man anders diskutieren kann, als Tagesgeschäft, weil man da nämlich feststellt, ah, Wahlrecht, Frage, wie werden Verfassungsrichter bestellt, welches Mandat und wer erteilt es ihr, hat die EZB und so weiter und so fort. Dann kommt man auf politische Themen, die, wie wir sagen, Themen der Demokratiereflexion, der Demokratietheorie sind, aber ich werbe dafür, davon Abstand zu nehmen, den ganzen historischen Ratten- schwanz der Demokratietheorie, dass man nämlich sagt, bevor die Tagung beginnt zum Thema, wie machen wir jetzt den Bundestag resilient, feiern wir erstmal mit 17 vorgetragenen Präampeln die Geschichte der Demokratie, wie wir uns sie gerne verherrlichen ab. Nein, gar nicht. Jetzt mal pragmatisch runterbrechen. Die demokratischen Prinzipien, die wir haben, benennen, nicht unter einem Deckmantel verstecken, sondern einzeln benennen und dann erklären, warum wir sie schützen müssen, wie wir sie schützen können, sie dann auch wirklich zu schützen, das im Parlament zu diskutieren und so weiter und so fort. Diese Versuche, die es jetzt gibt, in Amerika dem Präsident einzunorden, also die normativen und die juristischen Sachen neu zu ordnen, was ja nicht gut gelingt. Was derzeit in Amerika nicht gut gelingt und wir aber in Europa gerade diskutieren, Macron hat die große Rede gehalten, wir haben diese Resilienzoffensive da am Bundestag. Ich meine damit noch nicht, dass hier irgendwas auf Dauer jetzt immer erfolgreich funktionieren kann und so weiter und so. Aber in dem Moment, wo wir jetzt feststellen, Veith sagt uns, die Demokratie ist bedroht. Wir haben eine De-Evolution. Da würde ich sagen, nein, die Demokratie wird das allererste Mal überhaupt funktional angewendet. Statt einfach nur ewig als Verherrlichungsinstrument mitzubringen, wo man viel zu spät feststellt, wir haben die Leute gar nicht mitgenommen, wir haben irgendwen verpasst.
Aber was machen wir mit denen, die alle nicht mitgenommen sind?
Na, wieder mitnehmen.
Aber von welchem Prozess aus? Wer nimmt die mit?
Wenn wir einen Appell richten wollen.
Ja, aber ich kann ja einen Appell. Das ist ja jetzt so wie Chantal Muf sagt, sie braucht eine Linke gegen die Kommunikation.
Nein, ausdrücklich nicht. Diese Appelle, die sich immer an das Publikum richten, kann man alles sein lassen jetzt. Ich will keine Ansprechungen mehr an irgendwelche AfD-Wähler, irgendwelche Jungen, irgendwas. Ich will jetzt eine Ansprache an die Leistungsrollen.
Aber wir hören doch nicht hin.
Die Washington Post macht jetzt seit Jahren diesen Spruch, Democracy dies in Darkness. Und das stimmt. Es ist die Darkness, wenn man nicht sieht, was da passiert. So, wir haben 700 gewählte Parlamentarier. Von denen wir bei der Hälfte gar nicht wissen, was die eigentlich tun. Die will ich jetzt auf die demokratischen Prinzipien verpflichten.
Wie?
Na ja, indem einfach die Tagesordnung da liegt. Wir machen jetzt das Bundesverfassungsgericht z.B. resilient. So, ich sage nicht, dass die Demokratie nicht untergeht. Ich würde nicht mal sagen, dass das autokratische Modell per se schlechter ist als ein demokratisches. Also ich will da nicht falsch verstanden werden. Ich gehöre nicht zu den Verherrlichern der Demokratie.
Das würde man ja auch sonst übernehmen.
Ich gehöre nicht zu den Verherrlichern der Demokratie. Ich möchte nur, dass die Prinzipien, die sich als leistungsfähig erwiesen haben, erhalten bleiben. Wenn sie abgeschafft werden, muss man halt gucken, was dann passiert. Dann kommt es tatsächlich zum Untergang. Und wenn wir dann irgendwann eine AfD-Mehrheit haben, die sich auf Lebenszeit in irgendwelche Ämter bringt, dann sind wir aber wirklich wissentlich da untergegangen. Also, eine weitere Sonntagsrede nützt uns nicht.
Das wird aber Selk ganz genau so sehen. Die Frage ist nur, jetzt hat ja Selk hier keine Politikberatung gemacht. Das ist ja jetzt ein bisschen bei dir so, dass du jetzt sagst, so könnte man es machen. Nehmen wir doch mal nicht diese extremen Fälle von, die AfD hat die absolute Mehrheit. Sondern sagen wir doch einfach, wir beide wissen um die demokratischen Defizite in der EU und wie furchtbar das ist. Jetzt wissen wir, dass keine Mehrheit entstehen wird, egal wie die Wahl jetzt rausgeht, welche Prognose Recht hat, die dafür sorgt, dass die EU demokratischer gestaltet wird, im Sinne von Transparenz, Funktionaler wird sie, sie geht mehr auf die Bürger und ihre Bedürfnisse ein. Also diese ganz normalen Dinge, die wir wollen, keine hohes Lied der Demokratie, sondern diese ganz funktionalen Geschichten, da wissen wir, dass das ja nicht kommt. Was macht man damit?
Also zum ersten Mal würde ich sagen, wenn wir zum Thema Demokratie im Buch lesen, dann kann das durchaus ein bisschen historisch und empirisch sein. Zum Beispiel bei dem Thema, wir haben jetzt eine europäische Wahl. Die kann man durchaus im Fernsehen mal diskutieren unter dieser Maßgabe. Es wurde immer knallhart einfach Stimmen durchgezählt. Wer die Mehrheiten hat, gewinnt seine Abstimmung. Wir wissen, dass in der Europäischen Union manche Abstimmungen sehr knapp sind, wie zum Beispiel die von Ursula von der Leyen, das neue Kommissionspräsidentin. Sie hat sie also mit Stimmen aus dem damals relativ autokratischen Polen und dem heute immer noch autokratisch regierten Ungarn gewonnen. Das bedeutet, hier hat man ein Stück Demokratie verkauft. Wenn ich jetzt eine nächste politische Ansprache habe, die mich ernst nimmt, dann will ich keinen Zukunftsausblick von Frank Walter, wer wir sein könnten. Ja, so heißt ja dieses Kapitel. Ich will jetzt nicht nur einen Kapitel zum Beispiel, sondern ich will einen Rückblick auf den Abbau der Demokratie die letzten vier Jahre. Wir können ja auch uns darauf einigen, bei einer demokratischen Wahl nicht das Wahlprogramm für die nächsten vier Jahre zu lesen, sondern Journalisten, die wirklich eine Aufgabe suchen, nehmen sich das Wahlprogramm der letzten Wahl und ziehen Bilanz. Wie sähe dann politischer Diskurs aus? So und dann kriegt man auch diese Themen anders mal strukturiert, nur dieses Problem, du hast es ja in den Talkshows besprochen, ist am Ende, ich sage es, wie es ist, wie ich es meine, auch wenn ich es gerade habe, mal es beurteilt habe, aber eine Frage des auch inhaltlichen Diskurses. Wenn wir aber jetzt…
Also doch, das ist nämlich meine Frage, weil du jetzt so sehr diese deliberative Demokratie abgewatscht hast, dass du jetzt zugleich als jemand, der sich in diesem Zwischenraum laufend aufhält, als Podcaster und Publizist, doch eigentlich auch sagst, ich schreibe das jetzt hier in mein Buch rein, hoffe, dass das dann gelesen wird, gut, sogar wenn es Politiker lesen würden und daraus dann etwas erfolgt, wie zum Beispiel ein sinnvolleres Gesetz zur Rente. Das ist hier schon deine deliberative Idee von Demokratie, wo du habermas eigentlich sehr nahe stehst.
Also die AfD ist auch deswegen erfolgreich, weil sie sich wirklich geplant, also in Planungssitzungen hingesetzt hat, um sich zu überlegen, wie organisieren wir den Protest? Wir müssen TikTok übernehmen, so bespielen, dass wir da haushoch überlegen sind. Zweitens, wie wählen wir unsere Themen aus? Also die treffen ja all diese Entscheidungen, die diese Entwicklung voranführt. Diese Planung kann man auch mit anderen Personen und anderen Zielsetzungen genauso treffen. Was eine besondere Aufgabe nicht für das Publikum von Maibrit Illner bedeutet, sondern für die Redaktion von Maibrit Illner. Die Leistungsrollen, die jetzt profitieren von Demokratie, damit sind Amtsträger, Parlamentarier und vor allem dann im reflexiven Diskurs Medienschaffende gemein. Die müssen sich überlegen, ob sie weiterhin für kleine tagesaktuelle und dann würde ich sagen auf falschen Felder errungene ökonomische Gewinne, ah heute wieder mein Publikum, so, opfern, das ist prinzipiell, also im Grunde langfristiges Denken. Man kann mit einer klug gewählten Kontroverse, diese Erfahrung macht ja auch Junge naiv gerade, also wenn es einfach nur darum geht, viel Medien Geld einzusammeln, dann bucht man, macht man die Monetarisierung an bei YouTube und hofft, dass man immer eine Million Views hat, also was macht man, man lädt nur noch AfDler ein. So, kurzfristig für das particuläre Interesse desjenigen, der dann da sitzt und die ganze Zeit die Demokratie verherrlicht, ist das super lukrativ, aber langfristig wissen wir doch wohin das führt.
Aber das glaube ich nicht, dass das jetzt Tilos Impulthürste ist, jetzt ständig AfD-Leute einzuladen.
Nein, aber das Prinzip gilt ja trotzdem. Egal, was Tilo davon hält und wie wir das bewerten. Dieses Prinzip, dass man mit AfDlern, die die Kontroverse nach Hause bringen, sehr viel Geld verdienen kann, das gilt einfach. Egal, welche Bewertung man da dran schließt. Also muss man dem widerstehen. Was bedeutet, wir haben doch ein öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehsystem, das mit Absicht sich keine ökonomischen Fragen stellen muss im tagespolitischen Sendungsplan. Und sie machen es trotzdem, weil sie intern abrechnen, wer nicht im Jahr auf über 10% Quote mit seiner Talkshow kommt, fliegt raus. Und das sind doch diese kleinen Prinzipien. Diese kleinen Werte. Wie organisieren wir eine Talkshow, in der politisches Personal vorstellig wird? Kann man genauso streng organisieren, wie wir trennen zwischen Regierung und Opposition. Da lassen wir doch auch keine Verweichlichung zu und sagen, heute mal wieder keine Fraktionsdisziplin. Es machen einfach alle, was sie wollen. Dem Publikum ist völlig unklar, was demnächst passiert. Was ja auch eins der Probleme in der Europäischen Union ist. Also wir brauchen so ein paar Prinzipien, die nochmal abstrahieren von, ah ja, Demokratie haben wir schon immer so gemacht, denken wir nicht weiter drüber nach. Sondern wir brauchen den Prinzipienkatalog und müssen halt darüber nachdenken, ohne das Publikum die ganze Zeit da zu belästigen. Das schaffen die Leistungsrollen schon selber.
Jaja, aber sie müssen es ja wollen. Und das ist ja, es entsteht ja nicht einfach so, weil du das jetzt hier sagst, dass das dann morgen ausgeführt wird. Und das wäre ja das, was jetzt Veith Selk wieder sagen würde, dass es alles richtig formuliert. Nur die Frage ist, die der Wirkung, die es hat, dass du das sagst, beziehungsweise an wen richtet man das, wenn man jetzt möchte, dass die Talkshows anders besetzt sind, dass die Opposition diese Rolle übernimmt und die Regierung das. Und da sind wir dann bei dieser unglaublich sinnbringenden, aber auch dilemmaproduzierenden Ausdifferenzierung, die dafür sorgt, dass wir hier einen Appell in die Ohren des Publikums senden und wir zugleich aber nicht die Veränderungen herstellen. Und diese Frustration ist extrem groß. Bei fast allen Veranstaltungen, die ich mache, kommt die Frage am Ende, wie ich eigentlich mit der Frustration umgehe. Und das sind ja alles Leute, die politisch informiert sind und so weiter. Also die ja schon ganz viel von dem erfüllen, was jetzt ein Habermaß oder auch eine Muff oder sonst wer von Demokraten erfordern und anfordern. Und das haben sie und trotzdem ist diese Frustration da, weil sie ja bei mir auch da ist. Und das ist ja etwas, was in dem Sinne nicht aufzulösen ist, sondern was hier für mich als Dilemma in so großer Klarheit und Eleganz noch nie beschrieben wurde und auch in diesem ungeheuren Rundumschlag, den Veith Selk hier macht, dass ich sagen muss, das ist eine große Leistung. Er bleibt aber dann an dem Punkt stehen, wo er den Endpunkt gesetzt hat. Alles darüber hinaus müssen wir selbst sehen. Mehr kann ich gar nicht dazu sagen.
Also es gibt zwei Wege. Der soziologisch abgeklärte ist zu sagen, bei so einem Buch, Demokratie, was für ein komischer Begriff, das ist kein Grundbegriff in der Politikwissenschaft, wenn man sie ernst nehmen will, sondern es ist halt ein Modell, das so ein bisschen als Sammelbegriff irgendwas darstellt.
Na ja, aber wir haben jetzt gleich…
Nein, nein, also man kann einfach eiskalt rangehen und sagen, so ich habe jetzt Luhmann gelesen, was für mich bedeutet, meine Rolle ist die des Zuschaus. Ich schaue mir an, wie die Devolution passiert. Dass die Diagnose so weit stimmt, würde ja keiner bestreiten. Also sitzt man dann daneben und kann noch mal ein bisschen klüger beschreiben, wie es kaputt geht. Oder, und dann macht man es aber, finde ich, ein bisschen anders als die Sachen, die hier auch zertrümmert werden, zurecht. Man geht schon so auf Sachen wie, ja, wir brauchen einen besseren Testscores, wir müssen mal ein Appell loswerden, Alarmismus ist nicht falsch. Die Frage, wie vermittel ich denn meine Erkenntnis darüber, dass alles kaputt geht und so weiter, kann man sich ja durchaus mal stellen. Das bedeutet aber einfach nur jetzt meinerseits der Wunsch, wenn man Politikwissenschaft betreibt und sagt, ich schreibe ein Buch über Demokratie und wie sie kaputt geht. Warum nochmal in Habermas arbeiten, wenn Anne Will das Publikum wirklich bespielt? Ja, irgendwelche Leute haben irgendwann mal Habermas gelesen. Irgendwo wirkt es noch nach und dann kann man nochmal die eine oder andere Pointe machen, in dem man sagt, tata, es war nichts dahinter. So, Anne Will bespielt jetzt mit ihrem Publikum, äh, Carmen Joschka, die bespielt ein Millionenpublikum. Warum die nicht einfach mal namentlich, auch in einem Surkamp-Buch in Grund und Boden schreiben? Und zwar ordentlich begründet. Die Argumentationen sind so einfach.
Das wäre ein anderes Buch, wenn das einer schreibt. Das werden wir definitiv dann im Salon besprechen. Wir bleiben aber dabei, dass das ein hochinteressantes Buch ist, über das es sich zu streiten lohnt. Die Demokratie ist in der Krise und die Theorie der Demokratie auch. Das sagt Politikwissenschaftler Veith Selk in seinem großartigen Buch Demokratie-Dämmerung. Es ist eine große Dekonstruktion der Demokratie-Theorien. Es ist aber auch eine Dekonstruktion der Demokratie, wie wir sie vorfinden. Er legt alle blinden Flecken bloß. Er zeigt uns, wie dramatisch die Lage ist. Aber er bietet uns keinen Ausweg, sondern einen Endpunkt an.
Und deswegen gieße ich Wasser in den Wein. Ja, es ist ein sehr gutes Buch. Aber die Soziologen werden sagen, haben wir doch schon immer gesagt, warum lest ihr denn immer noch Habermas? Schaut doch einfach mal Karam-Mjoska. Ich wünsche mir denselben Autor und denselben Verlag, aber nochmal kämpferisch und die Nadelstiche richtig setzend, empirisch, historisch, aufrüttelnd.
Das literarische Leben wollen wir auch nicht vergessen. Und ich habe einen interessanten Roman gelesen von der niederländischen Autorin Fienn Feldman. Dieser Roman heißt Xerox und dieser Roman handelt von einer jungen Frau, die in einem Amsterdamer Start-up tätig ist. Was sie dort so genau macht, weiß man nicht. Sie ist dort aber in ihrem Büro zusammen mit einem Drucker. Dieser Drucker ist wie viele Drucker einer, der Launen hat, der manchmal mürrisch ist, sich anspringt oder irgendetwas und sie aber hat einen sehr guten Zugang zu diesem Drucker gefunden. Wie man mit ihm zurechtkommt, das ist eigentlich noch zu wenig gesagt. Diese Frau, deren Namen wir nicht erfahren, die hat eine Beziehung zu diesem Drucker aufgebaut. Dem ganz normalen ist ein Motto vorangestellt von Rainer Maria Rilke, wenn keine Gemeinsamkeit zwischen den Menschen ist und ihnen, versuchen sie es, den Dingen nahe zu sein, die sie nicht verlassen werden. Und genau das tut diese Protagonistin. Es ist so, dass hier ein Roman entstanden ist, der uns die moderne Bürowelt zeigt. Also der Angestellten-Roman ist ja etwas, was es immer wieder gab. Manche haben vielleicht mal Martin Walser gelesen oder vor allem Wilhelm Genazzino. Und dies ist ein moderner Angestellten-Roman, der soweit geht, dass der Mensch entindividualisiert ist. Deswegen hat die Protagonistin keine Namen und auch die Kollegen haben keinen Namen, sondern die heißen einfach Sales, Marketing, also je nach dem Zuständigkeitsbereich. So einen lustigen Techniknamen, Rata75X3. Nein, aber der Drucker hat eine Subjektivität, die sich dann irgendwann bahnen bricht. Nämlich, wenn sie aufgrund von einigen Verwicklungen im Unternehmen nicht bei ihrem Drucker sein kann, dann bekommt er ein eigenes Bewusstsein. Und dieser Drucker schreibt auch ein Kapitel in diesem Roman.
Den du jetzt in der Hand hältst gerade.
Den ich jetzt gerade in der Hand halte. Das heißt, also dieser Drucker wird zu einem Subjekt. Um mal ein bisschen herauszufinden, wie das so eigentlich da ist, wie die Dialoge verlaufen, die geschildert werden in dieser angestellten Welt hier ein Auszug. Eine andere Kollegin, die PR macht, erzählt Sales, dass ihr lahmarschiger Bruder nun endlich wisse, was er mit seinem Leben anfangen wolle. Er verkauft, awkward das zu sagen, aber nun ja, Business ist Business, kolumbianischen Bordellen, eine spezielle Software, damit die Frauen mit mehreren Freiern gleichzeitig Webcam-Sex haben können. Er fliegt jeden Monat nach Bogota und verhandelt mit Männern, die sich als Hausherren des Bordells bezeichnen. Oh, okay, sagt Sales. Ja, sagt PR. Ich wusste anfangs auch nicht, was ich davon halten sollte, und ich finde es auch seltsam, mein kleiner Bruder, der den Schulterschluss mit der Pornoindustrie sucht. Aber gut, Sex Positivity und Sexarbeit ist auch Arbeit. Stimmt, sagt Sales. Sex Positivity. Es ist eine Win-Win-Situation. Die Frauen kommen viel effizienter an ihr Geld. Eigentlich verstärkt man ihre wirtschaftliche Position. Ja, das ist wirklich toll. Und ich bin froh, dass mein kleiner Bruder mit diesem Start-up endlich was gefunden hat, das ihm Energie gibt. Also diese Dialoge finden dort so statt. Aber vor allem ist es so erstaunlich, wie hier beschrieben wird, das Verhältnis zum Drucker. Ich lasse von meinem Drucker ab und gehe wieder nach unten. Unterwegs komme ich an dem Besprechungsraum vorbei, in dem wir irgendwann mal alle zusammenkommen mussten, um die Vision und Mission unseres Unternehmen zu diskutieren. Der Kundendienst und das unterstützende Personal durften auch mitdenken. Also hier wird schon klar, sie geht nicht einfach aus der Tür, sondern sie verlässt den Drucker und geht dann woanders hin. Und dann beschreibt sie, wie diese Meetings stattfinden. Und jeder, der schon mal ein Meetings war, wird sich vielleicht daran erinnern. Sie sagt, auf dem Tisch lagen stapelweise farbige Post-its. Wir sollten uns vorstellen, dass unser Unternehmen eine Person sei. Welche Eigenschaften hätte diese Person? Um nicht das Gleichgewicht zu verlieren, musste ich mich mit den Ellenbogen auf dem Tisch abstützen. Sonst wäre ich langsam von meinem Stuhl gerutscht, bis ich bewusstlos unterm Tisch gelegen hätte. Ich schrieb nichts auf die Post-its, aber das fiel niemandem auf. Vieles, was gesagt wurde, hörte ich. Den Worten eine Bedeutung zuordnen konnte ich jedoch nicht. Ich sah, dass die Münde sich bewegten und meine Kollegen und Kolleginnen einander zuneckten. Menschen schrieben Kernbegriffe ans Weitbord. Dann wurde es plötzlich still. Der Gesprächsleiter sah in die Runde und suchte jeden Blick. Hatten wir einen Auftrag bekommen? Hatte er eine Frage gestellt? Wussten alle anderen etwa, was von ihnen erwartet wurde? Der Kaffee in meinem Becher wurde kalt. Ich selbst fröstelte auch. Und in meinem Kopf war nur ein Gedanke. Es gibt so viele Mittel und Wege, um Ideen und Gedanken zu vernichten. Und diese Gedankenvernichtung und auch diese Subjekt-Vernichtung, die stattfindet, die wird hier in sehr kalter und dann nur im Hinblick auf den Drucker emotionaler Sprache uns geschildert. Es ist eine sehr einsame, entindividualisierte Welt. Und so wundert es dann nicht, wenn irgendwann der Drucker selbst spricht und fragt, lebe ich? Das ist die Frage. Ja, ich selbst sehe das so. Trotz meiner Macken verspüre ich ein starkes Streben danach, in aller Einfachheit und Funktionalität so, wie ich bin, vorzubestehen. Dass genau dieses Gerät sein, versuche ich aufrechtzuerhalten. Das ist alles, was ich tun muss. Und das ist auch, was Leben tut. Das eigene Fortbestehen sicherstellen. Obwohl mein Lebenstrang übrigens nicht rein darauf beschränkt ist. Jenseits meiner Sehnsucht nach Selbsterhaltung gibt es noch etwas. Etwas, das ich nicht benennen kann. Leben sollte mehr sein, als einfach nur fortbestehen. Leben sollte wie das Nachjagen einer Seifenblase sein. Ein Spiel auf einem Platz. Das sind also diese Ideen, die der Drucker artikuliert. Aber dieser Roman versucht, diese Differenz zwischen Mensch und Drucker da verschwimmen zu lassen, um uns zu zeigen, wir haben es hier mit Leuten zu tun, die nur noch in so Sprachhülsen existieren, die in einer Bürowelt nicht Menschen sein sollen, nicht sein dürfen. Und der uns auch zeigt, dass man vielleicht eben einfach so sein, also in einer monotonen Arbeit ganz aufgehen kann, so wie der Drucker auch dann ganz Drucker ist, wenn er druckt. Und diese Schilderung der Monotonie der Arbeit, das habe ich so noch nicht gelesen. Und deswegen kann ich diesen Roman durchaus empfehlen. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das ein absolutes Meisterwerk ist, aber ich würde sagen, dass es doch nochmal eine sehr bemerkenswerte Stimme ist in den angestellten Romanen, die es bereits gibt. Und ich hoffe einfach, dass man mehr davon bekommt. Also ich möchte eigentlich mehr Arbeitsweltliches in der Literatur lesen. Auch vielleicht nicht nur die Bürowelt, irgendwelche Management-Etagen, sondern vielleicht auch diese anderen Arbeiten, wo die gesellschaftlich notwendigen Produkte hergestellt werden. Also das ist jedenfalls etwas, was ich empfehlen kann. Fien Feldmann, Xerox erschienen bei Hansa und, weil wir darauf hingewiesen wurden, dass wir das doch nie dazu sagen. Ich will es hier noch mal herausstellen. Wer hat es übersetzt? Übersetzt aus dem niederländischen von Christina Brunnenkamp.
Und bekommt der Drucker am Ende noch seine Personalakte, oder bleibt er weiter eine Sachleistung?
Nein, der Drucker hat ein ganz blödes Schicksal.
Traurig.
Denn manchmal werden ja auch so Drucker ausrangiert. Also wir gehen dem mal nach. Aber es ist kein Kitsch wie bei Raleigh oder so. Also das ist schon was anderes.
Gut, wir bleiben in der Literatur. Macrons, Neue Sorbonne Rede. Rettet Europa, damit es nicht stirbt. Also wir lesen die deutsche Berichterstattung zum Thema. Wir beginnen beim Spiegel. Sechs Jahre nach seiner großen europapolitischen Rede sprach er wieder an der Sorbonne über Europa. Diesmal mit einer anderen Botschaft, klärt uns Britta Sandberg auf. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass Präsident Emmanuel Macron wusste, welches Risiko er mit einer Wiederauflage seiner berühmten Sorbonne Rede aus dem September 2017 einging. Einige seiner Berater im Elysée sollen ihm davon abgeraten und ihn gewarnt haben, das kann nur schief gehen. Also so großes Drama ist auch hier diese Verherrlichung von der Rede 2017, gerade in Deutschland. Klar kann die was bewirkt haben, aber nicht in Deutschland. Also hier muss man gar nicht anfangen, nachträglich diese Rede für so und so weiter. Aber Macron, wir kennen ihn, wie Britta schreibt, als dickkopf und angstfrei. Hat die Rede trotzdem gehalten. Wieder seiner Beratungen. Damals, hören wir hier, ich lese mal im Wortlaut, nicht, dass jemand denkt, das sind meine Worte. Damals war er erst einige Monate im Amt, ein 39-jähriges Wunderkind. Damals ein leidenschaftliches, mitreißendes Plädoyer für eine neue europäische Souveränität. Er war pausbeckiger als heute, unverbrauchter, unbekannter auch.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch schon wieder dieser Stil, den Karren Mioska abfragen könnte. Herr Macron, Sie waren pausbeckiger noch vor fünf Jahren. Was ist denn nun passiert?
Genau, was ist denn nun passiert? Nicht nur in Frankreich, auch in Europa hat sich nach sieben Jahren im Amt eine gewisse Macron-Müdigkeit eingestellt. Zudem warf die französische Opposition dem Präsidenten vor. Er missbrauche sein Amt, weil es ist ja gerade Wahlkampf. Seine Kandidatin liegt 15 Prozent zurück. Der Resemblement National, also wie auch immer hier Lepens-Gruppe führt. Die Frage ist, sagt jetzt Britta Dings, ob Europa die Europäer ein weiteres Mal wird überraschen und beeindrucken können. Ihre Antwort lautet, es gelang ihm. Aber der Text klärt uns darüberhin nicht unbedingt auf. Es ist jedenfalls eine, sagt sie nochmal, überraschend kohärente, strukturierte Rede. Weniger optimistisch im Grundton als 2017. So, wir sind jetzt halb durch den Text durch. Bist du schon, fühlst du dich schon aufgeklärt und gebildet? Also was hat er denn gesagt, würde ich jetzt mal fragen. Er begann jedenfalls mit dramatischen Worten. Uns Europa ist sterblich, es kann sterben. Und ob es das tun wird, hängt von unserer Entscheidung ab. Er klang ernst und besorgt, falls du es noch nicht rausgehört hast. Ja, wir sind nicht genügend gewappnet. Jetzt schwenkt es über in Macrons Worte. Zu langsam nicht ehrgeizig genug. Die Lage zu verändern, würde fünf bis zehn Jahre brauchen. Wir sollten sie nutzen. Vielleicht haben wir eher nur fünf Jahre. Also großes Drama. Dann so ein Zwischenzitat. Wir haben zu lange geglaubt, dass unser Modell unfehlbar ist. Aber nun erleben wir, dass unsere Demokratien kritisiert und unsere Werte in Frage gestellt werden. Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist bedroht. Unsere Wehrfähigkeit ist natürlich bedroht. Wir brauchen eine europäische Verteidigungsstrategie. Das sind diese schwammigen Begriffe, bei denen man sagt, das ist diese Semantik, vor denen uns Veith so war. Deswegen die Abklärung von Habermas. Es ist einfach nur hingehen und sagen, komm, wir deliberieren mal ein bisschen über die Vorschläge, die da sind. Wir brauchen eine glaubwürdige europäische Verteidigungsstrategie.
So, und jetzt sage ich dir, wer ist ein riesen Habermas-Fan?
Die Franzosen. Aber die Franzosen kamen ja auch mit solchen Ideen, wie Drucker sind jetzt Agenten auf Augenhöhe mit Menschen.
Bruno Latour. Im Parlament der Dinge. Ja, das ist ja wirklich das schlimmste Buch der Welt. Ich gestehe der Literatur diese Spielereien ja gerne zu. Ich habe dann so ein Interview gesehen mit Fiann Feldmann, wo sie dann auch glaubt, dass das an sich ein politisches Programm sein könnte, dass Drucker Subjektivität haben. Dann würde ich sagen, drehen.
Dreh mal Kunst und Künstler. Das geht hier leider nicht. Der französische Präsident ist auch unser französischer Präsident. Also glaubwürdige europäische Verteidigungsstrategie, kompatible Waffensysteme, schnelle Eingreiftruppe, nukleare Abschreckung. Die allerdings hat er erst drei Tage später dann nochmal hervorgehoben. Das war hier alles schwammig gelassen. Europäische Rüstungsindustrie, das ganze Programm. Er wiederholte seine Forderung, gemeinsame Schulden dafür aufzunehmen. Ich will jetzt schonmal teasern. Wir erfahren erst viele Texte weiter im Kommentar, aber hier nicht, dass es um 1000 Milliarden pro Jahr geht.
Ah ja, ist doch ganz gut zu wissen.
Ja, ist eigentlich gut zu wissen, steht im Spiegeltext nicht drin. Ansonsten Wirtschaftsfragen. Neue Konzepte bitte. Wachstumsmodell muss überdacht werden. Wettbewerbsnachteile müssen aussortiert werden. Eine Verdoppelung der EU-Investitionsgelder. Es werden wieder keine Zahlen genannt. Also nicht in ihrem Text, in der Rede schon. Kapitalmarkt, Union. Haben wir drüber gesprochen. Wir müssen hier einen Kulturkampf gewinnen. Nationalistische und populistische Bewegungen müssen. Wir müssen uns gegen die stellen. Also es ist der Humanismus, der uns von den anderen unterscheidet. Also das ist wirklich... Ich will nicht seine Rede da mit im Beschlag nehmen, sondern hier geht es erstmal nur darum, wie reportiert wird. Es ist nicht gut. Wir erfahren fast nichts. Er schlägt noch mal einen Bogen zum Raketenabwehrsystem. Kohlenstofffreier Energiemarkt. Sie zählt im Grunde nur auf. Wir wissen selber nicht einen noch aus. Und dann nennt sie das Digitalverbot von Unter-15-Jährigen. Stimmt so gar nicht. Macron will nicht ein Digitalverbot für Unter-15-Jährige, aber will so eine Art digitale Volljährigkeit mit 15. Vorher sollen die Eltern Verantwortung übernehmen. Und es wird dann immer häufiger in dem Text auch dieses Zitat gebracht aus der Rede, weil man Kinder in diesem Alter auch nicht alleine in den Dschungel schicken würde. Das taucht in mehreren Texten auf. Das viel bessere Bild, was er konkret in der Rede benutzt hat, kommt nicht vor. Dort sagt er nämlich, wir schicken unsere Kinder in die Schule, indem wir sie bis an den Klassenraum fahren, in unseren dicken Panzern. Aber was sie auf digitalen Bildschirmen machen, ist uns egal. Und das finde ich viel besser. Das ist das viel bessere Bild, aber er hat irgendwie Dschungel gesagt, und deswegen sind alle auf diesen Dschungel eingesprungen. Oder sie haben alle nur voneinander abgeschrieben. Können wir mal überprüfen. Tagesschau. Europa kann sterben. Überschrift, okay. Sieben Jahre nach, bla bla bla. Es besteht ein immenses Risiko, geschwächt oder gar abgehängt zu werden. Okay, okay, okay. Sie ziehen natürlich auch den Einstieg. Unser Europa ist sterblich.
Kann das sein, dass das vor allem alles fußt auf DPA?
Davon würde ich mal schwer ausgehen, denn wir erfahren in diesem Text nichts weiter, außer das, was wir hier schon gehört haben, was auch die DPA repartiert hat.
Mir ist nämlich immer mal wieder aufgefallen, wenn ich irgendwas vorbereitet habe, dann hat man so eine DPA-Meldung zu irgendeiner Rede und dann liest man die Rede und denkt, das ist aber erstaunlich, was da so rausgenommen wurde. Das Eigentliche wurde zumindest dann in der DPA-Meldung oft nicht benannt. Also ich würde sagen, wenn man Medienkritik mal wieder üben will, manches ist ja auch schon durchgespielt, man könnte sich mal sehr dezidiert mit der DPA auseinandersetzen, was da eigentlich so getrieben wird.
Nicht nur mit der DPA, sondern auch wirklich mit diesem Effekt, der dann passiert, weil die DPA ist ja in dem Falle auch nur eine Person, die im Raum ist, wenn dann Rede gehalten wird. Diese Rede steht ja natürlich zum Glück online, wenn auch nur französisch. Kann man ja davon ausgehen, dass die Medienhäuser, wenn sie in Frankreich Korrespondenten haben, dann französisch können. Ich war selber mal im Raum mehrfach eigentlich, aber in einem Fall war es wirklich so witzig, weil ich so neben Journalisten sitze, wo der eine den anderen fragt, was hat er gerade gesagt? Keine Ahnung, muss man auf die DPA warten. Die DPA sitzt aber nur drei Stühle weiter, und man hofft dann einfach, dass die DPA gehört hat, was da gesagt wurde. Also in der Hinsicht der absolut berechtigte Kritik. Ich glaube, sie trifft hier auch zu. Das Einzige, was die Tagesschau noch mehr hat als Spiegel, ist, wir sollen kein Vasall der USA sein beim Thema Verteidigungspolitik. Zeit online steigt auch ein. Es besteht die Gefahr, dass unser Europa sterben könnte. Will ich auch nicht kritisieren, ist ja ein wichtiger Satz. Ansonsten alle Sachen, mal gucken, ob hier noch was Innovatives dabei kommt. Also ich lade in den kommenden Monaten alle Partner ein, eine europäische Verteidigungsinitiative aufzubauen. Okay, es hat halt so wörtlich gesagt, wurde hier reportiert. Das ist für uns eine Neuigkeit. Gemeinsame Schulden, keine Zahlen genannt. Dann noch mal das Vasallen-Zitat, das wir gehört haben. Also im Grunde die Signalworte aus anderthalb Stunden Rede. EU-Verteidigungshaushalt im nächsten Jahrzehnt. Also hier noch mal eine Konkretisierung aus der Rede, die wir vorher nicht kannten. Die FAZ, Macrons düstere Visionen vom sterblichen Europa. Der russische Imperialismus sei das größte Sicherheitsrisiko für Europa. Erstmals zeigt sich Macron offen für eine europäische Raketenabwehr. Also hier liegt man ein bisschen Fokus drauf. Es gab wohl deutsche Vorschläge eines European Sky Shield Initiative, also einer ESSI, zu der er sich jetzt verhalten hatte, würde ich sagen, ja gönnerhafterweise. Also das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass ein französischer Präsident bei einer Rede mal einen konkreten deutschen Vorschlag erwähnt, weil er wurde ja noch niemals erwähnt mit irgendwelchen Ideen in der deutschen Rede. Ansonsten wird auch in FAZ nochmal darauf hingewiesen, dass ja der 26. September 2017 eine politische Sternstunde war. In dem Falle ist das also Sorbonne I, das ist jetzt Sorbonne II. Ansonsten nichts Neues außer einem Zitat. Sehr französisch klagen auch die Forderungen, Zitat, zur Kriegswirtschaft überzugehen. Und nicht ein Versal der USA zu sein. Also die Kriegswirtschaft haben wir vorher in den Texten noch nicht gehört. Hier wird sie genannt. Mehr Kontrolle beim Grenzschutz. Also die FAZ legt auch nochmal Wert auf ihr Lieblingsthema. Migration. Ansonsten Volljährigkeit mit 15 Jahren. Also Europa der digitalen Volljährigkeit mit 15 Jahren. Wir müssen die Kontrolle über das Leben unserer Kinder in Europa zurückgewinnen. Ich halte ehrlich gesagt, umso mehr ich davon lese, dieses ganze TikTok-Zeug für wirklich das mega Thema überhaupt. Also ich weiß gar nicht warum. Also später heißt das nochmal in anderen Texten, das war so als Fremdkörper der Rede drin. Weil es ging ja um Europa und usw. Dann denke ich mir, beim Thema Europa, Zukunft, Verteidigung muss man über TikTok und die Jugend sprechen. Das ist eins zu eins. Also da ist nicht, das ist ein Fremdkörperding oder so. Na ja, die FAZ hat jedenfalls einen eigenständigen Text gemacht mit der Überschrift, Macron will eine andere EZB. Er hat nämlich in dieser Rede, erfahren wir jetzt zum ersten Mal, Spiegelzeit, Tagesraum nicht gebracht, ein neues Mandat der Europäischen Zentralbank, Bekämpfung der Inflation, ja, aber bitte auch, Wachstumsziele, Ziele der Dekorbonisierung und als drittes, ich glaube Arbeitsmarkt, ich weiß gar nicht, aber es war also drei weitere Mandate für die Europäische Zentralbank, was wir ja aus der amerikanischen Zahlzentralbank so weit kennen. Die EU-Verträge verpflichten auf Preisstabilität, das ist klar, aber Christine Lagarde hat ja schon darauf Wert gelegt und agiert auch so, dass dieser Green Deal auch ein bisschen sich in der Finanz- oder Geldpolitik da niederschlägt. Sie schließen hier nochmal mit so einem Hinweis. In Frankreich haben dieses Thema auch die rechten Politiker entdeckt, denn dort heißt es von Marine Le Pen oder aus ihrer Partei, von Jean-Philippe Tanguy, der jetzt gerade die Europawahlkämpfe da anführt. Wenn wir diese grüne Transformation erreichen wollen, müssen wir eine geldpolitische Waffe einsetzen. Kann natürlich wieder hier so ein populistisches Aren verwechseln sein. Es wäre ganz gut, wenn wir die Geldpolitik mal wieder, und sei es über das Vehikel, irgendwas grün, solange wir an der Macht sind. Und am Ende wirklich über den Text entscheiden, der da geschrieben wird. Süddeutsche Zeitung in einer Grundsatzrede zu Europa fordert Frankreichs Präsident einen Ruck in der EU. Also man schließt an die ganz alten Seegewohnheiten an. Eine Ruckrede. Thema Nummer eins, Handelspolitik. Es geht um die massiven Subventionen aus China und Amerika bei den Schlüsseltechnologien. Deswegen auch diese großen Geldsumme, Verteidigung hier und so weiter. Da wird also grundsätzlich anders gedacht als bei uns in Deutschland, aber das kennen wir ja soweit auch. Er setzt sich für ein größeres gemeinsames Budget ein. Auch das wurde uns in den Texten vorher nicht gesagt, dass er da grundsätzlich auch den tagespolitischen Alltag mit größeren Budgets schon mal ausstatten will. Sie reagieren hier drauf, wie Scholz, also sie kommen ja darauf zu sprechen, wie Scholz auf die Rede reagierte. Er hat nämlich bei der Plattform X, Klammer auf, vormals Twitter, ich weiß nicht genau, warum die Journalisten das immer noch machen, geschrieben, deine Rede enthält gute Impulse, wie uns das gelingen kann. Also zu irgendwelchen Themen. In dem Falle Europa Stark bleiben lassen. Nicht mehr Europa Stark machen, sondern damit Europa Stark bleibt. Also deine Rede enthält gute Impulse, wie uns das gelingen kann. Es gibt noch einen extra Kommentar von Stefan Cornelius. Der liest sich so. Blablabla. Er verfügt über einen Intellekt und das dazugehörige Sendungsbewusstsein. Er redet und redet und redet. Ich fordere, wir müssen... Also, er wird sicher nochmal drüber lustig gemacht, dass Macron hier sehr viel denkbare Pfeil geboten hat. Ich weiß auch nicht, was soll das immer? Nun gut, zu diesem Einstiegssatz. Europa kann sterben.
Aber ist da nicht auch etwas dran jetzt an der Kritik? Denn ist es nicht so, dass wir jetzt Macron in den letzten drei Monaten mit geradezu jeder Position erlebt haben und auch mit zum Teil konträren Positionen?
Also nicht bei diesem Europathema. Da war er doch seitdem im Amt ist immer komplett...
Naja, bei den...
Verteidigungs-Operenität, Technologieentwicklung.
Bei den Europathema, bei Bodentruppen-Senden und wir müssen Konfrontation mit China...
Ausdrücklich strategische Ambiguität. Er hat ausdrücklich erklärt mit, ich sage das, damit um zu verschleiern, was wir wirklich tun, lege ich alles auf den Tisch. Das ist ja so interessant.
Oder seine Abwehr gegen China und zugleich seine Reise nach China, an dem er sagt, wir müssen auch mal einen eigenen Weg mit China finden. Einen besseren, nicht so von Washington diktierten Weg. Also ich finde, dass Macron schon in den letzten Monaten sehr viele Widersprüche produziert hat.
Ja, deswegen sollte man die ja auch mal anders beobachten, wie da kommuniziert wird. Ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, eine Rede des französischen Präsidenten ist einfach Pflichtlektüre. Da kann man nicht sagen, das ist hier wie bei Frank-Walter und ein Wir-Buch oder so, weil hier echte Budgetentscheidungen aufgeworfen werden von jemandem, der am Ende, wenn man ihn darauf festnagelt, das auch wirklich einbringen kann, muss man das einfach mit Ernsthaftigkeit besprechen. Und seine China-Reisen-Beobachtung, Begleitung, da habe ich nicht verfolgt, aber seinen Hinweis, man könnte ja auch Bodentruppen schicken, also das war ganz explizit, das war auch, fand ich, erstaunlich, dass jemand seine Strategie, nämlich, ich will die im Unklaren halten, offen sagt. Das wäre ja so, wir haben ja die Fragen gehört.
Aber ist es dann noch eine Strategie, wenn man es offen sagt?
Also man sagt doch eigentlich, wir schicken Bodentruppen? Das ist ja die Mad Man-Strategie von Nixon. Muss man kommunizieren, die versteht sich nicht von selber. Da müssen Leute hingehen und sagen, der dreht völlig durch, wir haben ihn nicht unter Kontrolle.
Richtig, aber das bedeutet ja, man sagt, wir schicken Bodentruppen und dann sieht man, okay, was wird der andere dazu sagen. Aber wenn ich sage, ich schicke Bodentruppen und sage am nächsten Tag, das gehört zur strategischen Ambiguität, dann nehme ich das ja raus, dass ich das Mad Man-Spiel spiele. Sondern ich sage ja dann wieder, naja, das war so ein Trick. Also man kann ja nicht sauber einen Trick machen und ihn so gleich verraten.
In dem Fall finde ich es gut, das so zu machen. Es ist, also so funktioniert diplomatische Abschreckung. Wir haben jetzt Atomwaffen. Man sagt das dazu. Man macht es nicht so wie Israel, sagt, wir wissen nicht so genau, könnte es sein und so weiter. Weil dann erlaubt man auch den anderen, dass Iran einfach sagt, wir wissen nicht so genau, kann sein und überhaupt. Sondern nee, man hat Atomwaffen und dann sagt man dazu, wir haben die nur im Verteidigungsfall und wir liefern die auch nicht weiter. Aber wir haben Atomwaffen. Also man macht es ganz explizit. Aber diese strategischen Ambiguität würde ich auch sagen. In Europa wurde offen kommuniziert, dass wir auch Bodentruppen schicken. Das wissen alle Bescheid. Niemand ist davon überrascht, wenn es passiert. Wir sagen aber dazu, es ist nur eine Drohung. Aber sie ist schon mal ein Möglichkeitenraum. Und das Problem, finde ich, war dann, dass Scholz da einfach sagte, ne, also das schließen wir ja per se aus. Kann er ja von mir aus gerne ausschließen, aber die wichtigere Botschaft war, das ist ein Droh-Potenzial. Und dann muss man sagen, damit drohe ich auch. Wenn man es danach nicht macht, kann man es ja immer noch. Aber die Drohung soll bitte im Raum stehen bei sowas.
Na gut.
Zu diesem Einstiegssatz, Europa kann sterben, sagt jetzt Cornelius, ja, selbstverständlich verfügt die EU über keine Ewigkeitsgarantie. Das ist zu flapsig, finde ich. Das ist irgendwie... Nun gut, Oliver Meyers hat dann mal ein bisschen strukturierter aus Paris in der SZ geschrieben. Vieles davon, was wir schon kennen, aber nochmal wirklich auch mit Zwischenüberschriften. Strategische Vertrautheit in der Verteidigung. Deswegen auch diese internationale Akademie für Verteidigungsfragen. Das hatte er damals schon in seiner Rede drin gehabt. Es kam ja dann nicht Raketenschirm und Atombombe. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das muss einfach ganz explizit, so wie auch strategische Ambiguität. Wir haben da eine Eingreiftruppe. Wofür wir sie verwenden, wissen wir nicht. Das ist halt dieses, ja, dann kommt die Seals. Es gibt sie halt. Europas Grenzen, eigener Punkt, und eben, und hier lautet die Zwischenüberschrift jetzt, 1000 Milliarden Euro. Im wirtschaftlichen Teil seiner Rede rief Macron, riet Macron, dass die Europäer wieder gemeinsam Geld ausleihen sollten. Von 1000 Milliarden pro Jahr, sprach er. Es geht um künstliche Intelligenz, Quanteninformatik, Raumfahrt, biotechnologie und neue Energien. Er ist zuversichtlich, bis 2030, da Weltführerschaft auf diesen Gebieten zu erringen. Klar, es ist halt dann ein Systemwettstreit mit China, aber ich finde auch, sowas kann man ja mal formulieren. Internet, also die Überschrift glaube ich hier, Internet ab 15 Jahren. Denn Hasspornografie und Pedokriminalität, da kann man ja mal Einhalt gebieten. Dieses Thema, unbestritten hochrelevant, stand ein bisschen quer in der Grundsatzrede. Da würde ich sagen, nein, denkt da nochmal drüber nach. Das sind, also wer über Resilienz redet und dann die Gehirne einfach so einen Weltkrieg, der Denkarbeit da zum Fraß vorwirft, braucht am Ende auch keine 1000 Milliarden für irgendwelche Raketenabschiff-Dinger, sondern da muss man echt gucken, wie man da mal aus der Zwick-Würde auskommt.
No one buys books, sagt Al Griffin in ihrem Substack Elysian. Ich empfehle das sehr zu lesen. Was hat sie gemacht? Also wir erinnern uns, Penguin Random House wollte Simon & Schuster kaufen. Das war im Jahr 2022. Das hat sich am Ende zerschlagen aus kartellrechtlichen Problemen. Aber diese Verhandlung, die da stattfand vor Gericht, hat dafür gesorgt, dass man wahnsinnig viele Protokolle hat, die auch publiziert wurden. Das Buch ist über 1.000 Seiten lang.
Protokolle von diesen Verhandlungen?
Von diesen Verhandlungen, wo die CEOs dann aussagen, wie dominant ihr Geschäftsmodell ist und so weiter. Sie hat Ewigkeiten gebraucht, um das zu lesen. Sie hat es aber gelesen und präsentiert uns das jetzt hier. Sie sagt, die großen fünf Verlagshäuser geben das meiste Geld für Buchvorschüsse, für berühmte Persönlichkeiten wie Britney Spears und Franchise-Autoren wie James Patterson aus. Und das ist der Großteil ihres Geschäfts. Außerdem verkaufen sie eine Menge Bibeln, Bestseller wie Herr der Ringe und Kinderbücher wie Die Raupe Nimmersatt. Diese beiden Marktkategorien, prominente Bücher und wiederholte Bestseller aus der Backlist, machen die gesamte Verlangsbranche aus und finanzieren sogar ihr Eitelkeitsprojekt, die Veröffentlichung all der anderen Bücher. Das ist das Eitelkeitsprojekt, die Veröffentlichung der anderen Bücher. Und zwar ist es so, dass sehr, sehr viele Bücher, nämlich 96% aller Bücher, die erscheinen, sich weniger als 1000-mal verkaufen. Und wir reden hier jetzt 96%.
Weniger als 1000-mal.
Verkaufen sich weniger als 1000-mal. Amerikanischer Markt. Wir reden jetzt über Belletristik. Wir reden jetzt hier nicht über das wissenschaftliche Buch, das nur in der Bibliothek zu haben ist oder so was. Best Seller sind selten. Nun, in meinem Aufsatz, Bücher schreiben ist keine gute Idee, hat sie auch schon mal verfasst, hat sie geschrieben, dass im Jahr 2020 nur 268 Titel mehr als 100.000 Exemplare verkauft haben. Ja, haben mehr als 100.000 Exemplare.
In einem 300-Millionen-Markt Amerika, der gleichzeitig international angebunden ist.
Gut, international ist ja nochmal eine andere Sache. Sie kann ja jetzt nur da, weil es ja um diese Verbindung da ging. Wissen Sie ungefähr, wie viele Autoren es in der gesamten Branche gibt, die in diesem vier-Jahres-Zeitraum, also 19 bis bis 23 geht das dann, 500.000 Einheiten verkauft haben oder mehr. Es gibt 50 Autoren.
Echt?
Ja, 50 Autoren haben 500.000 Einheiten in einem einzigen Jahr verkauft.
Bei Simon & Schuster oder in dem ganzen Markt?
Im ganzen Markt.
Gruselig.
Markus Dohle, das ist der Geschäftsführer von Penguin Random House, ich glaube inzwischen gewesen. Aber es ist ganz interessant, dem Mann noch zuzuhören. Wir hatten mal ihn hier in den 29ern, als er gesagt hat, ich bin Proud Taxpayer. Er ist für hohe Steuern, auch für Leute, die viel verdienen. Bei OMR war er mal zu Gast. Der wird hier also auch dann befragt. Er sagt, wir sind Angel-Investoren für unsere Autoren und ihre Träume, ihre Geschichten. So nenne ich meine Redakteure und Verleger Angel. Es ist eher die Idee des Silicon Valley. 35 Prozent sind profitabel, 50 auf Beitragsbasis. Jedes Buch hat also die gleiche Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit. Gesucht werden Einhörner. Die gibt es aber nur alle fünf bis zehn Jahre. Zum Beispiel die Twilight-Reihe. Die hat dann Hunderte Millionen Dollar eingebracht. Es gibt so etwas wie erwartete Top-Seller. Das sind die Berühmtheiten, die Bücher schreiben und hohe Vorschüsse kassieren. Weit weniger als ein Prozent der Autoren, das ist jetzt der Verleger von Sutherland House, erhalten Vorschüsse über die Marke von 250.000 Dollar. Wie viel? Weniger als ein Prozent aller Autoren.
Ich dachte, es war eine absolute Zahl.
Es gab im Jahr 2022 insgesamt 233 solcher Deals. Mehr nicht. Hill, jemand anderes aus der Verlangsbranche, sagt, dass Titel, die einen Vorschuss von mehr als 250.000 Dollar erhalten, 70% der Vorschussausgaben der Verlage ausmachen. Das heißt, die Verlage geben wirklich das meiste Geld einfach nur für diese verrückten Vorschüsse aus. Es ist so absurd. Es hat sich hier natürlich noch mal bestätigt. Also bei Autoren geht es eigentlich nur um Vorschüsse. Alles andere ist im Prinzip egal. Seinander hat jetzt so einen ewigen Bestseller geschrieben. Alles andere zähnlich. Die meisten werden von Pendrian Random House vergeben. Simon & Schuster ist bei Platz 3. Bei den anderen steht der Name nicht dabei. Aufgrund von, ja, der darf nicht bekannt gegeben werden. Die waren ja nicht involviert am Prozess. Inwieweit rechnet sich das? Jetzt denken wir sofort an die Bücher der Obamas. Da steht hier nur, von den Büchern der Obamas wurden so viele Exemplare verkauft, dass sie als statistische Anomalien aus den Shards entfernt werden mussten. Das ist einfach so viel. Das verzerrt alles. Damit können wir uns das gar nicht beschäftigen.
Was aber bedeutet, das lohnt sich dann auch denen?
Für die hat es sich gelohnt. 75% unserer Akquisition, sagt jetzt jemand von Gallery Books Group, der sich also darum kümmert, an Leute ranzukommen, Prominente, die Bücher schreiben, ist die direkte Ansprache von Prominenten und Sportlern. Also, die zu nerven, wollt ihr nicht in ein Buch schreiben und dann Vorschlüsse reinzuholen.
Wir haben ja hier zwei dieser prominenten Bücher gelesen. Sagen wir mal drei.
Harry?
Harry, Bono, Obama. Bonos und Obamas Bücher waren wirklich sehr gut. Und nicht nur waren sie gut, sondern Obama hat ja auch noch selber gelesen und hat dann, ich kann mich noch erinnern, wie er Desmond Tutu so nachgemacht hat auch, nachgespielt hat. An deren Sicht ist das vielleicht doch kein schlechtes Produkt. Also nicht per se zu verurteilen, aber Harry, Katastrophe. Das sieht man halt doch.
Also, jetzt weitere Zahlen. Random House hat dann bekannt gegeben, ab welchen Verkaufszielen, die man sich so setzt, welche Vorschüsse gezahlt werden. Kategorie 1, Leittitel mit einem Verkaufsziel von 75.000 Einheiten und mehr. Vorschuss 500.000 Dollar.
500.000 für 75.000 Käufe?
Ja, fand ich sehr viel.
Ich brauch mal, gell?
Also, das ist doch unglaublich. Ja, man muss aber sagen, Kategorie 2, 3, 4. Das geht dann weiter runter, also bis hin zu 50.000 Euro. Aber 50.000 Dollar bei 5.000 bis 10.000 verkauften Einheiten.
Ehrlich?
Ja, also die Vorschussgeschichte ist in den USA viel stärker verbreitet, offenbar als in Deutschland. Weil das wären eher Zahlen, bei denen die Verlage sagen würden, Deutschland, da machen wir es nie wieder. Also, es ist sehr interessant. So, und jetzt kommt aber toll, wie sie das jetzt schreibt, nachdem sie diese Kategorie aufgeführt hat. Ist doch jemand beunruhigt, dass die höchste Stufe Buchverkäufe von 75.000 Stück und mehr sind? Also, man könnte ja sagen, ja und dann 200.000, 500.000, damit rechnet gar keiner. Also, das sind, dann kommen wir schon in den Bereich der Anomalie wieder. Die Verlage wollen natürlich ein festes Publikum. Man will deshalb auf viel mehr, wird auf Franchise gesetzt. Dann wollen die Verlage kein Geld für Marketing ausgeben. Und das bedeutet dann, dass man mit Leuten gerne Bücher macht, die schon Social Media haben, die da weit verbreitet sind, Podcasts und so weiter. Denn die machen ja dann selbst das Marketing. Und das wird auch eingepreist in die Vorschusszahlung. Also, man sagt dann, hat so und so viele Follower, hat einen Podcast, kann man einpreisen. Dann Colin Hoover, das ist einer, die jetzt da bei diesem Booktalk, die schreibt so romantische Geschichtchen da, ist die erfolgreichste momentan. Aber wird Simon und Schuster gefragt, zahlt ihr dann für die das höchste Marketingbudget? Nein. Antwort, sie ist die Königin von TikTok und hat daher eine große Fangemeinde. Also müssen die sich nicht mehr drum kümmern, macht die selbst.
Was ja auch stimmt, wenn die Verlage auf TikTok Werbung machen, buchen die eine Agentur, die den drei Kacheln herstellt, die sie dann an drei verschiedenen Zeitpunkten, abends irgendwann und so weiter. Da geht unglaublich viel Geld drauf dafür, dass da von den Autoren selbst so ein megamesiges Ding da abgefeuert wird. Da würde ich auch keine extra Werbung mehr machen.
Amazon bekommt viel Geld von den Verlagen, um die Suchergebnisse zu optimieren. Dadurch entsteht natürlich auch so eine Oligopol-Bildung. Es gibt viele Bücher, für die wir eine Million Dollar im Voraus ausgeben und die im letzten Jahr veröffentlicht wurden. Und die es nicht einmal in die Top 1000 von Buchscan geschafft haben, sagt Madeleine McIntosh, CEO von Random House OS. Weniger als 45% dieser Bücher landen auf der 1000-Bestseller-Liste. Also die geben extrem viel Geld aus, bringt aber nichts. Ein Beispiel, Andrew Cuomo, der Gouverneur.
Ach so, ja, genau sein Bruder.
Der wurde ja unglaublich gelobt, toll mit Corona und alles. Buchvorschuss 5 Millionen Dollar, weil alle dachten, das geht dann weg. Hat aber dann ja so B2-Skandal und Pflegeheim-Skandal. Keiner will das Buch. Marie Kondo, die Aufräum-Expertin, war zur falschen Zeit am falschen Ort. Hat auch einen hohen Vorschuss bekommen, steht nicht genau die Zahl hier. Hat ein Buch veröffentlicht im März 2020. Wie schön es ist, im Büro zu arbeiten. Also in den Lockdown reingefallen.
Geil, in den Lockdown hinein veröffentlicht.
Billy Eilish hat trotz ihrer 97 Millionen Instagram-Followern, 6 Millionen Twitter-Follower innerhalb von 8 Monaten nach der Veröffentlichung ihres Buchs nur 64.000 Exemplare verkauft. Der Sänger Justin Timberlake verkaufte in den drei Jahren nach der Veröffentlichung seines Buches nur 100.000 Exemplare. Dann irgendeine andere Abgeordnete, 3 Millionen Twitter-Follower, 1, 3 Millionen auf Instagram, 26.000 Bücher verkauft. Also es gibt sehr viele. Piers Morgan, dieser furchtbare Host, hat 10 Millionen Follower in den sozialen Medien allein. Hat ein Buch geschrieben, Wake Up, hat sich 5600 Mal verkauft. Riesen Vorschuss passiert, nichts passiert. Das heißt, das ist ein wirklich ein Angel-Investment. Also das kann auch total scheitern, selbst bei diesen wahnsinnig prominenten. Was man daraus eigentlich ziehen kann, ist, würden die Verlage sich vielleicht mal wieder auf die Literaturen, auf gute Bücher konzentrieren und nicht diesen Promis so nachlaufen, könnte man vielleicht mit sehr viel weniger Geld gute Sachen machen. Es ist eigentlich wie in der Filmindustrie. Man nimmt eine Milliarde und baut damit den nächsten Marvel-Film, statt damit 25 niedrig budgetierte Filme oder, naja, es sind immer noch 40 Millionen, 35 Millionen Dollar Filme zu machen und zu sagen, ja, da könnten wir aber wirklich Neues aufbauen und so. Nein, man konzentriert sich auf diese großen Leute. Das Beste ist, man schreibt ein Kinderbuch, zum Beispiel wie Eric Carle, Die Raupe Nimmersatt. Das Buch steht seit 19 Jahren jede Woche auf der Bestsellerliste.
Es ist Wahnsinn, Der Griffelow, Die Raupe Nimmersatt, Dr. Brom, was es alles gibt. Aber ich finde es auch gut.
Ja.
Also das sind alles gute Bücher.
Genau, das ist sicherlich lesenswerter als das Buch von Piers Morge oder Marc-Uwe Kling, das Nine Horn und so.
Das ist alles spektakuläres Zeug. Also in der Ansicht der Kinderbuchmarkt, der ja nun auch wirklich einfach nur Geschenke markt. Es ist ja, was kann ich dem Kind schenken? Und dann schenken wir das, was sie alle schon geschenkt haben, da einmal drin, die Raupe Nimmersatt.
Hier nochmal, Markus Dohle. Etwa 20 bis 25 Prozent der Leser, das sind die 4 Leser, machen 80 Prozent des Umsatzes der Branche aus, der für Bücher ausgegeben wird. Was wäre das Allerschlimmste, was kommen könnte, wäre ein Netflix für Bücher. Das geht ja schon etwas in diese Richtung. Spotify würde das ja gerne viel, viel größer machen. Wenn das wirklich kommen würde, wäre das der absolute Ruin. Deswegen sperren die sich alle. Und ich finde zu Recht dagegen.
Kindle Unlimited ist ja da. Und meine Bücher gibt es auch zu lesen.
Ja, aber du kriegst jetzt da nicht Veith Selk oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sowas abgerechnet wird. Aber ich habe nur gesehen, dass der Verlager einfach entschieden hat, dass das halt...
Ja, das ist aber ungewöhnlich. Also Ende vom Lied. Die Bloggerin schreibt, wenn sie nicht gerade ein prominenter oder ein Franchise-Autor sind, wird ihnen das Verlagsmodell nicht mehr als einen winzigen Vorschuss und ein Dutzend Laser einbringen.
Ja, das ist, wie soll man sagen, sehr ernüchternd. Bleiben wir so ein bisschen beim Thema, denn Simon & Schuster, bei Meta saßen sie vor zwei, drei Jahren da und haben gesagt, lasst uns die mal kaufen. Warum, fragt man sich. Nun, dieser Text hier beginnt wie folgt. Ende 2021 stand OpenAI vor einem Lieferproblem. Mehrere Autoren der New York Times 5 in der Zahl haben sich mal umgehört, wie die großen Konzerne jetzt damit umgehen, dass sie alle Daten dieser Welt brauchen. Und dass sie aber nicht alle einfach so aufsammeln können, sondern dass es da auch Urheberrechte und was auch immer gibt. Und dieser Text, wie Tech-Giganten Ecken abschneiden. Ich weiß nicht genau, was DeepL da übersetzt hat. Ich habe den neuesten Halttext nicht hier. Also Cut Corners, also Ecken abschneiden. In diesen idiosynkratischen Übersetzungen habe ich jetzt gehört, DeepL fährt ja den Ansatz Wort für Wort und dann so Satzbauweise. OpenAI versucht jetzt, den Kontext mit reinzuholen, also dass Cut Corners nicht mit Ecken abschneiden übersetzt wird. Kann man sich mal angucken. Also es ist sozusagen alles ganz verwoben hier. Wie Tech Giants Ecken abschneiden, um Daten für KI zu sammeln. Sie haben bei OpenAI, Google und Meta, also Facebook, sich umgehört. Denn man stieß Ende 2021, als wir alle noch gar nicht in dem Hype drin waren. Es kam ja erst anderthalb Jahre später dann GPT-4, im März 2023. Genau. Stieß man schon an diese Grenzen. Alle seriösen englischsprachigen Texte waren vorrätig. Man hatte keine dunkle Ecke mehr, in die man gehen sollte. Oder wie es hier heißt, alle Reserven waren ausgenutzt. Weshalb sich OpenAI damals dachte, komm, wir bauen jetzt Whisper. Whisper AI ist die Software, die also Transkriptionen anfertigt von Sachen, die noch nicht als Text vorliegen. Das bedeutet Podcast zum einen, das Transkript dieses Podcasts ist auch von Whisper erschienen, wird gemacht von Whisper. Es geht wahnsinnig schnell, ist absolut fehlerfrei. Also nicht absolut, aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich fehlerfrei und kostenlos. Also bei unserem Dienst auf Onec, der uns den Podcast immer im Audiomäßig so ein bisschen aufhübscht und so, ist das einfach drin. Boost einfach und dann kriegst du einen Transkript dazu. Also sehr praktisch. Und OpenAI hat das damals entwickelt, um YouTube-Videos zu transkribieren. Was sie dann auch gemacht haben, Greg Brockman, als derjenige, der heute Präsident von OpenAI ist und damals ja auch GBT 3, 5 und 4 dann vorgestellt hat fürs Publikum, also in dieser wichtigen Rolle hat diesen Whisper AI Service selbst mitentwickelt und sie haben am Ende eine Million Stunden YouTube-Videos transkribiert. Also Videos ordentlich ausgesucht, damit dann auch der Datensatz gewisse Qualitätsansprüchen genügt und transkribiert. Google hat es mitbekommen und ist noch nicht eingegriffen, weil das widerspricht den Nutzungsbedingungen von YouTube. Du kannst nicht einfach von außen kommen und sagen und so weiter. Nach diesem ganzen Facebook, Cambridge Analytica und so weiter haben aber alle so ein bisschen ihre AGBs mal auf Juristen, damit nicht am Ende das große Gesetz kommt, so ein bisschen in voreilender Voraussicht ihre AGBs aktualisiert, was bedeutete, dass Google sich selber von YouTube-Transkriptionen ausgeschlossen hatte. Weshalb sie dann auch gesagt haben, okay, wir haben das jetzt gesehen, dass ihr das macht, wir sagen aber nichts dazu, weil wir machen das ja auch und wir dürfen es eigentlich auch nicht. Also da gab es große Abmachungen des Stillhaltens und Schweigens darüber. Zeitgleich Meta arbeitet auch an seinen PAL-Modellen und Ingenieure sitzen dann da und überlegen mit Anwälten und Managern, ob man nicht einfach Simon & Schuster kauft und dort relativ günstig einfach an diesen nun mal sehr hochqualitativen Datensatz der dortigen Bücher herankommt. Also es ist einfach mal so nebenbei, was man braucht, hier kauft man Simon & Schuster.
Das ist die primäre Überlegung. Es geht nicht darum, ob man mit Simon & Schuster Bücher verkaufen kann.
Es geht um gar nichts. Einfach nur der Datensatz. Es ging nur um den Datensatz. Haben sie also überlegt und es dann doch nicht gemacht. Nun ja, jetzt sind sie alle da und handeln Lizenzen aus. Dauert aber extrem lange, nützt ihnen also nichts. Es findet ein großer Urheberrechtsmissbrauch statt, nicht nur mit YouTube-Videos, auf die jetzt alle zugreifen, sondern bei uns läuft es halt über, ja gut, wenn wir einen Transkript haben wollen, müssen wir es denen gleichzeitig schenken. Ich habe jetzt persönlich nichts dagegen. Ich arbeite ja gerne mit an der Weiterentwicklung dieser Technik. Aber es gab damals keine Daten mehr. Nachrichten, alle fiktionalen Werke, alle Forenbeiträge, alle Wikipedia-Artikel, alle Computerprogramme, alle Fotos, alle Podcasts, alle Filmclips, die es irgendwie gab, alles war leer gegraßt. Diese Chatbot-Systeme lernen dann auf Basis von hier steht dann einfach drei Billionen Wörter zum Beispiel. Drei Billionen Wörter als Textpool ist, wie hier steht, doppelt so viel wie die Boardlane Library der University of Oxford, die also seit 1602 alles sammelt. Die sammeln natürlich keine Reddit und, aber Wikipedia auch, wahrscheinlich. Also da ist einfach alles leer gegraßt. Wir haben jetzt gesehen, dass der Börsengang von Reddit ganz gut war, weil die haben davor noch akb-mäßig geregelt, man muss nämlich mit uns verständigen und das lizenzieren. Und dann sind sie an die Börse gegangen und alles, wow, das ist bestimmt, und dann waren sie gleich doppelt so viel wert. Und haben quasi diesen Börsengang mal gut getimt. Google, Meta, haben jetzt gesagt, Datenschutzgesetze. Kennen wir doch. Ein Anwalt von Andresen Horowitz, die ja Finanzierungsseite im Hintergrund steht, sagt dann, die benötigten Daten sind so umfangreich, dass selbst eine kollektive Lizenzierung nicht funktionieren kann. Weshalb sie einfach, wie dann gesagt wurde, den größten Datenraub aller Zeiten begangen haben. Alle haben sich einfach an allen Daten bereichert. Und jetzt ist es dazu gekommen, dass 10.000 Autoren, Unternehmen und Branchenverbände Kommentare zur Nutzung ihrer kreativen Werke abgegeben haben. Beim Copyright Office, einer Bundesbehörde, die also demnächst Leitlinien entwickelt, die ein bisschen spät kommen jetzt, wo die Systeme ja schon laufen. Also diese jetzt nachgeordneten, was weiß ich, die New York Times verklagt OpenAI, weil man seine Sachen da schon findet im Datensatz. Das ist natürlich jetzt kein adäquater Weg. Im Januar 2020 veröffentlichte Jared Kaplan eine bahnbrechende Arbeit über künstliche Intelligenz, auf die sie sich alle beziehen, die einfach seine Conclusio einfach lautet, mehr ist besser. Qualitativen Gewinne der Systeme ist nur über quantitative zuarbeiten, zu erringen. Also es ist nicht so sehr die Algorithmen-Frage und so. Die Prinzipien sind allen Unternehmen bekannt, sondern man braucht jetzt einfach viele, viele, viele Daten. Ganz interessant ist, dass er heute bei Anthropic arbeitet, die ja mit Claude ein Ding haben, das noch mal höher gewertet wird, zumindest bei dem Reasoning, so Witze erklären und solche Sachen, als OpenAI, also als GBT4. Und er hat das Paper damals zusammen, zum Beispiel, mit Ilya Sudskäfer geschrieben, den wir ja auch heute kennen, als Technikchef von OpenAI und so. Also diese Leute haben sich ja paradigmal einfach selber damals wissenschaftlich hingelegt. Und nun wird gearbeitet. GBT3 rute noch auf 300 Milliarden Token. Wir können es jetzt grob übersetzen mit Worten oder Phrasen oder wie auch immer. DeepMind hat 2022 schon Modelle gehabt, die in die Billionen-Token-Grenze kam. China hat jetzt ein KI-Modell Skywork heißt das mit 3, 2 Billionen Token. Google hat Palm II vorgestellt mit 3, 6 Billionen Token. Und so weiter und so fort. Es wird jetzt einfach immer größer. Und Sam Altman hat im Mai letzten Jahres eingeräumt, alle verwertbaren Daten sind verbraucht. Das ist alles weg. Was hat man jetzt? Da geht der Text dann drauf ein. Die Diskussion haben wir auch schon gehabt. Ob man jetzt mit synthetischen Daten, die sich dann noch mal selber über verschiedene Ecken, Sozceva hat es ja selber schon beschrieben, wie die Modelle dann ineinander greifen, um irgendwie eine Qualitätssicherung hinzustellen und trotzdem diesem Demenz-Charakter zu entgehen, dass die Maschine an sich selbst dann einfach in so einem Normalzustand, einfach in so einer Demenzreihe. Irgendwo müssen Überraschungsmomente her und die Maschine kann sich noch nicht selber überraschen. Dafür braucht sie immer noch den menschlichen Input. Deswegen ja auch Simon & Schuster und so. Das sind einfach diese Werte, auf die es jetzt ankommt. Naja, der öffentliche Aufschrei bleibt, soweit wir jetzt gesehen haben, aus. Aber die Juristen sitzen dran. Die New York Times sagt hier auch offen, dass sie da natürlich selber ihre Stakes mit drin hatte. In dieser ganzen Gemengelage. Und solche Sachen wie Kauf von Simon & Schuster schreckt natürlich auf. Das ist einfach hier Stephen King und so. Das ist dieser ganze Katalog. jetzt werden die ethischen Bedenken und die technischen Notwendigkeiten hin und heuer geworfen. Sam Ortman hat hier noch so ein Zitat. Er spricht vom Ereignishorizont. Also kann man synthetische Daten benutzen, um seine eigene Maschine besser zu machen? Solange man den Ereignishorizont für synthetische Daten überwinden kann, bei dem das Modell intelligent genug ist, um gute synthetische Daten zu erzeugen, ist alles in Ordnung. Dieses Bild des Ereignishorizonts kennen wir ja vom schwarzen Loch. Also es saugt einfach alles auf. Und man kann aber nicht reinschauen, weil selbst das Licht mit da reingesaugt wird und so. Also dass Sam Ortman da wieder mit so Blödsinn daherkommt, war natürlich irgendwie klar. Naja, ein System erzeugt die Daten, während ein zweites die Information bewertet. Wir gucken, ob so eine Verschachtelung funktioniert, um die Guten von den schlechten Daten zu trennen. Die Forscher sind sich noch uneinig, ob das funktioniert. Ich würde sagen, klar, es kann irgendwie am Ende das funktionieren. Also man kann durchaus den Duden-Corrector beauftragen, einen von oben AI geschriebenen Text auf Grammatik zu überprüfen. Aber das irgendwo hat das Grenzen, gerade wenn die Maschinen Richtung diesen Sinn- Fragen-Generierung, also echte Verständlichkeit und so weiter, gehen. In deren Sicht ist das, glaube ich, noch eine interessante Auseinandersetzung zwischen den Vertretern der Menschen und den Vertretern der Maschinen auf juristischen Felder, weil die Politik nicht so schnell ist, da irgendwelche Gesetze zu schreiben.
Ja, sehr gut.
Dieser Text war jedenfalls in allen großen Podcasts besprochen. Ich fand es ganz erstaunlich, dass es mal wieder gelang, Texte zu schreiben, die man danach bei Verge, Pivot, Hardfork, natürlich und so weiter, Leolaport, überall das mal thematisiert wird.
Es gibt eine neue Studie zum Gaming von Yuzu. Diese Studie wurde in diesem Monat veröffentlicht und die sagt uns einiges darüber, wie sich das Spielverhalten verändert hat, bzw. wie konstant es doch ist. Zum nächsten Mal muss man aber feststellen, es gibt einen Einbruch. Und zwar hat mit dem Ende der Pandemie die Spielerei ein bisschen abgenommen. Und es gibt jetzt immer noch nicht ein signifikantes Wachstum und es ist auch nicht in Sicht. Das heißt da, die Spielzeit ist im Jahr 2024 rückläufig und die Marktkonsolidierung führt dazu, dass immer mehr Augen und Geld in die Hände von wenigen Spielern und Studien und Studios geraten. Also wir sehen jetzt das in der Spieleindustrie, was ich jetzt eben für die Buchbranche beschrieben habe. Und das kann man zum Beispiel daran sehen, 90% des Umsatzes mit neuen Spielen im Jahr 2023 43 Titel entfallen sind. 43 Titel haben 90% des Umsatzes mit neuen Spielen ausgemacht. Der andere Umsatz, und wir werden jetzt gleich mal sehen, wie groß dieser Umsatz ist, ist mit alten Spielen. Aber man sieht jetzt die Independent-Spiele oder die auch nur kleineren Spiele, da sind wir noch gar nicht bei Independent, die haben kaum eine Chance. Es sind am Ende nur 43 Titel, die überhaupt als neue Titel einen relevanten Umsatz machen.
Ich habe gehört, dass aus 2 Milliarden Spielern demnächst 4 Milliarden werden. Und die ganze Branche sich jetzt darauf vorbereitet, dass das immer weitergeht mit dieser. Aber die Zahlen sprechen offenbar dagegen. Das war für mich auch mehr so eine Angeberkonferenz, im Sinne von 8 Milliarden Menschen, 4 Milliarden online, 2 Millionen Spielen und im Nächsten 4 Milliarden.
Ja, ich muss hier hinzufügen, es geht hier hauptsächlich um den PC- und Konsolenmarkt. Und Konsolen sind sehr, sehr wichtig, aber der PC auch. Aber das mobile Spielen, wo dann alles repräziert wird, jedes Handyspielchen, da sieht es möglicherweise anders aus. Darauf gehe ich jetzt nicht ein, aber das wird auch hier erwähnt, inwieweit bei Sportspielen zum Beispiel die Reichweite enorm vergrößert wurde, dadurch, dass man die jetzt auch für das Smartphone zugänglich machen lassen hat. Das heißt, möglicherweise widerspricht sich das gar nicht, was du da gehört hast, sondern das ist eher dem geschuldet, dass jetzt dann solche Handyspiele oder Spiele, die man sonst noch auf der Konsole spielte, plötzlich auf dem Handy zugänglich sind, dann wiederum mehr Spieler bringen. Die Spiele in den Top Ten nach den durchschnittlichen, monatlichen, aktiven Usern sind im Durchschnitt über 7 Jahre alt. Also die Top Ten ist beherrscht von Spielen, die durchschnittlich 7 Jahre alt sind. Fortnite, Minecraft, Roblox hatten wir auch schon mal hier, Sims, das wird gespielt auf der Playstation, auf der Xbox, wo auch immer. Das ist also etwas, was wirklich ganz signifikant ist. Leute spielen alte Spiele oder bleiben dauerhaft bei einem alten Spiel und das wird ja immer wieder auch geupdated. Also was ganz wichtig ist, sind diese Pay-to-play-Spiele, die man abonniert hat und dort gibt es dann ja auch immer wieder Erweiterungen und all das. Aber man bleibt einem Spiel treu. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen vergleichbar mit man ist Fußballfan von einem Verein und dem bleibt man treu. Da wechseln die Spieler und gibt es neuen Trainer, aber eigentlich bleibt alles gleich. Die durchschnittliche Spielzeit ist aber tatsächlich gesunken jetzt bei den Konsolen. Das ist auch sehr klar, wenn Leute zu Hause sind im Lockdown, können die viel mehr spielen, als wenn sie jetzt unterwegs sind oder ins Büro müssen. Mehr als 60% der Spielzeit zwischen 2022 und 2023 entfällt auf Titel, die sechs Jahre und älter sind. Also 60% der Spielzeit. Wenn ein neues Spiel veröffentlicht wird, das sich auf ein Originalspiel bezieht, also wir es mit einem Remake zu tun haben, steigen die Originalspielzeiten extrem an. Also alle spielen dann nochmal vorher das alte Spiel. Mehr als 60% der Spielzeit entfiehlt auf Franchises mit jährlichen Veröffentlichungen. Also wir haben da eine ähnliche Struktur wie im Kino. Ein Franchise jagt das andere.
Wenn man das jetzt vergleicht mit den Zahlen vorher vom Buchmarkt. Die Leute, ja es gibt so ein paar neue Bücher, aber das nimmt man dann so als Spielwiese. Eigentlich kauft man die guten alten Bekannten. Man verschenkt irgendwelche Bücher und das sind dann auch alte. Eigentlich sind dieser ganze Medienbetrieb wahnsinnig alt, oder? Die Bücher sind alt, die Filme sind alt, also die Filmidänen, es kommt dann einfach so ein... Die Computerspiele jetzt auch.
Neue Titel machen 8% der gesamten Spielzeit im Jahr 2023 aus. Das ist doch unfassbar. 48 der richtig. Erfolgreichen Spiele waren von den 45 kostenpflichtige Live-Play-to-pay-Spiele. Ja, es gibt dann noch einige differenzierte Aufdrösungen, was dann so genau gespielt wird. Was vielleicht noch interessant ist, weil wir jetzt eben über Verlage und hier sprechen wir über Publisher reden. Wir sehen, dass im Laufe der Zeit immer weniger Publisher einen übergroßen Anteil des Engagements für sich beanspruchen. In jedem Monat des Jahres 2023 beherrschten zwischen 28 und 34 Publishern 80 Prozent der monatlichen aktiven User. Das heißt, diese Publisher-Zahl nimmt immer weiter ab. Es waren einmal mehr und es sind also immer weniger Akteure, die immer mehr Spieler und Spielzeit auf sich vereinen. Das heißt also, wir haben da auch eine Oligopolbildung und da sind wir wahrscheinlich erst noch am Anfang. Wenn man sich bei der Buchbranche das ansieht, da sind das da in den USA noch fünf, sechs Player, über die man spricht. Mehr gibt es gar nicht. Auch in Deutschland hat sich das sehr konzentriert. Das bedeutet aber auch bei diesen Konzentrationen immer auch, dass nur noch wenig Neues versucht wird. Man setzt immer mehr auf alte Titel, Prominenz, Markennamen. Das also auch hier in der Gaming-Welt, die gewiss vielfältig ist. Man ist de facto damit zu tun hat, dass nur noch ganz wenig Kreativität auch monetarisierbar ist. Das heißt also, die Leute, die tatsächlich da sich eine Pluralität in der Gaming-Industrie wünschen, die werden eher bitter enttäuscht sein, wenn sie jetzt diesen Report verfolgen.
Ja, also dieser Gaming-Markt, ich habe noch so im Hinterkopf, als ich damals Redaktionsschluss schrieb, dass die sehr viel Hoffnung auf den europäischen mobilen Gaming-Markt setzen, weil sie gesehen haben, dass in Japan sehr viel mehr gespielt wird und pro Nase zehnmal mehr Umsatz. Also da ist man dann einfach bereit, Konsolenpreise oder so zu bezahlen. Also ich weiß nicht genau, wahrscheinlich ist das auch alles so mit Abos und so, aber...
Ja, Abo ist das Entscheidende. Also es gibt ja ganz viele Spiele jetzt auch, die man sich gratis runterladen kann. Und da, wo es Spaß macht, kostet es Geld.
Genau, auf dem Smartphone lange so... Ne, das Smartphone darf gerne 1000 Euro kosten, aber eine App für 2, 99 Euro kauf ich nicht. Also waren die Spielpreise alles so ein bisschen... Dann wurde man so reingetrickst in, ja, dann bezahlt auch so nach und nach. Aber irgendwie hat man in Japan den Bogen geschlagen, dass man da sehr viel mehr Geld umsetzt. Und in Japan spielen auch alle diese Rollenspiele irgendwie. Also alle haben irgendwelche Agentenfiguren, mit denen sie durch irgendwelche Welten tappeln. Das war auch hier noch mal anders. Würde mich auch mal interessieren, ob das demnächst mal so wandert. Ob man dann sehr viel mehr Gamer, die mit dem Smartphone beim Pendeln in der Bahn sitzen und sich gerade in andere Welten träumen und dann wo auch immer virtuell unterwegs sind. Und mit unterwegs, meine ich, so richtig unterwegs zu Fuß durch eine Landschaft gehen. Unser Lieblingsthema Inflation, was hat es mit dir auf sich? Prognosen für geldpolitische Entscheidungen und Kommunikation bei der Bank of England, ein Überblick. Ben Bernanke wurde also im Juni 2023 beauftragt, unabhängig zu überprüfen, wie gut die Prognosequalität der Bank of England ist. Und am 12. April wurde jetzt dieser Text veröffentlicht, Kurzfassung, Aufbau und Pflege einer hochwertigen Infrastruktur für Prognose und Analysen, Bereitstellung eines Prognoseverfahrens, das ist die Entscheidungsfindung des MPC, das ist das Gremium, das über zum Beispiel Inflation dann einfach festlegt, was die, wie auch beim Wirtschaftswachstum diese Zahlen dann nennt, Verwendung der Prognosen und so weiter. Also es geht hier so richtig ins Eingemachte. Die Bank stand so richtig blank da, wie viele anderen Banken auch, und haben gesehen, oh, wir haben hier, also wir lagen einfach komplett daneben. Können wir überhaupt noch irgendwelche Politikberatungen machen, sodass die dann eine Entscheidungsfindung haben oder allgemeine Aussagen treffen? Und er hat sich dann dazu verleiten lassen, 60 Interviews mit Einzelpersonen und kleinen Gruppen zu führen, an Arbeitsessen teilzunehmen, auf allen Ebenen des höheren Dienstes dort mal kurz vorbei zu schneien, zusätzlich mit britischen Print- und Rundfunkjournalisten, Finanzmarkteilnehmern und anderen britischen Prognostikern zu reden, Akademiker und Wirtschaftswissenschaftler hat er auch noch konsultiert, zusätzlich alle Vorsitzenden der zuständigen parlamentarischen Ausschüsse im Unterhaus und Oberhaus. Also wirklich ganz breit und der Text ist auch 150 Seiten lang. Er sagt auch, wir machen hier einen großen internationalen Vergleich, also die Bank of England gegen die Fed in Amerika, die EZB, die Reserve Bank of New Zealand, Bank of Canada und die Norges Bank in Norwegen plus Schweden, die Sveriges Riksbank. Kurzfassung da, alle haben dasselbe Problem, aber nützt uns ja auch nichts zu sagen, alle sind blind, wenn alle blind sind. Naja, es gibt diesen Ausschuss für Geldpolitik, diesen MPC, Monetary Policy Committee, den stellt er auch noch mal ausführlich vor, also der hat neun Mitglieder, fünf interne, vier externe. Und die externen sind auch mit Absicht extern, das sind nicht mal alles britische Staatsbürger, weil es um die Förderung größerer Denkvielfalten geht. Also man hat sich wirklich Mühe gegeben hier mit möglichst großen, und man sieht ja auch, welche Ansprechpartner er so brauchte, wie da so eine Inflationsprognose zustande kommt. Die Bank dort hat ja dieselben Mandate wie auch die EZB, also es ist dieses 2%-Ziel plus. Ne, in dem Falle kein Plus, also die Bank of England macht dieses 2%-Ziel vor allem. Und wir wollen uns einfach nur mal die beiden Grafik angucken, auf die es drauf ankommt. Also Inflation. Wir sehen hier, ich zeig's dir, die Inflation der letzten Jahre ab 2015. Du siehst also, jede Farbe ist eine Bank, und dann haben die einfach das 2%-Ziel und sehen, die Inflation ist ja auch bei 2%, was soll schon sein. Und dann kommt aber die Inflation und geht hier zum Beispiel in England am höchsten auf 11%. Also je nach Warenkorb oder so. Aber wir haben ja alle so einen 10%-Inflationsspike jetzt gehabt. So, also das ist die Ausgangslage. Wir haben viele Jahre Ruhe, und dann kommt Pandemie und Krieg und eine riesige Inflation. In der zweiten Grafik haben wir jetzt die Prognosefehler. Also wir haben eine Inflation und dann haben wir eine Prognose der Inflation. Und hier wird jetzt die Fehlerhaftigkeit in dieser Prognose gezeigt. Was bedeutet? Wir sehen also, wenn die Inflation ruhig ist, ist der Prognosefehler genau bei Null. Also die Inflationsrate ist bei 2% und der Prognosefehler ist bei Null. Der Graph entwickelt sich also genauso wie bei der anderen Grafik, also einfach nur zwei Etagen tiefer, weil das eines ja hat 2% Inflation und 0% Abweichung. Und dann kommt die 10%ige Inflation und die Fehler in der Prognose. Und die Fehler sind einfach eins zu eins genauso groß wie die Inflation. Ach so, ich dachte, das sei jetzt gerade, okay, das ist einfach nur noch mal. Man hat gar nicht vorausgesehen, was da passiert.
Man muss das sagen, es sieht aus, als sei es einfach zweimal die gleiche Grafik. Aber das ist es nicht, sondern einmal ist es die Prognose und einmal ist es die tatsächliche Inflation.
Es ist die gleiche Grafik, aber sie sagt halt unterschiedliches aus. Das eine sagt, okay, wenn die Inflation zwei ist, sagt ihr, wir prognostizieren eine Inflation von zwei, also die Abweichung ist null. Wenn die Inflation zwölf ist, dann sagt die, ja, Inflation prognostizieren wir auf zwei Prozent, das heißt, die Abweichung ist zehn. Also so wie man in ruhigen Zeiten einfach genau die Prognose sieht und nicht abweicht mit der Prognose von der tatsächlichen Inflation, weicht man danach genauso ab. Also man hat einfach gar nichts vorausgesehen.
Niemand weiß etwas.
Niemand weiß etwas. Und jetzt sagt Bernanke, das Problem ist wirklich ein ganz besonderes Problem. Es hat ihn wirklich alle handwerklichen Mittel zerhauen, denn es gibt jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten oder es gibt zwei Prognosen, die gemacht werden. Das eine ist jährliche. Also das kennt man ja in Deutschland. Geradischer Wirtschaftsweisen gibt eine Prognose ab für das Wirtschaftswachstum im kommenden Jahr. Er schaut also ein Jahr voraus. Und dann gibt es noch relativ kurzfristige Prognosen. Die machen nur eine vierteljährige Voraussicht. Die vierteljährige Voraussicht weicht nun nicht allzu sehr davon ab, sondern man sieht immer noch bei Schweden, die sind auch mal so 4% Abweichungen. Aber bei einer 12% echten Inflation hat man sich um ein Drittel verschätzt. Die anderen liegen dann bei dieser kurzfristigen, quartalsweisen Voraussicht doch relativ nah. Und jetzt könnte man ja denken, okay, das ist nicht uninteressant, so kann man wenigstens einen Monat vorausschauen. Nur, um einen Monat vorauszuschauen, brauchst du nichts außer gesunden Menschenverstand. Du legst nämlich einfach das Lineal ans letzte Jahr und ziehst die Linie fort. Also du plottest einfach nur die Vergangenheit allein aufgrund der Erfahrung, des geschichtlich geschriebenen Wissens, wie war denn die Inflation. Das heißt, die Banken haben jetzt flächendeckend festgestellt, dass sie nicht prognostizieren können. Sie können nur kurzfristig das Wetter vorhersagen. Also diese Woche war es jeden Tag 20 Grad. Mal gucken, was es am Montag ist. Wahrscheinlich 20 Grad. Aber sie können eben nicht einen Monat später. Weil dann ist ja schon wieder eine neue Wetterlage. Da könnte es 30 oder 10 Grad sein, je nachdem. Und das fand ich doch erstaunlich, dass hier die große Aufarbeitung von Bernanke ist, dass man aus diesem, ja, wir können ein Quartal plotten, aufgrund, wir ziehen einfach die historische Entwicklung, wie sie ist, fort, keine Rückschlüsse auf weitergehende Zukunft macht und auch keine weiteren handwerklichen Mittel hat, um das zu machen. Ich fand ja diesen ECB-Text schon, wo sie so ein bisschen auf Wehrheimheit Pech verwiesen haben. Aber dass sie hier einfach wirklich sagen, wir sind nicht alleine betroffen. Und es geht einfach nicht. Jedes Mal, wenn man jetzt hört, Wirtschaftsweisen haben gesagt, nächstes Jahr ist Wirtschaftswachstum so und so. Und dann kommt irgendein Politiker und sagt, deswegen machen wir mal das und das. Dann sagen, good luck. Das ist alles Fantasie im Grunde. Man hofft dann einfach. Fand ich wirklich erstaunlich. Ich wollte noch mal diesen Satz, der hat es dann auch. Prognosen für ein Quartal im Voraus sind... Es sei daran erinnert, dass bei der Bank of England, wie bei den meisten Zentralbanken, sehr kurzfristige Prognosen meist durch Extrapolation der verfügbaren Daten und verschiedensten statistischen Modelle erstellt werden, denen die längerfristige Prognose entsprechen muss. Aufgrund ihrer rückwärtsgerichteten Komponenten erfordern diese Prognosen auch die Vorwegnahme der Revision der vergangenen Daten. Also man blickt überhaupt nur in die Vergangenheit und macht keinen paradigmatischen, prinzipiellen Aussagen, man errechnet nichts, sondern wie gesagt, man liegt linear an die Temperaturentwicklung und dann fällt es irgendwann auseinander. Das kennt man ein bisschen bei Kachelmann-Wetter. Da hat man ja auch, wie wird es die nächsten zwei Wochen? Und am Anfang geht es los und dann wird dieser Korridor der Möglichkeiten immer größer. Also Prognosen für ein Quartal im Voraus sind daher nicht besonders repräsentativ für die Prognoseverfahren der Zentralbanken im Allgemeinen. Weil einfach nur sagen, es war jetzt drei Monate so, also wird es nächsten Monat so, das kann jeder. Aber das, was die Zentralbanken eigentlich machen wollen, weiter in die Zukunft schauen, klappt einfach nicht. Und das, was hier für die Inflation gesagt wird, gilt natürlich dann auch für BIP-Wachstum. Also den Text kann man in den nächsten 30 Seiten zum BIP-Wachstum lesen. Das ist, finde ich, auf Augenhöhe mit dieser Erkenntnis aus China. Ach so, wir haben uns ganz grob verrechnet bei der Demografie. Wir haben doch eine Million pro Jahrgang weniger. Ach so, aber darauf beruht doch wirklich alles, was ihr gerade macht. Ja, schon. Deswegen ist das auch ein Problem. Sagen wir mal lieber nichts mehr dazu, so ungefähr. Also wir haben es hier doch mit erheblichen, wie soll man sagen, prinzipiellen Problemen zu tun, bei denen ich nicht sagen würde, es ist jetzt ein Megaproblem, dass sie das nicht prognostizieren können. Sondern es ist ein Problem, dass wir relativ viele Institutionen darauf gebaut haben, dass da Erwartungen hergestellt werden.
Ja, die ganze Zinspolitik basiert ja darauf. Und unsere Rezession ist dann auch deshalb da, weil die irgendwas prognostizieren, was sie überhaupt nicht eintrifft.
Was sie einfach nicht wissen können. Ja, also die Zinsentscheidungen der letzten zwei Jahre sind wahrscheinlich wirklich, die sollte man nochmal anders aufarbeiten. Und demnächst dann anders treffen. Also nochmal einen Sprung von 4, 5 Prozent oder sowas. Das darf wirklich nicht passieren.
Was kann man tun, wenn man nicht weiß, was eigentlich los ist? Man kann so tun, als wisse man es ganz genau. Damit sind wir bei dem Text von Hans Kundnani über den Berliner Blob. Was ist das für ein merkwürdiger Begriff? Was will dieser Senior Research Fellow beim Shetham House in London uns sagen? Er sagt, Einseitigkeit und Gruppendenken kennzeichnen oft die außenpolitische Sicherheitsblase. In Deutschland ist dies besonders stark ausgeprägt. Und dieser Begriff Blob, also B-L-O-B, geht zurück auf Ben Rhodes. Er war außenpolitischer Berater bei Obama. Er ist eigentlich auch Teil des Problems. Wollen wir jetzt aber nicht darauf eingehen. Er hat dann ein Buch geschrieben, das den Titel The World As It Is hat. Und da sagt er, Blob ist so eine gallantartige, schleimige Masse. Und damit ist jenes Gruppendenken gemeint, Zitat Rhodes, das scheinbar stets unweigerlich zu weiteren militärischen Interventionen im Nahen Osten führe. Dazu, irgendetwas zu bombardieren. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir aus unseren Think-Tanks gut kennen. Bombardiert mal irgendwas. Das wird bestimmt gut sein. Jetzt schreibt Kundnani, manche Blobs sind blobbiger als andere. Und der Berliner Blob, so scheint mir, ist vielleicht der blobbigste von allen. In Washington wird das Group-Think-Problem immerhin bis zu einem gewissen Grad durch Parteidenken eingedämmt. Und das ist jetzt interessant. Dadurch, dass Demokraten und Republikaner sich notwendigerweise als Oppositionen gegenüberstehen müssen, sind auch die Denkfabriken angehalten, Gegenpositionen zu beziehen. Zugleich entsteht dadurch aber auch zwischen diesen Denkfabriken ein Austausch, bzw. ein Wettstreit der guten Ideen. Und man arbeitet dadurch eher faktenbasiert. Er schreibt jetzt in Deutschland, ist die politische Kultur im Gegensatz dazu stärker Konsens-orientiert und der Group-Think-Gefahr deshalb noch akuter ausgesetzt als in den USA. Weiter heißt es, dass außenpolitische Eliten tendenziell ähnlich denken, hat eine Kehrseite. Sie koppeln sich gedanklich in gewisser Weise von dem ab, was die Allgemeinheit über außenpolitische Fragen denkt. Denkfabrikler teilen eine Reihe von Grundannahmen, die auch weitgehend mit dem Blob in anderen Ländern, zumindest im Westen, übereinstimmen. Von den gänzlich anderen Interessen und Präferenzen der Normalbevölkerung im eigenen Land sind sie aber oftmals abgeschnitten. Und das können wir ja ganz deutlich sehen, wenn alle deutschen sicherheitspolitischen Denkfabriken sagen, mehr Waffen liefern, Taurus, los damit. Und man dann sieht in Umfragen, dass das sich gar nicht deckt mit der Meinung in der Bevölkerung.
Vor allem alle Welt liefert Panzer außer Deutschland. Und dann liefert Deutschland, und plötzlich sind es die einzigen und die ersten, die jemals Panzer geliefert haben.
Solche Dinge, ja.
Also diese Entkopplung deutscher Debatten auch auf ökonomischen Felder und so, ist ja wirklich immer wieder beeindruckend.
Deutschlands außenpolitische Eliten, vor allem die, die sich mit Sicherheitspolitik beschäftigen wollen, unbedingt, dass Deutschland sich strategischer verhält. In der europäischen Sicherheitspolitik eine Führungsrolle übernimmt, mehr Geld für Verteidigung ausgibt und bereit ist, seine militärischen Fähigkeiten zu nutzen und ähnliche Dinge. Die deutsche Öffentlichkeit steht alldem jedoch ziemlich skeptisch gegenüber, schreibt er hier. Politiker wie Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz, die zwangsläufig engeren Kontakt mit der Öffentlichkeit haben, werden von Denkfabrikeln häufig dafür kritisiert, dass sie der öffentlichen Meinung folgen, statt zu führen. Das ist ja das, was jetzt überkommt. Der ist so führungsschwach, der zaudert. Also das ist, die Denkfabrikler denken sich das aus und sagen, ja, mir doch egal, dass wir in einer Demokratie leben. Das muss doch alles genauso sein. Interessant ist ja nun, dass die Denkfabrikler heute, die sagen, der Scholz soll mal führen und mal wirklich konfrontativ auftreten gegen China und Russland, meist dieselben Denkfabrikler sind, die damals noch die Merkel-Außenpolitik begleitet haben. Und damals genau die Merkel damals sagten ja, jetzt ist gerade das Mainstream, also machen wir das zu Mainstream. Das heißt, hier bevor der Krieg in der Ukraine begann, verteidigten viele deutsche Denkfabrikler Angela Merkels Außenpolitik. Das heißt, sie teilten die gängige Meinung, solange sie gängige Meinung war. Doch nach Russlands Einmarsch in die Ukraine im Februar 22 wurden sie auf einen Schlag allesamt zu Hardlinern. Und inzwischen sehen sie ihre Aufgabe scheinbar darin, diejenigen zu attackieren, die außenpolitisch nicht auf dieser Linie sind, vor allem sozialdemokratische Politiker. Die bekommen es ja knüppeldig ab. Und das wird ja dann nochmal so widergespiegelt, dass wir Karen Mioszka sehen, wie sie Lars Klingmeier ins Gebet nimmt, dass er doch erkennen muss, welche Stunde jetzt geschlagen hat. Und zwar die, die die Denkfabrikler geschlagen haben. Ja, und so kommt es dann hier, das Absurde an der Kampagne des Berliner Blob, zur Befreiung des Leoparden, war nicht nur, dass er sich leicht hin auf eine so eng begrenzte Frage, wie den Einsatz eines bestimmten Waffensystems fokussierte, als hänge davon der Ausgang des ganzen Krieges ab. Und dass er damit zu der Ernüchterung beitrug, die sich einstellte, als die Panzer schließlich zum Einsatz kamen, und klar wurde, dass sie nicht die von vielen erhoffte Wende brachten, sondern auch, dass diese Kampagne zur Stimmungsmache geriet und Analysen Mangelware wurden. Eine führende Vertreterin, ich weiß nicht, wer das ist, wüsste es aber gern, eine führende Vertreterin eines deutschen Außenpolitik-Thinktanks regte sogar an. Sie und ihre Kolleginnen sollten bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz allesamt Kleidung mit Leopardenmuster tragen. Ja, und dann noch hier eine Anmerkung zu Nahost. Es ist schwer zu sagen, ob dieses dröhnende Schweigen über Israels Vorgehen auf Überzeugung beruht, also dass Deutschland belegungslos unterstützen soll, oder auf Feilkeit. Man hat Angst, sich anders zu diesem Thema zu positionieren. Aber es wird gewiss dann wohl wieder zu schwerwiegenden Fehleinschätzungen kommen.
Oh je, mein letzter Text ist aus The Nature. Sie hat ihn veröffentlicht, kostenlos für alle. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Textpolitik so ist, aber manchmal kann man einfach so reinlesen. Das wirtschaftliche Engagement für den Klimawandel heißt es hier von drei Autoren, die Folgendes unternommen haben. Sie haben empirische Erkenntnisse für mehr als 1600 Regionen der Welt über 40 Jahre ausgewertet. Ich nenne sie nachher nur mal so namentlich einige Datensätze, von denen man nie gehört hat, zusammen. Aber man wollte mal eine robuste untere Grenze für die Auswirkungen auf das Wirtschaftswachstum durch den Klimawandel definieren. Also in Zahlen ausgedrückt, was kostet uns das denn alles nun? Und hat deswegen die Weltwirtschaft der nächsten 26 Jahre genommen. Also man will so ein bisschen das Jahr 2050 mal umrahmen und stellt hier fest, bei den Emissionsentscheidungen, wie man sie jetzt getroffen hat, muss man mit einem globalen Einkommensrückgang von 19% rechnen. Die Spanne ist 11 bis 29% und die wahrscheinlichste Ziellage ist dann 19% minus. Die sich allerdings unterschiedlich verteilen, ist ja klar. Also es geht um Schäden, die eintreten durch Wetterveränderungen oder was auch immer in Folge der 2°-Erwärmung. Diese Schäden übersteigen bereits in diesem kurzfristigen Zeitrahmen, die zur Begrenzung der globalen Erwärmung auf 2% erforderlichen Minderungskosten um das Sechsfache. Also eine Entscheidung, jetzt rein zu investieren, dass es nicht zu dieser Klimaerwärmung kommt, wäre sechsmal billiger, aber müsste halt jetzt gemacht werden. Statt in Christian Lindner Logik. Nee, das muss erst erwirtschaftet werden. Und dann kann man das ausgeben. Wir können auf gar keinen Fall einen Kredit aufnehmen dafür.
Kinder zu investieren, ist immer wirtschaftlich besser, als erst einmal aus dem Kind einen missratenen Erwachsenen zu machen und das dann wieder einzuhägen mit viel Geld.
Was Hänzchen nicht lernt, lernt Hans nimmer mehr. Also früh anfangen. Ich würde sagen, unter unserer Maßgabe hier, wurde auch wieder Zeit auf spezielle Weise codiert. Also der Faktor 6 hat nur auf der Zeitdimension wird das ausgespielt. Weil sachlich und so ist das ja alles geregelt. Nun ja, diese Verluste werden für alle Regionen prognostiziert, außer ein paar, die in hohen Breitengraden sind. Wir kennen ja die Diskussion, Trump will Grönland kaufen und so, weil das taut ja dann auf. Und dann hat man da Ackerland, den es vorher nicht gab. Also das sind so kleine Gewinne. Aber es ist doch ein flächendeckender globaler Verlust. Und man hatte nun hier Fortschritte in der Klimaökonomie, die also diese weltweiten Beobachtungen des Klimas und die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung mal zusammenbringt. Sie weisen natürlich noch darauf hin, das sind hier Projektionen, keine Vorhersagen, sondern man projiziert einfach die exogenen Auswirkungen künftiger Klimabedingungen auf die Wirtschaft. Also man geht von der prognostizierten Weltwirtschaftsentwicklung aus. Da, wo heute Autofirmen sind, sind sie auch noch unter 30 Jahren aus in Deutschland, da sind sie dann in Schleswig-Holstein. Aber solche Sachen, eingepreist, guckt man sich einfach, wie jetzt die, wie ein eingepreister Klimawandel aussähe, der sich notgedrungen zunehmend zwingend einpreist. Noch kann man ja einfach die Kosten raushauen und muss sie nicht weiter beachten. Aber spätestens, wenn dann der Regen fällt im Ahrtal und so weiter, dann hat man einfach Rechnung zu bezahlen. Diese globale Verteilung der Einkommensreduzierung ist natürlich ungleich, also 19% weltweit, Nordamerika und Europa 11%, Südasien und Afrika 22%. Was wieder bedeutet, diese Losung hatten wir ja in dem Buch das nomadische Jahrhundert, ein Grad mehr Klimaerwärmung bedeutet eine Milliarde mehr Flüchtlinge. Und ein nächstes Grad, eine nächste Milliarde. Also wenn die ökonomischen Verwerfungen durch den Klimawandel so sind, dass die Südasiaden und die afrikanischen Länder doppelt so viel davon betroffen sind als wir, dann bedeutet das automatisch Migrationsdruck. Da muss man dann einfach nur eins plus eins rechnen und deswegen steht es ja hier auch dran. Die globalen jährlichen Schäden bis im Jahr 2049 summieren sich auf 38 Billionen und jetzt nennen sie den internationalen Dollar 2005. Also es gibt wohl irgendwie so eine Standard-Einheit, der Dollar von 2005 und so. Aber 38 Billionen, da würde ich sagen, die Einheit mal egal, wenn wir vom deutschen Jahresbib rechnen, dann sind das vier. Und hier geht es um nahezu 40. Nehmen wir jetzt irgendwelche Umrechnungsmodalitäten dazu, dann ist das Faktor 10 von Deutschland. Also die drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt wird mal 10 als ökonomische Verwerfung in die Welt eingerechnet. Und zwar nur durch die Klimaschäden. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Es sind ganz gruseligere Zahlen, die man hier bekommt. Sie haben dann einige Grafen, wo man auch mal sieht, wie unterschiedlich Amerika relativ sanft, Zentrales, Südamerika ganz schrecklich, Afrika wirklich düster, Saudi-Arabische Halbinsel da unten. Also Katastrophe eigentlich. Man hat dann so eine Grenze, irgendwo Sibirien oben. Da wird es hier als blau eingezeichnet. Das sind aber die Gebiete. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, da kann man gut leben. Und das ist auch relativ viel Platz. Wobei das sieht ja nur hier nach viel Platz aus. Sobald man die Grafik als Globus darstellt, sieht man, Afrika ist der Riese gebrocken. Also Afrika ist halb so groß wie die Welt von der Fläche her. Da nützt es uns gar nichts, die Möglichkeit zu haben, drei Milliarden Menschen nach Sibirien zu verfrachten, damit sie sich da ein neues Leben aufbauen. Weil das sind ja dann nicht mal mehr Generationenaufgaben. Sowas geht einfach gar nicht. Also es gibt hier keinen Ausweg aus dem, was hier klimaökonometrisch errechnet wurde. Und der Methodenteil ist wirklich, ich will nicht sagen interessant, aber hier kann man mal illustrativ so ein bisschen nachlesen, was zu Gelte kommt. Also, die historisch täglichen 2 Meter Temperatur-Niederschlag-Summen, also welche Temperatur gab es auf 2 Meter Höhe und wie viel Niederschlag fiel, von 1979 bis 2019 steht in der W5E5-Datenbank. Die wird dann kombiniert mit der Version 2 des Watch-Forcing-Data-auf-Ära-5-Reanalysedatensystems. Dann kommt dann noch die Version 2.3 des Global Precipitation Climatology Projects hinzu. Außerdem hat man natürlich die Datenbank des Intersectoral Impact Model Intercomparison Projects und so. Also so geht es hier. Das CMIP6, die eSIMIP-Datenbank, Dose-Datenbank. Dann hat man nochmal in diesen Dose-Datensatz Daten für 83 Länder und 1660 subnationale Regionen einzeln aufgeschlüsselt, meistens verfügbar von 1960 bis 2019. Also hier wurde groß gearbeitet.
Und da stimme ich dir natürlich zu, man muss nicht alles wissen, um Dinge verstehen zu können. Ich vertraue jetzt Nature, aber ich muss in der Lage sein, den Artikel entweder mir jetzt hier von dir zusammenfassen und das zu verstehen, oder ich muss in der Lage sein, ihn zu lesen und daraus Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen. Aber die Debatte fängt jetzt nicht wieder an. Und was würde man dann wählen, wenn man den Artikel gelesen und verstanden hat? Dann wird es nämlich wieder sehr kompliziert. Nun ja, es wird teuer. Ich will nicht mit einem guten Ausblick enden, sondern eher mit etwas pessimistischen von netzpolitik.org. Da hat Markus Reuter über das neue EGH-Urteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung geschrieben. Der Europäische Gerichtshof hat in einem Urteil die Zulässigkeit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung von IP-Adressen erheblich ausgeweitet. Nicht nur sagt das Gericht in seiner Pressemitteilung, dass die allgemeine und unterschiedslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung von IP-Adressen nicht zwangsläufig einen schwerwiegenden Eingriff in die Grundrechte darstelle, sondern sieht auch deren Erhebung zur Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen als rechtmäßig an. Es gibt ein französisches Antipirateriesystem, Hadoopie. Dagegen wurde geklagt. Es gibt auch einen Gastbeitrag, den kann man auch mal lesen, bei netzpolitik.org von La Quartature du Net, einer französischen Organisation, die vielleicht ein bisschen vergleichbar ist mit einem Chaos-Computer-Club oder so etwas. Also auch so ein Digital Rights Club, der sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat. Und es ist jetzt so, dass diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung zulässig sein soll, wenn, so heißt es da, die Nationale Regelung Speichermodalitäten vorschreibt, die eine wirksame, strikte Trennung der verschiedenen Kategorien personenbezogener Daten gewährleisten und es damit ausschließen, dass genaue Schlüsse auf das Privatleben der betreffenden Personen gezogen werden können. Reuterschätzt das so ein, das Gericht hat bislang eigentlich so eine anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung deutlich abgelehnt. Jetzt scheint sich das aber immer weiter auszuweiten, bzw. ist man jetzt von dieser Linie abgegangen. Es wird hier dann auch la quadratur du net zitiert. Mit diesem neuen Urteil wird der Zugriff auf IP-Adressen nicht mehr standardmäßig als schwerwiegender Eingriff in die Grundrechte angesehen. Infolgedessen lässt der Gerichtshof die Möglichkeit einer Massenüberwachung des Internets zu. Es geht hier also offenbar vor allem darum, dass Urheberrechtsverletzungen stärker verfolgt werden können. Wir werden also gespannt sein, was das noch für Folgen dann haben wird. Da sehe ich auch wieder große Möglichkeiten für Abmahnanwälte und was da so alles ankommt. Es ist keine gute Entwicklung. Vielleicht müssen wir das mal größer im regulären Teil unseres Podcasts behandeln.
Bisher war es ja so, dass man sich immer darauf verlassen konnte, irgendwer macht ein Quatschgesetz und dann zerhaut es der EUGH. Und jetzt offenbar nicht mehr so in voller Breite.
Wir werden dann, das können wir jetzt nochmal sagen, wir haben es ja schon ein paar Mal angekündigt, im nächsten Salon das Buch zu Geopolitik, Außenpolitik von Richard David Precht lesen.
Wie wird das denn heißen und wann kommt es genau?
Ich habe den Titel noch nicht präsent. Es wird Ende Mai erscheinen, d.h. dazu pünktlich für die Salon-Lektüre dann.
Also online steht Richard David Precht, das Jahr der Toleranz. Man kann jetzt so ein bisschen an diesem Baum sehen.
Das Jahrhundert der Toleranz.
Jahrhundert der Toleranz.
Also ein Jahr, vielleicht ein bisschen wenig.
Das Jahrhundert der Toleranz. Plädoyer für eine wertgerechte Außenpolitik und es ist ein Baum drauf mit verschiedenen Flakkenblättern. Ein kleiner Traum-Zauberbaum. Wir sind gespannt. Steht hier noch ein Datum.
Ja, Ende Mai.
30.05.
Prima.